[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun
wins that is a losing move
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Geary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps Mr Tara
leads Viking Zay he is already a legend
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
this is the 11th round of the Tata steel
Chess Masters 2023 I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me my good friend
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski Donya 10
rounds in the books we have a clear
leader in Notre back of uttarov what are
you looking forward to today
well Robert good morning to everybody
thank God it's Friday it is Friday right
I always have to double check now and
we've got some amazing matchups today I
can't even begin to tell you what I'm
looking forward to because I could fill
up an entire volume this is going to be
an epic day
it certainly will be in a few days ago
Magnus Carlson he got out of it he
couldn't catch the leaders but things
have changed with some victories in the
last year round so we have a video of
magnus's thoughts in an interview he
gave just a few days ago
no I'm
realizing that there's
[Music]
um
possibilities for for that of course but
most of all I'm taking a further step to
playing a decent tournament and I've
sort of
um Turned turned it around in a good way
so I'm I'm happy with um
with that and obviously it's uh far from
in my hands still but um yeah this was
important and uh I'll keep on trying
you heard it from the world champion
himself he feels A Renewed sense of
possibilities Dania and we see because
of Wednesday's results there's good
reason for it he beat paramaksudu with
the black pieces
that was an incredibly impressive game
and Magnus very typically understated in
that interview he is in the midst of
what might be if he ends up winning this
tournament one of the greatest if not
the greatest uh Invitational Elite
tournament comeback of all time but he
knows that he's got a lot of trials and
tribulations ahead of him as do all of
the other players I was also very
impressed with kukesh who was dejected a
couple of rounds ago but has come back
with two very clutch wins he has no
chances to win the tournament Robert but
it's always great to see the young
players showing that resilience it
looked like he was gonna just be sailing
through from the bottom but he has to
win two of his last three games are good
for good cash as we look at our
leaderboard at the top of the standings
remains nadir Beck Abdul sitarov and we
heard Magnus Carlson say it's out of my
hands Donya and the reason why is
because he already has lost to both
abusotave and giri
and he has lost to Notre back with the
white pieces in fact Notre back has won
three games with black and he's lost
zero it's been a tour de force by the
Uzbek Junior Magnus Geary noterbeck
there is a traffic jam at the top and do
not discount Fabiana carwana in
lebanaroni and if the cards fall a
certain way and they pull off a strong
finish you could see yet another
reshuffling of the top of the tournament
cross table as we get into the last
couple of rounds and Wesley so we'll
play a part in this event he's been
under the radar somehow I feel like
that's what happens with Wesley as we
look forward to today's matchups he is
going to play a big part in determining
who might win the tournament because as
you see at the top there Magnus Carlson
with the white pieces Wesley so with
black
and I don't know if people realize that
Wesley so is not only plus two in this
event but has lost exactly zero games he
has been solid as a rock now perhaps a
little bit too solid for his own taste
and his ultimate trial is going to be
today black against a bloodthirsty
Magnus Carlson who understands the
importance of this game but of course
that is far from the only important
pairing we also have Anish giri against
Notre back abdusitor of another Marquee
matchup and let's not discount some of
the matchups which may not determine
first place but nonetheless are going to
produce some incredibly interesting
chess I'm looking at kymer against
report maybe an end game that kyber will
finally be able to win we'll see levana
Ronin against Fabiana carwana that is a
classic American matchup as well
and you mentioned Richard report he has
had two decisive games in recent rounds
so he is proving that he's ready to
fight the last round before the rest day
wasn't to be he drew against levonne
Roney quickly as it abduces Harvard
dingley Ren so dingling around with the
white pieces down there against Jordan
Von Forest that promises to be an
exciting matchup as will be the match of
Indian teenagers Arjun eragisi with the
white pieces gukesh with black Arjun he
isn't struggling he has not won a game
this tournament so he would like to beat
his compatriot in that game but I think
we should remind everybody that we're
going to be here for the long haul this
tournament is classical chess a hundred
minutes for the first 40 moves probably
50 minutes as they make it to move 60
and then after move 60 they get 15
minutes for the rest of the game 30
second bonus added the game's very first
move so as we've seen in recent rounds
first you had the call in Vincent
kymer's long rookette on ending uh
against their back I had his call
against Jordan Von forest in round 10
these games can last seven plus hours
and what an intensely frustrating
punishing experience to be on the losing
side or to be on the drawing side from a
winning end game you play six and a half
seven hours you put your Blood Sweat and
Tears into the game and your heart goes
out for Vincent kymer for gukesh who sit
there working their tails off for hours
upon hours and when this type of
tournament doesn't go your way well it's
incredibly painful as we have a look at
that beautiful unmistakable playing Hall
Phil to the brim Robert with Spectators
and of course players in the open
section Tata steel I always like to say
is a festival not just a super
tournament
is a festival indeed and somebody who is
probably feeling a bit festive
isotara but he is the black pieces
against that man right there Anish Gary
Anish has had for letting me know
masterful preparation throughout the
tournament he did not win that game
against Arjun aragaisy but even that
game when he had white was one where you
couldn't help but be very impressed by
Anish Geary he is playing uh with gusto
he is ready to take down this tournament
he has yet to win in Vikings a he has
been the runner-up five times but Donna
if he's going to win this year it
happens right now he has the white
pieces against the only player who has
more points than he does
I cannot wait to see what anishkiri will
have in store for us in the opening
first of all the very first move is
unpredictable E4 D4 Geary is armed to
the teeth in virtually every opening but
Notre back in so far as you can talk
about let's not say a weakness but
perhaps a weak spot in this tournament
he has had his share of dubious
positions out of the opening with the
black pieces as well against Argent era
geisi he was quite a bit worse even
though he won that game obviously
against Magnus Carlson he was also
slightly worse so what is Anish giri
going to bring to the table in the first
10 moves
the big question and note everybody he's
thinking about just that at the moment
he is focused he's leaning over the
board even though no moves have been
played and as you said this is a
festival we see Wesley so you know just
waving getting ready for the round but
behind him look at how many people there
they have their phones out taking photos
and videos it's great to see so many
people flock to the Dutch Seaside town
of Vikings a and these two players very
familiar with one another levonaroni
with white I've got a car one with black
indeed they are they faced off most
recently at the previous U.S
championship in St Louis where they made
a rather uneventful draw of honoronian
has been incredibly solid this
tournament it's been a bounce back
performance of sorts after Lavon
struggled mightily in that very same U.S
championship and for Fabiano caruana an
excellent tournament Robert until that
shattering loss with the white pieces
against Magnus Carlson yeah that sort of
took a great tournament to one that's
just decent and the players clappings
announcements are being made and we see
this is the Marquee matchup in the
Masters Tournament Anish giri white in
order to review Sarah black the hands
have been shaken and D4 no surprise
there from a niche but the big question
is what will abdusitarov do
he his repertoire is vast with the black
pieces nimso Indian slav Queen's Gambit
he's already taking a little bit of time
to brace himself he's not really
thinking about what he's gonna play he
knows what he's gonna play he pushes the
Deep on two squares forward the Queen's
on game he's just sort of bracing
himself reminding himself of how
important it is to be composed and fully
focused in this crucial moment Queen's
Gambit will we see a slav queen's gamut
accepted yes we will Queen's gamut
accepted well you are the prophet they
call you that for a reason and as you
were saying qga he said okay why not and
he's a little bit young to be playing
the Queen's Gambit accepted uh this has
been an opening choice that many of the
top players throughout history have
chosen is seen as one where you don't
get the same closed Dynamic that you do
with the Queen's game it declined or
various uh openings but instead he takes
on C4 immediately opening up the queen
so when we do get
an analysis board uh ready we will note
that the queen on d8 has an open line
all the way towards that white Pawn on
D4 so just the qg8 it hands white the
center white has two pawns the D4 pawn
and the E2 Pawn directly to the center
and black only has the E7 Pawn so that's
the trade-off
it is and has for a while been
considered sort of the inferior sibling
between the Queen's gamma declined the
slav and the qg8 the sort of Trifecta of
responses to the Queen's Gambit
oftentimes the Queen's gamut accepted
has a bit of a negative reputation but
uh I don't think it should have have
that reputation especially given all of
the new ideas that have been breathed
into this line in the last couple of
years and there we have it E4 by Anish
Gary the most ambitious response
immediately met with a Counter-Strike in
the center E7 E5 saying take my Pawn I'm
going to take your queen and force your
king out into the open D takes E5 Robert
is out of the question here for white
yeah you don't want to do that because
if you take on E5 as you're saying the
Queens get traded and then black very
quickly develops with Tempo because it
would be even material both sides with a
double Pawn black on C4 white on E5 but
it's just very simple for black you
trade Queens the white king gets stuck
in the center and then the Knight comes
out to C6 and so on so I just think that
for nishikiri right now he plays the
principal move Knight F3 once black
plays e takes D4 oftentimes white
doesn't even take back that pawn on D4
you play Bishop takes C4 instead and if
I'm not mistaken Donya Gary Kasparov
lost a game like this to shop here at
mamajov he's entire from serious chess
but it's a Blitz game and he lost in
like 10 moves yeah it was crazy this was
I think in zagra Blitz tournament quite
recently this is a very dangerous line
for black if he isn't aware of The
Cutting Edge Theory as a check is
delivered on before by notorbeck the
players continuing to Blitz out a
well-known theoretical line no major
surprises here uh Robert but this is not
necessarily the most common guest at the
highest level by the way the world
Champion's still not here
wow okay so we'll dive right back into
this game but we have to note that
Magnus Carlson yet to be seated yet to
make a first move and oh there he is he
just got to the board uh he finally has
made his opening moves so for Wesley so
that can be a bit uncomfortable because
you typically want to shake your
opponent's hand uh start the clock in a
timely manner but Wesley so is not a
player who is phased by anybody
including Magnus Carlsen after all he
took down Magnus in the 2019 Fisher
random World Championship
and of course he won a very minor
tournament I already forget what it's
called the chess.com Global Championship
it was nothing major kind of a
provincial uh amateur tournament Robert
he didn't really beat anyone impressive
that tournament either Wesley so is just
one of those guys who always seems to
fly under the radar yes uh he doesn't
later he has played in a candidate's
term he didn't play in the last one so
people kind of forget about him and then
he kind of hangs around and wins his
fair share of tournaments he sits on
plus two
and he has the power to really change
the course of this tournament we have a
nimso Indian the bishop comes out to B4
and the ball tossed right back into
White's Court which line is the world
champion going to unroll here
well Wesley so reaching in his pocket
maybe for an opening novelty and Bishop
B Ford a common response here there are
several Queen C2 is named very aptly on
my dad at the queen C2 nimzo but there's
also one don't say yeah stop making
stuff up
the queen C2 Nims are the second most
popular line I think E3 is sort of the
standard way to play and Magnus goes
with that and now once black castles the
bishop can slide out to D3 very quickly
the Knight on G1 doesn't necessarily
have to go to F3 even though it often
does it can also slide into E2 in some
variation so it's a little bit more
flexible from White's approach but black
at some point can take on C3 with the
bishop you don't want to do it
unprovoked but that will double White's
pawns there and that actually has been
increasingly popular I feel like Dania
where even without the inclusion of
white playing A2 to A3 black sometimes
just takes on C3 doubles the pawns and
then goes after the double pawns along C
file
and allowing the nimso Indian itself has
seen a surge in popularity in recent
years there was a point five or six
years ago when Knight C3 essentially
became Unthinkable at the highest level
players were playing the Catalan and the
rugosen was all the rage for some reason
maybe it's because of the new engines
life has been breathed into some of
these new nimso variations particularly
the Rubinstein variation which is what
E3 is called a slightly more original
name than the queen C2 variation and
Wesley so immediately counter-strikes
with the move C5 not the most common
response to E3 the most popular is
simply to Castle kingside and to reserve
the right to push the Deep on or push
the Steep on but Wesley chooses to push
the C Pawn straight away of course this
is also a very well-known continuation
wait did you know that the queen C2 Nims
was called the classical variation
it is yeah I really just thought it was
that's just the opening Explorer is
telling me I always thought it was just
called the queen T2 nimso
we Institute him so is what I thought it
was called new things every day uh so do
I it's a bit you know classical
variation I don't want to hear that but
that's neither here nor there because we
have uh in this opportunity Huebner
variation I didn't know that's what that
was called either I don't know the names
of openings but C5 does make perfect
sense you're striking at White Center
and white has several options at this
point you can develop your Bishop to D3
uh you played E3 for a reason you could
also develop your knight first either to
F3 or to E2 directly and playing Knight
E2 looks wrong because you're blocking
in your own Bishop but what you are
doing is protecting that Knight on C3 so
that if black has any ideas of capturing
that night you take back with the other
Knight and keeping your Pawn structure
intact so uh these early decisions they
may seem just like preparation that the
players have studied this and know it
very deeply and that may be true but
it's all about the direct direction that
you want to take this game so Magnus has
a big Choice as early as move 5 here
and he is not shy about taking his time
that it is possible that he did not
expect the move C5 that he expected
Wesley uh to follow the main course in
Castle kingside and of course Magnus is
fully aware of the options on the table
but you're absolutely right he's not
just deciding on the next move he just
he's deciding on the type of position
that you want to get because Knight F3
Knight E2 they might seem
interchangeable they might seem similar
but Robert the type of position you get
after each of these moves actually could
not be more different in fact when black
takes on C3 and white recaptures with a
B Pawn that's one structure if white
plays Knight 92 that's a completely
different ballpark so a big big decision
here coming up for Magnus
it is and Magnus Carlson he has a very
good lifetime record against Wesley so
so if we look at their head to head it
is quite a sizeable lead five wins for
Magnus just one win for Wesley 13 games
have been drawn I think the most
surprising aspect of that Donya is that
they haven't actually played each other
that much that's only 19 games in
classical chess we've seen Lavon aronia
and Magnus Carlson play something like
70 times so these two just haven't found
themselves across from one another all
that much and in particular in Vikings a
Magnus does have a winning record he's
won one game and drawn four so Wesley
would love to get his first win in this
critical round 11. and from a
psychological standpoint yes Wesley has
never won a game with black against the
world champion but he understands what's
at stake for Magnus Magnus is going to
have to take a lot of risks he didn't
win that white game against gukesh which
really wanted to if anyone with black
against Max sudlu but Magnus understands
the gravity of this game Wesley doesn't
need to do anything special he just
needs to play his chess and I think in
Wesley's mind Magnus is going to be the
one taking risks so if Wesley plays
solid he's going to get his chances
that is the way if you can call it one
to beat Magnus Carlson is sometimes he
does over press especially when he feels
like he needs to win the game he doesn't
lose very often it's a a rare occurrence
that just so has happened to occur twice
in this tournament uh but for Wesley so
he is not somebody who looks at his
opponent and gets scared you mentioned
the chess.com Global Championship who
did Wesley so beat he beat a car
Nakamura in the semifinals then nihal
sarin in the final the guy has beaten
the best of the best in all time
controls in variants he won the Fisher
random world championship against the
person that he is sitting across from
right now so Wesley so even though his
lifetime record not so Stellar against
Magnus that same thing is true for
pretty much every player on the planet
he is focused you see him with his hands
covering his eyes that is his typical
posture at the board he just wants to
focus on the pieces he does not want to
look at his opponent and be distracted
affected I just love that view so
picturesque the players focused and then
the spectators crowded around behind
them behind the barrier watching
intently watching The Players every move
physically literally and figuratively
Magnus continues to ponder uh this
important moment and I think we should
take this opportunity to travel back to
the bird's eye view and take a look at
what opening Innovations we see in the
other games we have a panoply of
different opening lines we've got a very
interesting Berlin over on your lower
right arag I see against ukesh giri
abdusitor of continuing along that sort
of typical Queen's Gambit accepted route
we've got a tarash in Iranian caruana a
rare guess at the highest level Robert
wherever you look and this is honestly
one of the great things about this event
it's just the diversity of openings that
we see in every round
and if we look at the middle on the
bottom row there if it's a chimer just
by the B4 against Richard report so if I
saw that position I already know that
Richard report is playing I don't know
what color but it just seems like an
obscure opening that is not typically
played at the highest levels but uh I
think we should tune in to our matchup
between Fabiano caruana and levonne
aronian because those two players if
they win today that might catapult them
towards the possibility of playing for
first place whereas right now they're
just at plus one I say just as if that's
not a huge accomplishment but for those
two players who have such an illustrious
history they're such great players
they've won this turn before levonne
Rowan has won it four times
just this one time but look at this we
have a tarash as you're pointing out and
for carwana he doesn't often play this
variation so he is catching Levon by
surprise and that is something that
Fabiano has done well in this event is
opening preparation has been quite good
he also is playing new lines that his
opponents can't just study beforehand
levon's gonna have to rely on previous
experience and prep but I really doubt
he studied it this morning
and the fact that he's thinking in this
position is already a little bit
surprising to me because as far as I
know the move Bishop to G2 simply
fianchettoing the bishop is pretty much
automatic are you aware of any viable
Alternatives Robert is there Bishop G5
or is he just sort of thinking about is
he remembering his file and thinking
about the future
he's thinking about the future because
as you're saying Bishop G2 that seems
very obvious uh there are another move
that could be considered is like Bishop
G5 but it doesn't really make sense but
the white king in the center you don't
want to allow the position to open up so
Bishop G2 simply develops the the bishop
gets yourself ready to Castle and you're
not afraid of C takes D4 because your
knight will just capture back so I am
curious what he's considering here and
something that I do want to point out
just so we can make a couple moves that
after Bishop G2 the reason we don't take
on C5 right away is we often wait for
black to play Bishop E7 because then
when we play D takes C5 the bishop has
to move a second time in a row whereas
if we just go back a couple moves uh
before Bishop G2 if you take on C5 right
away Bishop takes C5 it's the same
position except White's Bishop isn't
already on G2 so you often wait for that
Bishop to develop before capturing that
pawn that's a great point and it's a
ubiquitous idea across many different
openings in the Queen's Gambit declined
you see the exact same idea from black
side where black waits for white to
develop the bishop and then releases the
tension in the center since we have the
analysis board up I will point out that
the tarash is a dubious is the wrong
word but it's a very committal opening
from a positional standpoint because if
you kind of Waltz yourself uh into
normal middle game territory you're
going to end up with an isolated Queen
Pawn on D5 and whenever there's an
isolated Queen Pawn you want to look
primarily at who has control of the
square in front of the pawn so if black
plays passively with Bishop E7 I think
Bishop C5 there is the main move after
both sides Castle White can immediately
start applying pressure on the pawn you
can do it directly you can also do it
indirectly by attacking one of the
Pawn's defenders in the F6 Knight and
it's very very easy Robert if you don't
know the exact Theory to get yourself
into a nasty situation with black
yes you can find some huge trouble the
D5 Pawn is isolated which means it
doesn't have a best friend by its side
that means it's vulnerable so you have
to be very careful in these positions
and sometimes even when white takes that
Knight on C6 and you say all right my
pawns are connected I'm happy about that
the pawn that goes to C6 is kind of a
backwards pawn and it's easy to Target
so black has to be very very careful by
having a carwana he didn't play this
opening by accident he must have some
ideas up his sleeve but it is
interesting that he is starting to think
right now because he chose this
variation so he can't be surprised by
what Levon has done it is standard
opening fare
he's like oh no lavonfian ghettoed his
Bishop this throws me off completely yes
he takes D4 Knight takes D4 Bishop C5
and this theory has been around since
the 70s and 80s Gary Kasparov was one of
the main proponents of the tarash uh in
the in the 80s really at the Apex of his
chess career and there we have Fabiana
caruana
I think about to capture that pawn on D4
yes he has and he's developed his Bishop
to C5 Fabiana aware of the importance of
developing actively in order to
counterbalance the weakness of the D5
Pawn but this is just theory of course
it's Theory you're putting pressure on
White's Center and you you are not going
to blunder at night if you're live on so
the big question is what do you do do
you take on C6
fixing you might call it Black's Pawn
structure but giving the isolated
opponent a friend or do you play Knight
B3
um the move Knight to B3 it is viable it
attacks the bishop on Z5 right away but
you're also moving the same piece for
the third time and that may give black
the necessary time after Knight B3 to
say all right your knight has hopped
around quite a lot now my Bishop is
under attack Echo that's the big
question uh you slide back to B6 and if
white gets hungry and takes the pawn on
D5 with the Knight that's where things
get very interesting if we can just show
the variation it looks like you're
simply grabbing a pawn there but I
believe it was Bishop E6 so after Bishop
E6 if you take the Knight on F6 the
queen takes back and uh threatened The
Rook coming today it's just way too much
activity if you take on B6 you take on
D1 swap Queens okay after King D1 you
have a takes B6 now Bishop takes B3 is a
winning threat because the A2 Pawn is
pinned the D file is open and the king
is at the end of the line Knight G4
ideas come into play Knight B4 ideas
also available it's the type of opening
that is full of life and it's the white
king that will be less safe than the
black one
this is such an instructive line because
a lot of people just kind of assume that
when the Queens are swapped when they're
off the board your king is out of the
woods and that could not be further from
the truth I don't even look at this
position and think end game this is more
of a queenless middle game and blacks
pieces have tremendous potential here
this is not an appetizing line
definitely not one you would go into
without extensive preparation as we
speak Knight B3 Bishop B6 is on the
board let's get ourselves back to the
live board now Knight takes D5 is
obviously not forced and as a much safer
alternative black and simply Castle King
side which is exactly Robert Lebon does
can't really blame him or refraining
from Knight takes D5 no I think it's a
good choice and it's less forcing black
can't push the pawn to D4 that's often
the continuation at this point uh so you
thrust the pawn forward and get your
king out of the center but this matchup
between these two they have played each
other a lot they're very familiar with
one another and not just as opponents as
we see the lifetimes score is it five in
a car want a favorite 11 wins seven
losses and 28 draws many games played
between these two In classical chess but
Lavon does well in Viking Zay he is a
four-time champion of this event and he
has beaten Fabiano twice and drawn the
other two games zero losses to karwana
in tats of Steel
the concept of
a player doing particularly well in a
particular tournament is a really
interesting one and yet there's
something to it right players aren't
generally superstitious but sometimes
when they arrive for the 10th or 15th
time in a tournament where they always
seem to do well they get that additional
air of confidence and of course vice
versa every player almost every top
player has a tournament where things
just don't seem to click and for Lavon
aronian things just kind of always seem
to settle favorably in tata steel he
just has looked very confident this time
despite a string of pretty disappointing
performances in recent months in the
meantime Knight A4 castles kingside and
we've got ourselves a fascinating middle
game struggle here
yes and the big question is is the D4
Pawn a strength for black because it
limits where White's pieces can go the
Knight was on C3 had it hop to A4 the
bishop on C1 of course can't go to E3
the pawn is just taking up space it also
keeps that E2 Pawn in check because if
that pawn ever pushes then black will
take but it could also become a target
white already has the Queen and Knight
lined up against the pawn on D4 and the
bishop will be eliminated from B6 at
some moment so white can take that pawn
right away if you go Knight takes B6
and then take on C6 with your Bishop
then you could take the D4 pod after
that but you don't want to part with
your fee and keto Bishop that's a very
dangerous proposition in this particular
line if the Queens come off then you're
saying that's not a big deal but if the
Queen stay on us you're showing with
Queen C7 down the line the white king
will be more vulnerable than blacks and
the keywords there are down the line you
could look at this and say well I don't
see where the Checkmate is going to come
from it's way too early to talk about
Checkmate but it's all about the
potential energy in Black's pieces the
bishop coming out to H3 The Rook
swinging itself to d8 the pawn from C6
could delve into C4 and harass the
Knight on B3 it's just a pawn and black
gets just excellent practical
compensation for it white can play a
move like Bishop F4 here but the queen
can tuck itself away on B7 Bishop H3 is
on tap and this is not the kind of
position that you want to have if you're
playing for a win and I'm sure Fabiano
caruana has analyzed this line
exhaustively I am not expecting car
Lavon to grab the pawn on D4 so if we go
back to the live board he could do some
sort of mixture right he could take on
B6 but then refrain from Bishop takes C6
snag the bishop pair and perhaps get the
other Bishop out to G5 but we're
discussing this from a general
standpoint the players should still be
in familiar territory this is as far as
I know Robert still pretty well known
Theory with a lot of games in the
database
it is for sure white could play the
McQueen D3 just blockading the pawn
trying to bring a rook to the D file so
this is familiar territory seems to be
more familiar for Fabiano it is for
Lavon and as Lavon sits and thinks
Ponders his next move uh why don't we
zoom out for a second because
there's some explosive things happening
second from the right on the bottom row
dingley Ren is just stealing Jordan
front Forest Queen side uh but even more
fascinating to me for the moment is the
game second from the left in the bottom
row because para maksudu is sitting for
a deep think and it's early in the game
but if we could bring that board up for
a second we don't have to stay very long
because Parham is going to continue
thinking the last move played what just
just go back no yes go back ahead the
last one was Knight F3 to H2 in a night
orb what in the world is this you may
ask why would you undevelop your piece
that Knight is heading right to G4 and
what it's trying to do this is a key
principle in the night or look at the D5
square that pawn E5 cannot move
backwards you cannot cover the D5 square
with a pawn it is vulnerable so he is
trying to swap off that Knight on F6 and
you often see if you put the Knight back
on F3 I mean you can just show it here
as well you often go like Knight D2
Knight C4 Knight E3 something like that
he's saying let me be a little bit more
direct by playing Knight H2 to G4 and
instead of bringing a second Knight to
the D5 Square let's just remove the
defender of that square this is weird
stuff it also opens up the F2 Pawn to go
to F4 at some moment but Knight G4 is
the main idea here and Parham clearly
has not seen this line before it might
be a novelty it definitely might be a
novelty and this is a kind of move that
is congruent with the Knight orf's
theoretical history in the 90s and early
2000s all of the rage was revolving
around the sort of main moves Bishop G5
F4 the English attack with Bishop E3 and
F3 but in the last seven or eight years
Grandmasters have been looking and
looking for and producing some
incredibly rare lines in the night or if
we just go back to the position after A6
you've had Queen F3 you've had even H4 I
played that move you've had
crazy moves like Rook B1 even I've seen
so you know players have been extending
themselves trying to find fresh
territory in the night orphan I think
this is part of that Trend where maybe
Knight H2 isn't stockfish's top
recommendation if it was I'm sure Parham
would be aware of it it might be number
three or four maybe Prague ran another
engine such as Leela to find that move
this is what Grandmasters do nowadays
it's not just about finding the best
objective move it's about finding a move
where you understand the resulting
positions better than your opponent but
Robert as outlandish as this move looks
I think it is fully positionally
Justified he's fighting for the D5
square and what's wrong with that
that's a good decision and prognanda he
is a young player it means that he is
willing to take risks but this isn't
even that risky of a move he hasn't
thrown pawns forward and they can't move
back all he's done is use the principles
that he has learned give me the D5
square that is what I want and well that
now begs the question what does black do
does black have to respond with H5 just
if Knight G4 is such a big threat can't
I play H5 to stop it the problem with
playing H5 is you give white the G5
Square you often want to kick a bishop
out of G5 with a movie upon H6 later in
the game you also may find your H5 on
being targeted it's harder to Castle if
a bishop comes to E2 then it H5 Pawn is
in its direct line of fire so this is a
moment that you cannot take for granted
if you're Parham he understands the
importance of this move and whether he
plays B5 as a standard in many positions
like this just to throw your queen side
pawns forward or he reacts and takes
care of this Knight G4 we're good we're
gonna put threat in air quotes because
it doesn't threat to Wood material
there's no Checkmate but it's just a
positional threat and it just means for
param he needs to figure out how big of
a threat is it
and the last thing I'll point out uh
before perhaps we can swing back to the
bird's eye view is that white is under
no obligation to play Knight G4
especially if black plays H5 the Knight
has another hidden pathway another
airport that it could fly to once the
bishop comes out from F1 the Knight
could actually move back to F1 and then
to E3 which is exactly the same pathway
the same destination as the Knight would
land on uh in the more conventional
maneuver night uh D2 to C4 to E3 so in a
certain sense this move is actually
quite flexible yes you want Knight G4
but uh you could come back to F3 or you
could swing the Knight around to E3 all
of these ideas are uh part of the fight
for this crucial D5 Square well time
will tell if this novelty or
semi-novelty is going to pay off I think
it will
it's already paying off because he's up
so much time so we'll see how Parham
reacts Knight D7 but just as I was
getting ready to leave this game he says
let's play Knight D7 reinforce the
Knight on F6 and oftentimes you want to
play B5 and Bishop B7 so the Knight
being in The Bishop's path not the
biggest deal but probably Nanda playing
instantly that is scary for his opponent
you know that he's in his preparation
but what I wanted to do down there if
I'm being fully transparent is to zoom
out to the bird's eye view because if my
eyes are not deceiving me and I have
four eyes I wear glasses top left here
Anish giri Nori abusot is playing
instantly he's playing really quickly he
has more time than he started with but
the white king is castled Queen side the
black king is Castle kingside we could
be in for attacking chess
we definitely are in for attacking chess
I love opposite side castling and you
know who doesn't love opposite side
castling right about now that's Anish
giri this is not the kind of position
where you want your opponent playing
instantly that is a very disturbing sign
and how to break up this tour of trying
to turn the tables on the ultimate
opening Juggernaut is Anish giri for
perhaps the first time this tournament
going to be the one actually struggling
against his opponent's preparation
it's a huge moment I mean you know these
types of positions are very sharp so we
see a niche he looks flustered right
he's he knows that he's been caught and
he's not hiding it and for it no deer
Beck I we were saying before the game
started Dania that anishikiri being the
preparation wizard that he is uh
nerdirect being young it might be a
struggle for him but he is saying I am
taking it to my opponent I'm not
supposed to sit here with the black
pieces be scared no he is playing a very
sharp variation and if we can go to the
uh game here for a second the big
question that's being posed is Bishop
takes C4 is that available to white or
is black going to respond with Knight
takes E4 we should take stock of the
material at the moment black is a pawn
ahead white has given up two pawns black
just won so Bishop takes C4 restores
material equality but just for a second
but because Knight takes E4 might be on
tap
and this is one of those positions that
you only go for if you have analyzed it
very carefully with an engine because if
you look just sort of from a superficial
standpoint if we continue the line
Knight takes E4 Queen takes E4 Rook hu1
imagine showing this to Jose will Kappa
Blanca he would say well obviously white
is winning all of the pieces are in the
center
how could black possibly survive this
but this is the essence of modern chess
you have to look at everything
concretely sometimes
one your eyes might tell you one thing
but stockfish might tell you one other
thing and normally you want to trust
stockfish after something like Queen H4
I don't think that white has any
concrete tactics the sac on F7 is
premature it doesn't work because if
Rook takes F7 you could try to set
something up along the e-file but what
E7 is under Black's control if you keep
tossing the queen around it'll gladly
Park itself on F6 and guess what on the
very next move black will already start
bringing out his Queen side pieces and
to your original Point black is up a
pawn and Anish giri definitely cannot
forget that
he is not forgetting it he is
calculating right now and I think some
other important lines that we should
show is after Bishop takes C4 uh if that
is to be played right now Knight takes
E4 it looks like you're walking into a
pin with Queen E2 Queen E3 uh but if you
play Queen E3 the queen goes to C5 it
gets out of the pin and that Knight was
under attack twice and attacks the
bishop on C4 so you take my knight I
take your Bishop that sounds like a fair
trade now if you played Queen E2 instead
of Queen E3 you actually protect the
bishop so Queen C5 no longer works
because the Knight with cow there's an
E4 exactly every move has a distinction
to it and queen E3 covered the diagonal
Queen E2 doesn't that allows you to
escape the pin and then black is winning
as you see on the evaluation bar so the
option to pin that Knight it doesn't
really work for white at least it
doesn't gain material but let's actually
continue the queen E3 line for a second
and look at Erwin love me you read my
mind
that is Anise Geary's main second and
trainer and he's like what is going on
here we haven't looked at this but I was
going to say after Queen C5 Bishop takes
F7 check is an interesting intermeso and
after Rook takes F7 Queen takes E4 we're
left with a position or who knows what's
going on the answer is
I certainly don't it's even material
Kings and opposite sides of the boards
both Kings look a bit vulnerable it's a
bishop for black compared to a knight
for white
this is the kind of position you could
just stare at for 30 minutes 45 minutes
and figure out exactly nothing which is
a pretty disturbing sign for Anish gear
I mean even Rook takes F2 is on the
table that's a possibility although you
know if I had to make a move here on my
own I would probably try to develop the
queen side maybe Knight to A6 probably
not Knight C6 because that allows white
to take and then deliver a very nasty
check on d8 so after something like
Knight A6 we've got ourselves just a
completely chaotic position now with the
center as open as it is there's always
the possibility that you get a bunch of
Trades and listen at this point if Anish
giri takes another 20-25 minutes here he
definitely might not mind some sort of
liquidation and a bailout but right now
the ball is squarely in this court and
with every ticking second norterbeck has
to be feeling more and more confident
about his opening reparation this is
excellent work but by the Uzbek prodigy
and Gary does not look very pleased he's
digging deep right now so we'll leave
him to it in the live position he has
yet to take on C4 we'll see if he does
but as we look at the bird's eye view in
the bottom left levonne Rowan has
captured that Knight on C6 after
capturing the bishop on B6 still within
lavano carwana's preparation at least
the realm of it uh Magnus Carlson in the
top right we have an isolated Queen Pawn
we'll look at that game in a bit but for
now as dingley ran the second from the
right in the bottom against Jordan van
Forest that also is getting spicy we
will take a quick break and before we do
we want to show you everyone there at
this chess Festival the playing Hall is
full and it's full of Masters The
Challengers and all of the open
tournaments that are in session but
Magnus Carlson he wants to continue his
winning streak that is what he's aiming
for and we'll see if he can do that
return from this break
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
been permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dark chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chess so exciting
I don't know about slip no no no no no
I won
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
foreign
the Champions chess tour officially
kicks off with the air things Masters on
February 6th as usual we'll bring you
all the action right here at twitch.tv
slash chess use the command CCT in chat
for all of the details Magnus Carlson
Wesley sohikar Nakamura and many others
will take part in this event with a huge
prize fund but right now we are live in
the playing Hall in vikon Zay it is the
time to seal Chess Masters 2023 and on
screen we have no deerback Abu sotarov
and Anish Geary I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess alongside me my good friend
Grandmaster Daniel narodisky Dania we're
just about an hour into the round the
players they are struggling some of them
out of the gates with great opening
preparation by the likes of prognananda
and nordi rakabusitarov pretty
fascinating start
and you just knew we would get something
like this yesterday was the rest day the
players have a full additional date to
rest to catch up on sleep and most
importantly to do perhaps even more
preparation than they normally do and I
think you see a lot of players who took
that day very very seriously they did
not procrastinate they spent hours upon
hours reviewing their files and they are
now reaping the rewards won pragnananda
is another as he continues to Blitz out
moves instantly Knight H2 by the way are
hard-working production team reporting
that it is not a novelty it has occurred
a handful of times but just look at the
disparity on the clock and yet another
player who is showcasing some incredible
preparation the one and only Jordan Von
for race Robert that position should
come with an Advil included
I need at least three because I'm
looking at a that's second from the
right the king is on E7 for black and
Jordan completely unfazed which means
it's preparation let's go right to that
game because we are 14 moves in it is
White's turn and I don't even know the
material so I'm actually gonna do some
quick math black has six pawns white has
seven pawns the minor pieces are even
three minor pieces per side okay so it
looks terrible for black but looks can
be deceiving the Knight on C7 which gave
a check to the king that was on E8 now
is in big trouble the threat if black
had a free turn is Rook to B7 but that's
not the only threat in the position look
at that pawn down on B2 that's also
hanging so white has quite a number of
issues right now and because Rook B7
well when material I would think that
you might have to move your queen away
like Queen A5 but I'm guessing George
will play a flurry of quick moves down
yet and there are tactics waiting for us
I am itching to share what I found about
this position I spent the entire break
analyzing with chess space what's
amazing if we can rewind a little bit
and we definitely need anything else we
need five analysis boards uh to
deconstruct the complexities of this
position in this position after uh Queen
to B3 Queen B6 or queen C7 has been
automatic for years Jordan coming up
with a crazy novelty DC giving up as you
said his entire Queen side and then
nonchalantly pushing the sea Pawn
allowing the Knight direct access to the
C7 square and then what else is new the
king just coming out onto E7 in the
opening now here's what white has to
find after Queen to A5 dropping the
queen back taking the sting out of Rook
B7 here's what's likely to happen black
will most likely take on D4 and then
play Rook h8 to H5 how many times do you
play this move period much less on move
16. this forces white to find an
intermediate check on B4 4. black snaps
that Bishop off white recaptures king
Dodges the check moves to d8 notice that
the Knight defends the bishop now Robert
the Knight is going to be lost anyway so
white might as well give it up for a
pawn Knight takes C6 Desperado then
white snags another Pawn on C4 and black
shift the queen up to B7 this position
is evaluated by stockfish you guessed it
0.00 and this is after ding has to find
all of these moves and if I had to
choose the side here I usually like the
two pieces in a middle game when you
have two pieces for a rook
and the problem will be if we just look
at the position on the big board there
is not even seeing the position it's
evaluating it once you get there because
Jordan Von Forest is playing extremely
quickly so dingley Wren who is preparing
for a world championship match we should
add he's looking at this like uh oh what
am I walking into the fact that Jordan
is responding instantly could be a good
sign that Ding is finding all the best
choices the downside is you may only
have one good move for the next five and
if you make one mistake it not it's just
going to be a worse position you might
lose a full minor piece with Rook B7 on
tap for example so this is just a wild
position can we go back to that moment
that you were showing with Queen B3 and
as you were saying normally black plays
the move yeah
I just want to point out that the reason
why dingley Ren after d takes C4 didn't
just play Bishop takes C4 which we were
talking about you want to take back in
one turn is black plays B5 the bishop
Retreats somewhere along the diagonal
and then black will play the move I
don't know where it goes say E2 A6 and
then strike with C5 so you protect the
B5 Pawn you play C5 you see the
evaluation bar saying black is actually
doing quite well because the open H file
is good for The Rook that's staring down
at the pawn uh and C5 just tries to
blast open the position on favorable
terms because the white king is likely
to go Queen side and as soon as it does
the move C5 opens that side of the board
the king will not be very happy
yeah the white king just says no Safe
Haven either uh you get massaged down
the H file or after C5 black opens up
the C file puts a rook on CNN quickly
pushes the pawn down to B4 this was not
appealing to dingley Ren and you can't
blame him there was a very interesting
Bishop sacrifice on E6 but we will save
that for another day because we have
more than enough complexity on the board
already and dingley ran I was going to
point this out there's one other move
that preserves objective equality and
that is the move currently on the board
D takes C5 ding laughs in the face of
the threat of Rook B7 has he blundered
his Knight well spoiler alert dangling
around doesn't usually blunder Knights
and this is no exception after Rook B7
let's keep the analysis board up his
idea is to drop the queen back to A3
x-raying the king and after Queen takes
C7
there is a check on C6 again the king
drops back to d8 and in this position
there is an incredible move Robert Queen
A3 to A5 the point is just to defend the
C6 spawn the queen is unable to move
because it is pinned black has to give
away the Knight Rook takes B2 I also
came across this line in my analysis
Pawn takes Knight Knight Knight takes
pawn and you get total pandemonium in
the end game the chaos just does not end
that is an absolute wild line I mean to
find this over the board for dingly Ren
is very impressive because
it looks like you can lose the game
instantly with any mistake so he takes
on C5 and if we get to the position that
we have in the analysis board there uh
he is regaining his material uh but the
position still goes on it's the king
will never find safety for white the
black king would be in the center of the
board as well so that gives chances for
both
if I may just what makes this impressive
is that Queen A5 isn't just an optional
nicety it is absolutely forced if you
play instead the move Queen A4 and say
well let me defend the pawn directly
that loses to the straightforward
actually not Knight C5 probably because
C takes B7 and Bishop A5 and Knight B6
is the more accurate move because it
controls the A8 square and black simply
emerges up a piece after that black will
take on C6 so ding had to see the move
Queen A3 to A5 in calculating this line
that is what he just spent the last 25
minutes trying to find and he might
emerge out of the complications in one
piece Robert but he is praying to all of
the chess Gods right now that he hasn't
miscalculated bear with me for a second
go back before King d8 just one move
okay what if Jordan has some kind of
King E8 in store for us because if you
take on D7 with check because there's no
Queen A5 no Queen trade so you take any
simple check the Knight takes back and
the claim is that H2 is loose B2 is
threatened
um black cannot Castle the King has
moved a bunch of times already and you
look at the eval bar it's saying it's
level but it's level if you know what
you're doing and then you find the best
moves Jordan might have looked at this
10 moves further and that is so scary
for dingley terrifying
it's absolutely terrifying You Don't
Know How Deeply Jordan looked at this
because the line is so narrow
Jordan could very well have spent an
hour or two on the position after 1967
this is where his file could have
started and you know the bad thing is
that if your opponent plays instantly
you know you're in the preparation bad
if your opponent starts to think then
you kind of know that you probably made
a mistake so you're darned if you do and
darn if you don't
wow not a pleasant task ahead for
dingley Wren I just completely wild
stuff in on this board I I think we
should leave dailyren and Jordan to
figure this out Jordan is finally
thinking which means that he may in fact
be out of preparation or he's just
trying to remember it but in the top
right Magnus Carlson against Wesley so I
want to take us to that game not because
the current position is the most
fascinating but I just want to make a
little Point as we uh pull up that one
because a Magnus with the white pieces
the position
is one where the pawns same files as
each other the Bishops are about to get
swapped on E6 and let's just show Bishop
takes E6 Queen takes E6 I want that
position just one move down from now it
looks well it's just even right we have
Five Pawns each a queen looks dead equal
but what Magnus might be trying for is
his typical in-game magic that he sees a
future in this position where if he
brings his Queen to A4 and a rook to C1
and D1 maybe the A7 Pawn is just a
little bit more tender than the other
Pawns in the position now Dania if we
were playing this game I think we would
look at each other and be like Daniel I
think let's get some dinner yeah let's
go get dinner and let's talk about the
other games we have a draw here but I
actually don't think that Magnus looks
at this and just says the game is over
he always seems to find the chances but
then I think about Magnus Carlsen who he
is and then I look at what we have in
front of us the facts the club for
Wesley so so is his more time than it
started with he is playing instantly
each and every move this was preparation
and he must have caught Magnus in a line
he didn't fully know and for Wesley he's
saying I'm going to hold this game I use
my preparation to Perfection and it is
an even position
yeah no the clock situation is really
the most disturbing element of the
position for Magnus Carlson it's not
really the symmetrical nature of the
position if you had reversed the clock
situation I think Magnus would be
extremely confident right now but as it
stands if Wesley can make two or three
more accurate moves I think Magnus might
be staring down the barrel of uh
essentially a dead dry I think he has to
try Queen A4 put immediate pressure on
the Knight quickly get a rook to E1
Magnus Carlson is a virtuoso in these
types of positions but unfortunately for
him if Wesley analyzed the heck out of
this position with an engine Robert I
just don't see Magnus winning this game
against a Wesley who is prepared to find
another three or four accurate moves I'm
with you can we go back to move 12 for a
second and move 11 after B6 for black if
you behave I will behave I promise okay
great this was the critical moment
because Magnus played the move D5 here
which saw the liquidation that we're is
happening in the game so he chose to
make this move which simplifies the
position and the reason he did this is
because he had an isolated Queen Pawn so
before playing D5 he's looking at the
long-term prospects of if that pawn gets
blockaded with Bishop to B7 maybe Knight
A5 or Knight E7 as you're showing taking
control of the D5 Square white is the
side who's going to be worse so he says
I don't want to have any risk in the
position let me just play D5 and even
though the advantage that you hope for
does not exist you're saying I cannot
lose this position let me try to go from
here
yeah Magnus is not going to lose this
game and normally when D5 happens uh and
you've got the bishop pair then white is
able to claim a sizable Advantage but
this move Bishop to E6 it's so annoying
it takes the sting out of White's
initiative it forces Mass Liquidation in
the center now both sides with only one
minor piece on the board and I just feel
like Wesley is uniquely equipped out of
all of the top GMS there's just
something about Wesley's ability to hold
slightly worse positions that gives me
full confidence in the fact that this
game is likely to have a peaceful
conclusion with that being said Queens
are still on the board Rooks are still
on the board let's not pretend that
Magnus is going to offer a draw here he
is going to try to squeeze everything he
can out of this position before
admitting that Wesley's opening
preparation has yielded him a draw
and he plays Rook C1 going to the uh
open file he can bring his Queen out to
A4 later but the look on magnus's face
is one that's like oh man if I can win
this game it's going to take all the
effort in the world and for for Wesley
great preparation Wesley so is an
unbelievable chess player he really
flies under the radar I think in a way
that isn't entirely fair to how good he
is and I think the reason why is because
he is playing the most precise chess
very often if you look through his games
he is up there with Magnus and a few
others as the most accurate player in
the world the problem is he doesn't
often take risks so if he needs to win
some games to win the tournament he's
not going to go all out like some other
players will he's not going to make a
speculative opening decision because he
is a very pragmatic player and Donna you
and I know Wesley well you've played him
in U.S championships uh know I've had a
number of instructive conversations with
him but just to hear his thoughts on the
game and he's just really always trying
to improve and he doesn't like to make
decisions out of you know Force he wants
to really calculate wants to play the
best moves and Wesley is doing just that
in this game Wesley is a scientist he
strives for the truth in every position
whether you know regardless most of the
time of the tournament situation and I I
really respect that I think that makes
this game so fun to watch you know that
every time you look at a Wesley so game
he is going to be hunkered down looking
for the objective truth in the position
he is just a
Juggernaut and he's so good in the
opening he's so good with both colors
and he's just so unbelievably consistent
you know name the last bat tournament
Wesley so had I'll wait for a couple of
minutes it's really hard
he's great and I think he's going to
hold this position together as he takes
his first think of the game and he's got
the time
uh to invest in this position figure out
where he wants to put his Rooks okay so
while he does that why don't we zoom out
and take a look at his Olympia teammates
his frequent opposition at the U.S
championships levonne aronian and
Fabiano caruana that game is in the
bottom left and as we see there's not
many pieces left in that one and I'm
getting a flashback and it's Flashback
Friday here Donya this position reminds
me of the game between karawana and
Abdus Atara I think that was the second
round of this event where fabin was
black he had these double def Pawns in
an age Pawn the end result of that game
was a draw and what happened was if you
take this position and remove B6 C6
the pawn on B2 and the knight in the
bishop so just all the pieces that we
have now in red if all uh and now blue
as well if all those pieces are gone you
tricked me that that is a that's a
theoretical draw so rook and four versus
rook and three on the same side of the
board is a theoretical draw and that's
how Fabiano uh held the game against
abusotarov earlier in this event this is
looking very similar to that uh Lavon
doesn't really have much of an edge he
has a knight versus Bishop that's a good
thing because the bishop is inherently
limited to its own color complex but
there aren't really great dark squares
to hop to so I believe that Fabiano has
taken care of business in this game and
for Lavon do not play Knight D2 because
then you get back rank check
yeah 92 would not be a wise choice I
just wanted to piggyback and extend the
excellent point you just made about that
end game what's fascinating about it and
I'm just going to make a series of Moves
In order to get that position ignore the
actual moves
um the moves are going to be totally
nonsensical so let's eliminate all of
these pieces and let's say that the
bishop is traded for the Knight a very
uh objective line right all of these
moves are totally going to happen what's
amazing about this particular type of
four on three is that Black's Pawn
structure is and my coach taught me this
many years ago it's actually the ideal
structure you want to have if you're
defending a three on four and you might
hear that and say you're crazy we need a
new commentator Juan's on F7 F6 and H6
ideal in the middle game this is as bad
as it gets but the analogy I like to
make is kind of like the pawns are a
bumper they soak up any activity by
White's pawns it's like when they would
bury vampires in the old days and it
would put spikes over the grave you know
so when the vampire rose up he would be
impaled F6 and F7 these are like the
spikes so that any time white pushes the
epon up to E5 boom trade anytime I
pushes the pawn to G5 boom trade white
simply cannot make any progress and
Black's King is going to comfortably sit
on G7 defending all three pawns at the
same time this is a pretty
straightforward draw
and in the meantime
as we rewind back to the live board
Knight to C1 Rook B2 Rook C6
I think Robert the question isn't
whether this game is going to end a draw
it's how long this game is going to last
so I have two thoughts first of all you
said in the old days and they mentioned
vampires as if they're real so uh I love
your active imagination uh but I I want
to make a comment about these two
players they are very good friends and
they have worked together and that can
be very uncomfortable when you're
playing against somebody that you shared
opening ideas with that you have
collaborated with for huge tournaments
so Lavon and Fabiano have had training
sessions before the most recent
candidates at the Olympiad the three of
us would go on long walks talking about
all sorts of things I mean they really
respect each other and are good friends
and we see their lifetime heads head
they
really go at it they have 18 decisive
games and Fabiano's favor 11 wins to
seven but it now they've worked together
Levon has moved to the United States
plays on the American flag now they're
competing against one another but they
have that camaraderie and it just
becomes uncomfortable to play somebody
that you work with
yeah I've had similar situations
with Sam shankland for example with whom
I'm good friends and I've known him for
many many years he of course is from the
San Francisco Bay area and you know we
grew up together and it is hard
sometimes to push those thoughts away uh
and play your full strength but these
players they're used to it obviously
they have to do it on a tournament by
tournament basis so uh they switch
pretty seamlessly from training mode
training mode to playing mode I remember
I played the US Championship in 2015 I
think it was and immediately uh four of
the competitors including myself flew to
Armenia for the world team championship
and it was a really interesting
experience we were just at each other's
throats the tension was unimaginable and
all of a sudden now we're teammates and
you know we're part of the same
operation and I think it was really nice
how we managed to push away those
feelings of competitiveness we had a
couple days together to train in Yerevan
and we just had a great time
your point is well taken it's hard to
code switch between friend mode and
competitor mode
that's why everyone should be your
friend of me that way you can have both
at the same time but these two uh long
time friends they have played many games
this one looking like it's heading
towards a half point or both players so
let's zoom out to our bird's eye view we
have in the top left Anish Kiri against
that looks a lot different from where in
fact it doesn't even look like the same
game it's not the same position
how did we go with this again yeah
please don't copy me please don't do it
how did this happen
I think we need to debrief I
can't even understand how the pawns are
where they are let's Zoom back into our
Marquee matchup between the tournament
leader and the current runner up let's
rewind a couple moves back so we last
updated
in this position after Knights no
earlier before F3 was in this position
aha so Geary going conservative mode and
defending the E4 Pawn Notre back
striking at the Knight forcing it back
getting his night out and Gary
re-establishes material equality Bishop
E6 we have ourselves a trade nanesh giri
says I want those Queens off the board
and now they are off the board they're
gone and I have to say I like white
position I don't think it's a huge
Advantage but it is an advantage that's
going to less and the reason why black
has this isolated Pawn on E6 uh we
really should cut the board in half to
have this discussion because E6 isolated
which means it can be targeted
potentially black has an extra Pawn on
the queen side well white has an extra
Pawn from the e through the H file so
the players are going to be playing
essentially on different flanks white
would love eventually to push those
pawns create a passer but that's far
away given how much material is left on
the board so the big question is do
brook trades if all the Rooks come off
does that favor white or does it help
Black's defensive task if we trade the
knights off the board is that good for
white who then can move the king up and
have more space or is it good for black
because that means your vulnerable Pawn
is not going to be attacked these
questions are essential and I am
actually asking you Dania what do you
think what trades are good for white who
is objectively better here
so intuitively it seems to me that
Anisha seriously explore the option of
trading all of the Rooks and let's keep
our analysis board up the reason why
is that I feel that after the trader
works the Knight on C2 has a direct
Pathway to a very nice Square on C4 and
somehow blacks Queen side pawns start
feeling rather uncomfortable if you
think about it after something like King
F7 Knight E3 it's very easy for black to
waltz into his type of position where
White's already threatening Knight D6
and sort of Knight A4 is in the mix and
maybe Knight B5 Knight D6 with that
being said I think the likeliest result
of this game is still a draw blackhead
drag his King toward the center King E7
would stop Knight C6 so this is one idea
if Anish really wants to eliminate all
risk
but Robert I would really push back as
I'm looking at this on the idea that
white is better I think visually it
looks like White's got the edge because
of the E6 Pawn but that pawn is
essentially unattackable and on the
opposite side black has a pawn structure
asset too uh namely the C5 Pawn which
allows black in some cases to establish
an outpost on D4 so I really don't think
Anisha has much here
I'm with you and I think you're probably
the biggest proponent of sanghus that
pawn structure is often overrated in
chess that we look at pod structure
we're worried about isolated Pawn but
here it's not the biggest deal because
it's hard to get to and the Knight
coming to D4 that's not what white wants
to see white would love to quickly plant
a knight on D6 uh but it also doesn't
threaten all that much let's say you
play Knight B5 here for white okay black
will respond with Knight C6 and once you
get your knight into D6 it's not firmly
entrenched the Palm will go can go up to
B6 or black by Rook D7 and then bring
the second Rook on over to d8 and you're
protecting the pawn the 996 doesn't have
a pawn defending it and so I just feel
like you're right that my first take was
the Aesthetics of the position that pawn
on E6 doesn't look Pleasant it doesn't
look pretty but it's actually covering
the D5 Square so the D4 square is
accessible for a black knight while D5
is off limits to the white Knights yeah
the pawn is functional it's not pretty
but it's functional it's doing a job I
was also kind of taken by this nice
looking Pawn chain but Pawn chains don't
win games you know congrats you've got
less Pawn Islands big deal
material is equal you've got material
balance I actually think a niche has to
be kind of careful if he allows this
Knight to get into D4 we could be
looking at notreck being the one to push
this position so I'm really curious what
amount of risk Anisha is going to be
willing to take in this end game is he
just gonna trade Rooks and say you know
what good job I'm gonna acquiesce to the
drop or is Anish gonna try to stir
things up in this end game I think he's
thinking about just that yeah I do think
that he should try I mean not that this
is a must win there still will be two
rounds after this game concludes but I I
don't really think there is that much
risk Because unless those black pawns
start storming up the queen side the
Knight on C2 will work its way to C4 I
think that plan looks very nice and
black doesn't have anything to attack or
himself right the pawn structure is well
defended for white a pawn chain is as
strong as based Pawn the G2 Pawn is not
moving anytime soon and so I think that
you can play moves like 93 get your
knight to C4 and then try to figure out
what to do from there but abdusitar has
been really impressive and almost as
impressive as his play is his stare I
just saw him look up at me scary he did
it to Magnus Carlsen early in the early
in the day he is afraid of no one
in that stare at Magnus Carlson like boy
when are you going to resign I know
you're the world champion but I'm bored
and you need to resign so I make it to
Pizzeria before it closes at nine that's
what that stare was indicating odor
Beckham jusotarev is always game he's
always confident even when he was on the
cusp of losing that end game to Vincent
kymer just the way that he was moving
and the way that he was acquitting
himself at the board it felt like he
just knew that the draw was in the bag
and that confidence was not something
that we've always seen historically
among chess Juniors who are playing in
their very first super tournaments of
course not a break of just satorov he
won the world rapid Championship he
feels right at home among the world's
Elite and will for many many years to
come I want to take a quick look at
anishagiri's final two rounds because I
think a key part of his decision making
in this position has to do with who he
plays in the last two rounds and listen
there's no weak opponents in tata Steel
Master section but insofar as you could
get favorable pairings in the last round
I would argue Robert and perhaps you'll
push back on this I actually think Anish
giri has pretty good pairings in the
last two rounds two games that are
winnable to opponents who have been up
and down in this tournament
and two players who also take risk
Jordan Von forest and Richard report
those are the type of opponents you want
when you need to win games because they
don't often make boring draws I was
going to say they never do but report
against aronian right before the rest
day that was a force draw from the
beginning so I agree with you but from a
used to Taurus perspective he is the
black pieces in this game and let's look
at his final two opponents because he'll
be happy with the draw today regardless
but as you're indicating the road never
is easy in Vikings a he gets black again
against Wesley so that is that is brutal
that's not at all what you want because
Wesley with the black piece against
Magnus if Wes is able to hold that game
and make a draw comfortably he'll be
feeling very strong about his chances
and let's look at the standings for a
second because Abdul sitarov is black
against Wesley so if we can bring up the
leaderboard heading into this 11th round
Wesley so was one point behind abdusitar
which means he really wants to beat him
no this is a very very trying
part of the tournament for Notre bag
double black against two players in
excellent form and boy would he give
himself a push if he made this draw from
a position of strength well as Anish
Gary Ponders his next move he drops now
to below an hour on the clock there are
only 15 moves in I don't think time
pressure is going to be an issue this
end game is pretty easy to play and you
could make a couple of moves quickly if
he really needed to we look once again
at our bird's eye view a lot of the
games well some of the games are in the
end game some of the games have barely
exited the opening stage prognananda has
only just castled kingside Robert and
aronian carwana barely have any pieces
left
such different games across the board
here some games looking like they're
petering out others are just getting
going the middle and the bottom we
haven't actually looked at it in any
detail Vincent kymer against this report
there's a black queen on A8 now nobody
puts baby in the corner but Rich report
says I'm gonna do it voluntarily because
he is lined up his Queen and Bishop on
the board's longest diagonal on the
light squares so I think that that game
is just getting underway it's very early
stages in that one
yeah and we don't have to spend to dwell
on it for too long I feel emotional
about this game because I play this line
extensively with the white pieces uh I
have played it I've actually played it
from both sides and I think this
structure is just incredibly interesting
the way I like to think of this is
almost like a standoff where both sides
are just kind of locked in this
stalemate of sorts where neither side
really has any appealing Pawn Breakers
Robert you like to say that the side
that controls the pawn breakthroughs uh
is in charge from a strategic standpoint
well the only real Pawn breakthrough
that's available to either side is d65
and you do see black playing this move
under the right circumstances but apart
from that white can't really go C5 white
can try to prepare uh an e-pawn push but
that's also hard to do especially in
light of what Richard report just did
he's trained three of his pieces onto
that E4 square and from the white
perspective I have always found it very
difficult despite the visually appealing
nature of the position you've got a
space Advantage you've got you know a
nice little Queen Side Pawn structure
going
I always struggle to find a plan here
can't push those pawns as you're saying
and the pawn C4 Ultra well defended it's
not like black can play Rook C7 Rook C8
you're not attacking anything
but black can at some point break you
know I like to say it so of course I was
going to say it that at some point D5
can be a strike for black and white
needs to be looking out for that at all
times however if you play D5 too early
um like say you play D5 position I don't
actually think it gets black what he
wants white could simply take on deep
five with the pawn and after Bishop
takes D5 I think Slide the queen up to
A4 and look at these holes on the queen
side the A6 Square the C6 Square B5 all
of them are under White's control and
the bishop on F1 was staring into its
own Pawn as soon as you have G2 taken
care of the visual can slide all the way
out to A6 and before you know it white
controls that open file that can be very
dangerous for black
and the bishop the unsung hero of
White's entire construction here taking
the sting out of Black's battery making
that Queen on a look pretty foolish
black is kind of stuck in molasses here
can't move this Knight because the other
one hangs if you move the other night
well then the queen pressures The Rook
you're absolutely right you don't want
to go D5 prematurely you'll lose
essentially all of your winning chances
in a position like this so Richard
Report with a important decision to make
as we go back to the live board I'm
expecting a neutral move such as A6
maybe he will want to double Rooks on
the C file maybe the Knight can jump out
to E5 but I think Robert is safe to say
we are in for a long grinded out
maneuvering battle in this game between
kymer and Richard report Vincent kymer
has been going the distance in the last
two rounds I think he's played a total
of 14 hours that's many hours more than
the person who has played the next
longest so uh he is Battle tested he
hasn't been winning the games even with
advantages but I like his position and I
like his time look at that he's up
nearly 20 minutes on the clock and I
don't think reports decisions are easy
here I think you are correct A6 Rook C7
Rook C8 all those moves are pretty
logical my question is then what because
D5 still isn't scary I just don't think
that black has a particularly imposing
plan to speak of
yeah I think neither side has a plan but
white just has more comfortable digs in
this position it's easier for white to
tread water than it is for black and
White's got a lot of very small things
that he could try to do to set himself
up for Success when the position does
open up you could consider trying to
play E4 not because you want to go E5
because you want to further blunt
Black's battery you could slide the
queen back to A2 you could even push the
a pawn so a lot of options on the menu
here for both sides and it's a question
of when the position opens up and which
side will be better prepared when it
does we'll keep an eye on that for you
yes we will Let's uh go back to the
bird's eye view because I want to take
stock of a couple positions and make
note about one in particular if you look
at the game that's second from the right
and the bottom Jordan Forest has not
moved after C6 check we we're analyzing
that his King can slide to the back rank
either to eat or d8 he's figuring it out
he has left his preparation so that's
good news for dingley red but the game
at the bottom right we haven't looked at
it yet and I do think that it's quite
interesting because we don't have the
same material for the two sides so why
don't we go to our generic icy versus
Mukesh because we haven't looked at it
meanwhile in each carry by the way
Brooks has been swapped from that board
all the Rooks excuse me so that okay end
game but here look at this Tanya white
has an f-pawn black has a d Pawn white
has a knight black has a light Square
Bishop so when I look at this and we're
talking about Contours the dark squares
are under White's control if that Knight
was on E5 I think we could start talking
about an advantage for white but it's
kind of far away and going to F3 hangs
the F4 Pawn so black cannot take this
moment for granted to not just dilly
dally you need to come up with a plan
here and actually create concrete ideas
because if that Knight does jump forward
if it leaps into those dark squares
that's how you start getting in trouble
especially because white is up a pawn
from the F through H file and the D5
Pawn is isolated and not going anywhere
I definitely think White's position is
easier to play regardless of the
objective evaluation if I'm googesh
first and foremost I'm looking for a way
to trade Queens I think if you can trade
Queens you really take the sting out of
a night maneuver to E5 so one move that
comes to mind is Queen E7 to F6 and as a
positive byproduct if white indeed swaps
Queens on F6 it's just harder to get the
Knight around to E5 white has to spend
another Tempo protecting F4 but G3 does
not go unpunished the move G3 creates
major light Square weaknesses on the
king side and well I could drop the
bishop out to G4 and simply trade on F3
with what seems to be a very drawish end
game but I don't think black uh really
has any problems in a position like this
so that's one way that go cash should
handle the situation another is just to
bring his Bishop out let's say to F5 but
that potentially does allow the scenario
that you outlined with Knight F3 being a
distinct possibility here but you could
say listen I'm gonna let you get your
knight to E5 but you're gonna have to
let me me get my Bishop to the
equivalent Square on e4 and I think it's
very hard to say which pieces is better
because the bishop is nothing to sneeze
at it's pressuring G2 you could try to
get a rook to C2 and the move F4 Robert
I always try to point this out whenever
a pawn moves away from F2 and your
Castle kingside you always need to pay
attention to the A7 G1 diagonal a check
on C5 could come at a very inconvenient
time for white and it could push the
king directly into the line of fire of
the bishop so Bishop F5 Queen F6 I think
ukesh has a wealth of candidate moves
here that are viable but you're
absolutely right in that he needs to be
very careful and he needs to play with a
lot of energy here to uh not allow the
sort of good night versus bad Bishop
scenario and I actually want to show
variation let's say queen F6 your first
move because I just want to go Rook a to
C1
Queen takes C3
uh Rook takes C3 and the A4 Pawn is so
misplaced because Bishop D7 comes with a
shot against that pawn otherwise Rook C7
would be powerful the White Knight would
enter the game but let's just go to the
end game you were talking about a B3 a
rook C8 Rook C1 and we'll swap off all
the Rooks because I just want to show
everybody what's bad about an isolated
Pawn if we get to this end game you see
the evaluation bar is creeping up
because the white king just Sprints to
D4 and that pawn on D5 is stuck in place
the light score Bishop has nothing to
attack and the Knight can hop around and
cause black some problems so this is not
an end game you desire if you are
ghukesh because the D5 Pawn is the
easiest target white has an extra Pawn
from F through H files which means you
can maybe create a pass Pawn of your own
whereas Black's pass Pawn is stuck in
its track so just something to look for
Down the Line This is not going to
happen because Google knows to avoid
this kind of scenario
very well explained and a good
illustration that past pawns aren't
necessarily good even in the end game
they very well might be a liability this
is like the definition of a two result
game where I can get the Knight over to
D4 black has nothing to attack as you
said but I think ukesh is doing a very
good job of taking his time he senses
that this is a critical moment and that
he needs to make a couple of accurate
moves I think in order to fully equalize
likeliest result here Robert I think is
a draw but I could definitely see this
game getting spicy in the near future
yeah I think that it is a level position
but now it's going to be determined by
what the next series of moves the next
stage is all about coming up with a plan
figuring out how to deal with the
isolate upon uh for white the F4 Pawn
does stick out the king can be a bit
unsafe so if that Bishop lands on e4
like you were showing in the previous
variation that could be good news for
good cash so let's uh get away from here
for now it is an interesting Position
gukesh will think and as we look at our
seven boards that prognanda game second
from the left and the bottom row still
full of life all of the pieces on the
board except for one Pawn gone for each
side the end game between Geary and do
satara that can last quite a while
longer because it's double nights and
six pawns per side Magnus Carlson Wesley
so in the top right you see Magnus on
screen there Wesley is playing a great
game he is no worse and nope Jordan run
Forrest second from the right and the
bottom he's finally moved so while the
players they're going to do their
thinking uh you know we are going to
head to a break but before we do we just
want to give a shout out to Landover Jay
Severson one of the co-founders of this
app you might know called chess.com is
at it again Jay has officially launched
his new app Landover inspired by
Settlers of Catan and resource Gathering
games with some transformative
Innovations tailored to player
experience Landover is available for iOS
Android and web browsers but if you're
still not convinced check out this
trailer and see what the game's all
about
foreign
as we look to the playing Hall we will
be right back for more from the 11th
round of the tots of Steel chess
tournament 2023
welcome to Landover a kitten inspired
hexagon resource game for up to four
players
use the feature-rich map Builder to
create unique and creative Maps
host or join custom games where you can
play Live or daily games with friends
other Landover community members or even
solo games against the Landover Bots
choose your initial settlements wisely
and then outweigh your opponents to
expand your Empire
more Villages and cities means more
resources for you to build outward and
upward
use landover's unique trade to build UI
to quickly and easily build whatever you
can afford
race up the culture Tech Tree to gain
additional abilities collect Dev cards
and grab the all-powerful Metropolis
don't forget to upgrade your military to
defend against the impending Barbarian
attacks and launch raids against other
players
prove yourself in rated games to earn
promotions and climb to the top of the
ladder
download Landover for free at
landover.io available on Android iPhone
and browsers
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the plank Hall is full of life in
Vikings a as you see on the screen in
front of you so many participants in
this chess festival and it is a true
chess Festival it's called The Wimbledon
of Chess in its 85th Edition and through
10 Rounds we do have a soul leader it is
the youngster from Uzbekistan the
Olympiad gold medalist for his team the
former World rapid champion no dear Beck
abdusitara but Anish giri Dania he is
right behind Abdus tarab he has the
chance to LeapFrog him if he can win the
game today
this is Anish giri 2.0 I mean we've seen
this inish Gary now for several years he
displays incredible opening preparation
gone are the tournaments where he draws
every game that Anish Gary is in the
past this is an incredibly unpleasant
opponent for absolutely everybody in the
field and let's not forget Anish Gary he
defeated both world number one and world
number two in the same tournament this
is a stat that I will research after the
broadcast but I can bet you silver
dollar it has only been done at most a
handful of times in chess history
well in this standings it just is
impressive to see two teenagers there
towards the top and for abusatara this
would be uh just another Stellar result
for him and the second half of the field
right we still have players who are
going to leave their mark on this
tournament we have Richard report he now
plays for Romania origin from Hungary
and dingley rent the world championship
Challenger you'll be playing match
against Beyond the Palm Tree but this
has not been his tournament done he has
struggled mightily he has a minor score
yeah minus one for the world champion
Challenger is really very very
disappointing no matter how you look at
it it's really hard to sugarcoat Diggs
performance and that real backbreaker
was that game against Anish giri where
Dane just had an overwhelming initiative
messed it up and ended up losing that
game
Vincent kymer Arjun erag I see some of
the young players really struggling as
well but one of the sub narratives
Robert will they be able to recover in
the last three rounds will Vincent kymer
finally be able to score a victory same
goes for our generic icy
big question and these players they're
out of contention for first place
because there's a magic number at steel
uh you know we've seen nine of the last
11 Champions have nine points or more
now eight and a half was the winning
score when Jordan Von Forest went to tie
break against Anish giri but nine points
is the magic number and right now we may
not see a player reached nine points but
the front runner to that figure is no
deerback abusotarev Anish giri would
love to be the person as the favorite
after this Roundup
that's such an interesting stat I always
like uh these types of Statistics which
show you what score you need to get most
of the time in order to win the
tournament it's nine and a half for
title Tuesday there's usually a magic
number and obviously you pointed out
eight and a half did win the tournament
once but let's not miss the then forest
for the trees
you need nine points
you know we've been having such a good
morning thus far and you had to do it
you had to throw in an unnecessary I
always have to do it you really do but
you have to sour the vibe
it's okay I've already forgiven you and
I was gonna say what we have to do now
is go back to the action because the
games all seven still in session and
you're the prophet for a reason the
bottom right that move Queen F6 that you
talked about between ukesh and Eric IC
has been played uh but where do you want
to take us time
where do I want to take this well I
think first of all just quickly point
out the d65 has indeed been played in
the kymer report game so we're gonna get
some fireworks there in the center top
left we're getting exchanges I think
we're gonna get a peaceful result but
that end game could continue for a while
what I want to go to is the prognananda
game I think we need to pay our respect
to Prague for that incredible Knight H2
Innovation probably the wrong word it is
not a novelty but just the guts to play
a move like this in the tournament of
this caliber not only has it paid off on
the clock I think it is paying off on
the board ragnananda stands quite a bit
better let's deconstruct why that is the
case so as you can see the Knight has
finally made its way by way of G4 to the
sort of destination Square on E3 and
from Parham side he has positioned his
pieces in such a way as to take the
sting out of the move Knight D5 and I
think think the important thing to point
out here Robert is that when you occupy
a weak Square you want to occupy it with
a piece you do not want a pawn to land
on that square
Aaron nimsovich in my system famously
compared that to sort of going to the
dentist and getting your cavity filled
you don't want to feel your opponent's
cavities with a pawn you always want to
do it with the piece and so Prague needs
to find a better time to put a knight on
D5
so
I like the analogy there and the pawn on
D6 is also a backwards Pawn so if a pawn
for white moves to D5 look let's just
make a castle and then Knight D5 just to
show what that looks like
and we start taking on D5 for black I'm
not even sure which way let's take twice
you're left with this Pawn here so the
D6 Pawn which could have been a Target
is now safe and sound the defy Pawn is
overextended and far away from the
remaining white pieces so that means D5
can become a liability D6 no longer is
one and as you're indicating F5 becomes
an option for black the C file is open
this is the type of position that is
only a dream for night over players
extremely unpleasant untenable for white
so Prague he's not even thinking about
playing Knight T5 now one way he could
prepare that move is by Shifting The
Rook over to D1 and then dropping the
bishop back to its initial Square Bishop
D2 to C1 I actually think that is his
main plan and then everything will be
set for the move Knight C to D5 and I
actually think the more I look at this
that this plan is not easy for black to
Parry Robert Rook D1 Bishop C1 and
Knight T5 and I would be very skeptical
here about the prospect of black playing
F5 that is a incredibly weakening move
so committal and with the King still in
the center uh you may never find your
king castle so F5 is stopped it's
prevented and if black does decide to
Castle here what is White's follow-up is
white going to play B4 and just start
throwing pawns forward on the queen side
um after Castle I want to put my Bishop
on H6 at some point but my knight on E3
is in the way so what is the response
that prognada has in store for us well
two questions first of all what if I try
to carry out my plan with rookated E1
and Bishop C1 Are you seriously
contemplating a five here do you think
that is Black's main source of counter
play
I would love to play F5 but
I'm not sure I'm ready for that's the
big question
do I have to I'm not sure I'm ready to
compensate with you that I still took
the plunge man I I was gonna ask if you
could put Queen B7 first that way F5
might come with a queen trade at some
point
it's a complicated position I really am
struggling to assess it and I have the
eval bar off from the side doesn't tell
me what moves to make and so it's
should know that I'm doing fine but what
is the actual plan that's what the
players are trying to realize well our
Irreplaceable producer who moonlights as
a analyst Vic is proposing the move
Knight F5 here which black also has to
reckon with and I think Knight F5
actually makes a good deal of sense
Robert the idea of course is that after
GF EF the pawn on F5 isn't dangerous but
it's going to move up to F6 and it's
going to set up a lobster pincer mate
idea forcing black to give back the
minor piece that is actually a really
really spicy idea
so after Knight F5 should black instead
take with the bishop on F5 is that uh
what's being called for here because
after e takes F5 I think black
tactically has the D5 here and that's
true because if you can expand the
center then you just claim space and the
bishop on D2 lpdo you love to say loose
pieces drop off we swap Knights and Rook
d8 at the end we'll win that Bishop on
D2
and I should point out Rook F to d8
looks like it doesn't matter it does
here the queen drops back to F3 and
makes contact with the Rook you have to
put this particular Rook on d8 in order
to win the bishop since Knight takes D5
is impossible you essentially have to
allow black to continue his Central
expansion so definitely something that
Parham has to reckon with and calculate
and at this point Robert it's not a
given that he's got time to calculate
all of this he's down to 42 minutes
we're only on move 16. and we saw this
in parham's game against Carlson when
they get got into the end game it was
equal to start but Parham already
started feeling the pressure on the
clock and I think he's reliving a
similar narrative here
it's an unpleasant situation right with
for Parham he's doesn't know if he can
castle and if his King has to remain in
the center that's not going to be
pleasant other ideas that come to mind
Dania even though I don't want to hand
my opponent the bishop pair the move
Bishop G5 right now because we keep
talking about the D5 Square Knight hops
to F5 so if Bishop G5 is played I don't
I need for castles as soon as I'm
talking about an alternative I see I
don't especially want to take that
Knight on E3 but at least that kind of
clears my head from some of the threats
that white had so Bishop G5 is not out
of the question going forward in this
one and Bishop E7 to G5 is a very
typical move in these kind of svechnikov
structures so there's definitely a a
precedent for that kind of move I'm
going to predict that Prague does play
Rook a D1 and actually going to predict
that he plays it pretty quickly trying
to combine pressure in the center with
pressure on Parham maksud loose clock
and if black takes the plunge and plays
F5 Robert we are going to get another
ridiculously explosive middle game
fireworks will be on this board and but
probably not he has five points out of
ten games he had a plus score but he has
lost some games lately he lost to uh
gukesh his compatriot that was an
unpleasant game for him it was a wild
Affair but this one feels more measured
from Prague the white piece is
everything is under control for now
there is no tension between any of the
pieces so it's about coming up with a
plan one idea I have done it is the move
I mentioned it earlier B4 for white
because I want to kick this knight from
C5 I think it's a very good piece and if
your knight retreats to D7 then I play
the Thematic A4 and what I'm trying to
do is chisel at the black queen side and
go after the A6 Pawn in the long run the
Knight on E3 is perfectly placed because
when you swap on A4 here the Knight
protects that pawn on C2 it also helps
white play C2 to C4 in the near future
so I think that
it's a good time for white to strike so
after B4 instead of retreating with the
Knight the Knight can go to A4 but I'm
wondering if you could take on A4 and
then try to quickly get the move C4 in
I'm not sure I can play it now or if
they play Rook C1 first but I am trying
to break on the queen side
I think that's a great idea and once you
do play C4 ultimately you can try to
smoke this bishop out of E6 and then our
old friend Knight D5 uh could be a
rather unwelcome guest or Parham I think
B4 is actually an excellent move
probably even better than Rook 881 and
you made a very insightful point there
about the Knight on E3 defending the C2
pawn and I think this speaks to the
importance of putting your pieces on
good squares when you do that you find
that those pieces actually play roles
that you don't even expect like in a
different line suddenly that piece is
doing something very very useful that
really is the magic of strong positional
play when you look at karpov games or
Capo Blanca games you see that exact
thing happen he puts a piece on a score
for one reason but then that piece ends
up serving three or four different
purposes
yes and I think in this particular
position the Knight would be able to hop
back to B6 and control A4 and C4 you see
the advantage in White's favor but at
least this position here it seems like
White's plans are not easy to make work
so we'll see how this one goes here I
think that it's a big moment for Prague
Nama he has plenty of time but if we
zoom out for a second we do have end
games that I just want to quickly touch
upon in the top right the game between
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so the Rooks
have come off it means we will be in a
queen and minor piece ending and Magnus
he doesn't look like he's exasperated
for a long fight he looks like he's
ready to shake hands in the near future
in the top left we have the end game
between Anish giri and norierbeck Abdus
atarov it's a double night ending where
each side has an extra Pawn on opposite
flanks white has an extra Pawn on F3
compared to Black on the king side black
has an extra Pawn on B7 on the queen
side so it's a tail of two sides of the
boards and then finally the end game in
the bottom left I think levada Ronin
Fabiana carwana that might be like a
result that is gonna happen soon we've
been talking about end games just like
this and it looks like Fabiano has
equalized without any issue in the
bottom left and currently Fabiano is
down a pawn but if I'm looking at the
position right he is going to win that
pawn by four shall we take a quick look
at that game we we might very well see a
result in the next couple of minutes
yeah so
as we look at that position currently
you would be forgiven for thinking that
white is playing for two results white
is up a pawn but you have to look at it
really black is threatening to take the
Knight and then to recapture the pawn on
F2 and you could say no problem I'm just
gonna play F3 that's exactly what
levonne aronia did I think Fabi is still
gonna take that Knight on D3 and then
shift The Rook over to G1 winning the
pawn on G3 and if white tries to
counter-attack the F5 Pawn black can
always defend it by bringing the king up
to F6 I think we're gonna get either a
repetition Robert or a draw for very
very shortly
yeah White's ponds are vulnerable and
even if it's a simple swap of Bishop for
Knight we talked about how those end
games are often drawn despite the fact
that black is down upon so Fabiano has
been quite steady with the black pieces
in this tournament against abusatara he
drew an end game like this now against
Lavon we see the trade and the look on
these two players faces Tanya right it's
the we're gonna make a draw soon aren't
we
yeah that tournament I I've been
referencing in this commentary in in
Corsica where drawers were forbidden uh
I Had A Moment Like This against it's
yenba Crow or we went into an opposite
colored Bishop end game with four pawns
each and we can't offer a draw so what
would happen is we would look up at each
other we'd kind of smile and that smile
can mean only one thing both of us know
that the time has come for us to repeat
moves so I started playing Bishop B7 to
A8 and he started playing Bishop B2 to
A1
and we were laughing at the end of that
game
uh well here neither player laughing at
the moment but it looks like we did see
a trade on D3 so uh the king is out on
D3 for Levon and that means that now
black can go Pawn hunting you can go
after the G Pawn as
we saw him do and Lavon is like all
right maybe I'll go Rook B5 but King F6
can just defend that pawn and I think
that's the draw we're gonna see you said
Bishop B7 Bishop A8 Bishop B2 Bishop A1
in your game yeah I think we'll see Rook
B5 King F6 Rook B6 check King G7 and
that's the repetition that's going to
happen
yeah definitely I could also go King G5
there
uh which might Force the draw as well
I'd also point out there is I think an
important line rugby five has been
played after King F6 white could try
King E3 Rook takes G3 and King F4 but
fortunately Fabby could drop the Rook
back to G5 simultaneously attacking H5
and defending F5 you're absolutely right
Rook B6 check on the board
and let's stay on this game because we
are about to get a three-time repetition
and a draw
yes lavon's like is there that King E3
move that Daniel was just measuring nope
black defends with that we're coming to
G5 so he knows that the draw is about to
happen and with the white pieces it's
to some extent a spoiled opportunity not
that it's easy to beat any of these top
players and there the draw is agreed so
levonne Ronin five minute car wanna
split the point these two friends uh
they have had decisive games between
them in the past but today it was
friendly and they're going to talk about
it lavon's saying did I have some
chances here but Fabiano with the good
preparation knowing what end games he
could reach with safety and so they both
moved to six points out of 11 games done
I have to say the preparation today
across the board of the black pieces has
been nothing short of superb Notre break
up just a toroff Wesley so and of course
Fabiana carwana all neutralizing their
dangerous opponents seemingly with very
little effort and Fabiano essaying the
tarash I always like it when relatively
rare lines make an appearance in top
level chess and we've seen this more and
more lines that have a dubious
reputation when you analyze them very
carefully with an engine you often find
that there is new life to be breathed
into them and that's precisely what
Fabiano caruana did is the Players
amicably exchanging some dialogue I
think the Arbiter told them to take it
outside
well that's not very amicable is it
right look you should take this outside
you too they're not going to go fight
you know outside they're just going to
continue their conversation maybe
they'll get dinner together as I
mentioned these two are very very good
friends and in the top left between
Anish giri and no deerback Abdus atarov
were in that end game it's two nights
for each side we have five pods for each
side but the punches aren't on the same
file so maybe we should tune in to the
game between Abdul sitar of the black
pieces and each year with white just to
see if there is life left in this
position does any security retain
winning chances because he would love to
overtake the leader of the tournament
he most definitely would let's go to
that game it is currently black to move
Notre back with just a a Oodles of time
here so I don't think that the clock is
in any way going to act uh on the result
of the game currently black snide on C5
is hanging so it's a major dilemma for
black because you can defend the knight
in several different ways you can play
King to D6 you could play the move B6
although I would seriously hesitate to
create light square holes on the queen
side or the knight from C5 could jump
forward it could jump back Robert I
never liked it when I had a situation
with four or five candidate moves and
it's really not easy to choose it's not
easy to figure out what distinguishes
one move from another
King D6 from Knight D7
what do you think Notre Beck is going to
choose here okay I think I can
distinguish one line if KD6
Knight B4 to D5 there's a tactical trick
if you take on defense oh yes I will
Knight F5 check that's beautiful because
if your king goes to C6 I take e takes
D5 with check and then I win your G7
pawn and I have a pass d-pawn gonna win
this game and if your team stepped in
the other direction the E6 Knight takes
G7 is check
and I I take on I get I guess I could
take on D5 as well but I thought you'd
think even simpler but here I think you
just promote because King D you don't go
D6 on the next move because the king
drops back you actually go King D6 and
then King C7 and the red carpet has been
unrolled for the d-pawn
wow wow night night end games are red
nitsky's worst nightmare you spelled
nightmare wrong there's a k missing from
the start uh but that pawn End Game King
of pony would be winning but uh Daniel I
was just saying I guess you're right
because if you go to that position one
more time Knight D5 Knight takes Knight
out of five check
uh King E6 Knight takes G7 check looks
incredibly tempting you're stealing a
pawn uh you're the King has to go
somewhere both the Black Knights are
hanging so white wins this way but your
line is more forcing it gives back no
hope and it ends the game on the spot so
I like that you did not take that pawn
on G7 like I did it said taking on D5
with the pawn and making sure that you
get a new Queen
well night end Games part of the reason
they're so complex and they're such a
nightmare is because it's essentially
two end games rolled into one there's
obviously a high probability of the
knights getting swapped so you're
constantly having to evaluate the
resulting Pawn end games which are no
easy matter to calculate and on top of
that you're also looking at the Knight
end game itself in the event that the
knights are not traded right now we have
four Knights on the board but there's a
high probability that at least one of
them is going to get traded you're right
King D6 is a grave Heir I think we've
basically narrowed it down to Knight D7
and Knight A4 and between those two
moves Robert I don't see a reason I was
gonna say I don't see a reason for black
to seek Adventures but Notre Beck he
does indeed drop the Knight onto A4 and
we see Erin love me there that is the
Dutch Grandmaster who has worked with
anishikiri for many many years he keeps
coming over and looking he's playing the
Challenger section but he's looking at
anisha's game and he's I think the
reason why he's like hmm is because the
knight from B4 can drop back to D3 and
that already creates a huge threat that
uh moving the night out of the way
allows the king to slide over because
the White Knight would love to jump into
the C5 square with check winning
material it's also putting pressure on
the E5 pod so Black's position is not
easy at all Donya I actually think that
after Knight D3 if the Black Knight
decides to take a step back with Knight
B6 check the white king will end up on
B5 Super Active there and I'm liking
anisha's chances in the end game I just
think it's not easy for no dearbeck to
play and yet I look at his clock he
spent very little time this game he
seems to feel that everything is under
control
but I'll tell you what I think Knight A4
might have been an inaccuracy because if
you compare that to Knight to D7 after
Knight D3 black would have had time to
play the move King D6 covering the C5
square and in that position Knight F5 is
uh entirely innocuous in fact you know
only black can be better in that
resulting Knight end game so the chief
difference is that after Knight D3 black
and still play King D6 but then you're
gonna have to reckon with King to B4 and
Knight to C4 check that Knight on A4 is
just a loose cannon it can be attacked
several different ways I think if Anish
plays Knight D3 he'll probably have the
most chances he's had all game and
Robert he has to be thrilled to be
playing for two results given how this
game started
for sure and this is a really nice
position for Geary he has nothing to
worry about he has exited the stage
where he's looking at his opponent like
what do you have prepared for me
preparation's gone that's a thing of the
past that's to worry about for a future
game but the near future in this one is
about the black queen side pawns will
they be safe and sound that King on C4
is very active here
um you don't want to rush with bringing
your king up the board because you'll
face some night checks but White's Pawn
structure is healthier the E5 Pawn that
can be a long-term Target to exploit and
the Knight on A4 is just a bit out of
the way I'm not sure why it's there it
will likely Retreat to B6 next it's
almost pre-movable but it could have
gone to D7 and kept everything compact
to begin with so I just think that Niche
has some chances left not that he has an
advantage I mean it's ever so slight but
I just think that the eval bar is
deceiving at this stage I think that
White's winning chances are there and
Anish will try to make the most of those
chances
and before we travel back to the bird's
eye view I think there's a very
insightful question uh from Bob Mc Joe
in the chat who asks if we could provide
our opinion on whether it is worth for
white to push his King side pawns and
what I would say to that is probably not
I mean you would only push your punts in
general you want to avoid unnecessary
pawn moves in the end game because every
time you push upon up you necessarily
create a weakness if you play G3 then F3
is undefended if you push the H Pawn
then that H Pawn could be the target of
a bloodthirsty night so the only reason
you would push your king side pawns
would be to to make a past Pawn or maybe
to play G3 and F4 but I think for the
time being the center of action the
battlefield is on the queen side that is
where I don't think it's an exaggeration
to say the game is likely to be decided
so one way or the other I always like to
say a pawn chain is only as strong as
its base Pawn the pawn on G2 is very far
away from Black's pieces as soon as you
push that pawn F3 becomes the base of
the pawn chain and that's more
approachable to the Black Knights now
pushing the H Pawn it may make sense in
some positions we keep talking about how
white is essentially up a pawn from the
e to the H file so you would love to
create a past Pawn the issue is that
Black's King is perfectly placed if
you're trying to create a pass Pawn
you're not going to get it or you're
going to create a pawn that can be
attacked so I think that it's a little
bit too early to think about pressing
forward on the king side and I think the
move Knight D3 already has a legitimate
threat the Knight going back to D3 hopes
to hop to C5 and White's next move is
bringing the king over to B4 to kick
that Knight out of A4 so I think Knights
and D3 and E3 look as solid as it gets
and then you can decide is the moment
right to push those but indeed Niche
sensing the importance of this moment
investing quite a deal of time and I
just ran a search in my games I have
never had uh an end game like this with
two knights against two nights I think
it's such a treat uh that we get to see
so many different unique not only types
of openings but also types of end games
and types of positions this is expanding
my own knowledge of the end game awesome
stuff in Gary Abdus tour of and I'm
pleasantly surprised because when they
entered this end game I somehow thought
things would fizzle out but now my
opinion has changed and I think the
leader of the tournament has his work
cut out for him if Anish plays Knight D3
yeah it's uh and he does
wow you said if he was like when he did
it immediately after you said it he was
what did you say four years I said hit
the road I said Hit the Road Jack uh you
ain't coming back no more but that night
did just come back it's my Gallup Ford
to C5 in the near future and no deerback
needs to figure out what to do and while
he does that maybe we can back out of
this game it's going to be an
interesting moment but there still are
five other games going on what catches
your eye look at that bottom well bottom
left is a draw but to the right of that
we're following a line that We examined
White made the huge mistake of trusting
our producer Bic and we know where that
leads right Robert Knight F5 was played
and Parham immediately grabbing the
Knight on F5 and thrusting the pawn up
to D5 a move that I think Prague very
likely missed and I think the landscape
of that position might be changing
okay that is a definite change and good
news for maksudlu I'm looking at the
second from the right the game between
dingley Wren and Jordan Von Forest that
one has reached an end game so there
were tactics Galore in the earlier
stages but now we are in a position
where both sides have a pair of Rooks
it's a knight versus the bishop and once
again pawns on different sides of the
board so uh Jordan seems to have
obtained a very nice position
yeah and I guess the white chances
really depend on whether he could make
something of that a pawn as long as
there are all four Rooks on the board I
really don't see that hey Pawn moving
past A3 but if ding can get one pair of
Rooks off I think at that point he will
essentially be playing for two results
so Jordan has to try to keep all of the
pieces on the board and generate counter
play perhaps by swinging the H Rook over
to the B file and then involving the
Knight one way or the other either
through C5 or maybe in some cases
through F6 and D5 but I agree completely
I think Jordan has more than solved all
of his problems and he should not lose
this game barring some sort of major
mistake
mistakes do happen it's been a grueling
event 13 Rounds in total we are around
11 right now uh why don't we check in to
see how Magnus is doing against Wesley
because in the top right of our screens
here it looks like just an equal end
game and you don't want to make that
mistake against Max you don't assume
it's going to be a draw just because it
is level but done it if I'm being honest
and I always try to be honest with you
partner this looks like it is extremely
equal how do you see a future where
magnets can even push for a win
well I think
to Envision that scenario just it's
impossible to calculate this because
both sides have so many candidate moves
you just have to kind of forecast
General scenarios I think the absolute
best case scenario for white worst case
scenario for black is the situation in
which y drives the pawn up to B5 in
order to fix Black's two pawns on on
dark squares and then somehow manages to
trade queens and you see what I'm saying
I think ultimately like gets the bishop
to B8 and wins the base Pawn on A7 but
there's so many ifs involved in that
equation and you know you'd stop on the
very first step like how are you
actually going to get the pawn up to B5
well I think Magnus should seriously
contemplate the move before but Wesley's
not just going to sit around he's going
to play B5 himself then support that
pawn with A6 the queen on C8 it may look
passive but it's actually very very well
placed because it's guarding the back
rank it's protecting A6 and it's
supporting the Knight and the Knight of
course is deprived the white Bishop of
its access to the long diagonal so for
the most part Robert I'm on the same
page with you and I think if we just
pause in the position you have on screen
there let's say uh White just puts the
queen on e4 I just want to get a
particular looking position Queen E4 A6
so we get the pawns on the light squares
that means the end games the bishop
can't possibly attack those pawns that's
really good news for black so if white
hopes to win you'll have to push your
king side pawns maybe play G4 H4 H5 just
hope that you can create a dent in
Black's solid King side position that
seems unlikely now that doesn't mean
it's impossible but I just don't see
where you crack Black's defensive setup
and if that's the case then Wesley so is
well on his way to securing a half point
in this game as long as black manages to
get his pawns on light squares I think
it's a dead draw for instance if white
plays a move like H4 black can always
drive the queen up to E6 and uh yeah the
pawn on E6 is isolated congratulations
but white has zero ways to make inroads
at night on C6 is so nicely covering the
potential infiltration Square on D4 this
is the dead draw
Magnus might try before he might also in
the Life position try a move like Queen
D6 but Robert that move looks very
menacing but it carries absolutely no
threats I feel like it's a paper tiger
yeah it does not actually have any
threats as you're saying and for megas
Carlson you can't expect him to win
every single game he's done a whole lot
of winning in the last bunch of rounds
if we look at his results he has won
three of his past four games there was
the drug against kukesh but he beat
Richard report live in a carwana and
Parham two of those wins with the black
pieces Wesley so is a veteran he is
super experienced he's won the Grinch
chess tour he's won the chest.com global
Championship he's won the Fisher random
World Championship he has many
tournament victories to his name now the
the last two opponents were Magnus
prognanda and Arjun aragaisi they have
yet to win those big events because
they're teenagers so I think that Magnus
if he draws this game he's not going to
be happy about the results but he still
has two games against very talented
players but players that in Prague Nanda
I know he beat him in vikonze's past
that's with the white piece is and then
Arjun air geising not having a great
tournament those are what you would see
as potentially winnable games for
magnets to end the tournament on the
right note
I mean regardless of how the world
champion finishes the tournament the
fact that we are even talking about a
scenario in which Magnus might win the
tournament speaks to just the incredible
nature of his comeback Magnus was dead
in the water he was minus one he had
lost two games in a row for the first
time since 2015 and now he looks like a
completely different player and this is
the Hallmark of a virtuoso you know this
is the Hallmark of an all-time great
somebody who was able to adjust on the
Fly take a tournament in which they're a
nightmarish form and transform it into
at the very least a very decent
performance and at the very most an
absolutely stunning combat Victory if
Magnus can deliver in the clutch
well he clutches the chest pieces starts
playing with them as is you know typical
chess player I knew you would do that I
knew he would use that word somehow I
just knew it I'm just letting you know
that I listened to you and I show you
that not by telling you that I'm using
the words that you say and magnus's
three wins the black pieces to boot
super impressive when he could have just
tilted that is true pudding snack you're
making me hungry with your username but
you're also uh telling the truth the
three wins with the black pieces in this
tournament it has been some good results
when having the second move but Wesley
so in this game looking like a
formidable foe so I do think we should
zoom out of here after this moment and
go to the bird's eye view because a game
that you actually mentioned one that has
changed quite a lot is the game between
pragnananda and maxulu that is second
from the left on the bottom row there we
see a different Pawn structure than we
left off so why don't we just like the
players dive into the position and
because I actually really like how it's
transformed for para
yeah We examined this variation if we
bring up the analysis board after Parham
castled kingside I really liked your
recommendation before but Prague going
directly for Black's throat on the king
side with Knight F5 we discussed G takes
F5 but Parham on alert taking correctly
with the bishop and then driving the
pawn up to D5 lpdo exploiting the
undefended nature of the bishop but
progress in panic and instead he
tightens the screws on the king side the
last move is Bishop H6 posing black with
a dilemma where is Parham going to put
his Rook well Robert I don't think it's
much of a dilemma if you're moving The
Rook you move it to d8 I think the
Dilemma consists of the question do you
want to first play the movie for or is
that counterproductive because it
weakens dark squares and or allows the
queen to move on to a better Square what
do you think
yeah I think the dark Square problem is
real so if you play E4 you may be
handing important squares in the center
of the board look at those pawns on E5
and D5 draw the arrows of the squares
they're keeping under their control D4
E4 and C4 right look at those pawns are
limiting your drifting White's pieces so
when you move them you have to be fully
certain that it's the right thing to do
because otherwise giving your opponent
some options and you can't take the move
back I don't think E4 is bad I think
it's a perfectly good move I just think
if I were playing the game I would play
Rook F to d8 and save that pawn push for
a later time
agree completely especially given the
time situation you just don't want to
commit this quickly when there's no
necessity of doing so I don't think E4
is a terrible move but after Rook have
to get I'm just wondering what exactly
how exactly Prague wants to keep the
Flames of the initiative going on uh the
king side well the obvious move here to
me is rotated E1 in order to put more
pressure on the D5 Pawn now you
definitely I thought want to refrain
from the move d4 but from a positional
standpoint because you give away control
of this crucial E4 Square the eval bar
though believes that black can
concretely make this work with some dark
magic apparently Knight takes E4 Queen
takes E4 and now an old friend Knight to
A4 enables black to put significant
pressure on White's Queen side pawns
potentially swing the Knight back to C5
knocking the queen out of its formidable
post on e4 but all of this is so hard to
see with only 36 minutes on the clock
block I think Parham in this situation
would be much more likely to Simply
defend the pawn on D5 with a move like
Queen C6
that Knight A4 idea is such a pain for
white to deal with because those pawns
on the queen side they're not defended
all of White's pieces the whole Army is
starting to get focused towards the king
side there's a bishop on H6 if your
queen could join the party there could
be a checkmating attack but that seems
very far away so it's a situation after
Knight excuse me Bishop H6
um where I would slide The Rook over for
black because I just don't think that
you want to make your choice is it going
to be D4 is it going to eat the E4 you
don't know just yet and that's why I
like rook d8 and as you were showing in
that variation
um D4 is accessible for black to get a
knight to A4 you can play Queen C6 as
you're highlighting just continue to
keep that status quo and what is white
doing Queen G3 going after the E5 Pawn
can black not simply defend it maybe
even with the bishop going to F6 at some
moment
yeah Bishop F6 is totally possible here
the evil bar shoots up just a little bit
but I would take any movement of the
evil bar with a grain of salt this
position would be hard to evaluate even
for the computer and you know what I
would consider here for Prague
especially if Parham takes quite a bit
more time on these moves I would
consider just going all out play F takes
G6 and now just play F4 and try to tear
open that f file I don't think this is
just sort of a foolish you know fake
Mikhail tall idea you're not actually
sacrificing anything as Brazen as it
looks you're trying to drive the pawn up
to F5 and if black takes it and suddenly
black is experiencing major difficulties
down the FL because the F7 Pawn is loose
so this is what I'd be worried about if
I'm Parham
wow that position we can just go back a
half move there before E takes F4 I was
wondering can black play D4 because of
course I want to bring my knight to E4
but after D4 there's F takes E5 and D
takes C3 and I see the evaluation bar
react okay I guess F takes E5 oh it's
it's not even certain this is how crazy
the position is that Eva bar is going up
and down like a seesaw and then it's
still in a position that is very
difficult Oh My Success
Rook takes F6 and this is just a case in
point right imagine having this position
five moves into a line you're looking at
this position who in their right mind
would go for it with black well
apparently there's the move Queen takes
F6 cool as a cucumber after ef6 Robert
you called it that Queen side is totally
neglected and white pays the price for
that in several of the variations we've
examined just look at this beautiful
position and I'll tell you something
even crazier white can try Queen H4
after B1 Bishop G7 it looks like made on
h8 is inevitable but just look at this
takes and I can't even do a whoop sound
because uh I've been talking quite a bit
in the last few days but after Queen H5
black brings the queen back just in time
how can you calculate all of this with
30 minutes on the clock
I don't have an answer to that and the
players will need to let their move do
the talking because it's such a
complicated battle the eval bar we have
that at our disposal the players do not
so knowing if the push is okay knowing
if that attack on the king side will
work out for white or black is first to
the queen side it is kind of an attack
on the queen side so you need to be very
careful if you're probably not of the
good news is he's up on the clock so
we'll leave him to it for now uh we'll
go back to our view of all six games
they're still in session I just saw in
these curious King on the top left King
has ventured out to the B5 Square so on
the flip side of this break we'll find
out does anishakiri have what it takes
to win his first Tata steel event he
needs a decisive result in this game or
will not Rebecca Taro maintain his lead
over the field that is the big press in
the round we'll find out more later in
this round but for now we'll take a
break more to come in just a few minutes
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level you're
getting started on the fundamentals you
should check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you did you not notice your
king was in check and still can't figure
out why the pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun
winds that is losing thing move
once again Vicon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps win eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is gone peaceful if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Geary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps mustard
leads Viking Zay he is already a legend
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
[Music]
we see the playing Hall in Vikings say
it is bustling with energy and tons of
thought and calculation many people from
the Masters Tournament all the way down
to the open boards they are trying to
figure out the best move and well while
they do that let's just set the record
straight let's remind everybody what
we're doing here I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess alongside me is Grandmaster Daniel
narodiski this is the 11th round of the
Tata steel chess tournament 2023 this is
known as The Wimbledon of Chess it's the
85th Edition down here it's so rich with
history The Who's Who of Chess have
played in Vikings a and this year brings
the highest rated average field in
history
indeed it does you don't earn a name a
moniker like The Wimbledon of Chess by
accident and I don't think a single
person in the entire world a single
chess fan disputes that name Tata steel
has such a story tradition everybody has
played in it for Max irva that only
Dutch world champion to botmanik it's a
spaski name a Grandmaster they have
played and cherished their time in the
tiny Dutch Seaside town the tournament
actually used to be in the nearby city
of by for like but tournament Robert is
one and the same 85 years
85 years and some of the players in the
field not even in their 20s and one
player in particular has stood out that
is nodier Beck Abdul satara he may be a
teenager but he is super strong and
right now he leads this field seven
points from 10 games he is playing Anish
giri the person in second place while
Magus Carlson and Wesley so who are tied
in third they are playing each other
levonne aronian Fabio caruana in fifth
and sixth respectively they drew their
game against each other so all of the
top players are competing against one
another that's super exciting and the
second half of the tournament the
players who have been struggling a bit
they still are going to leave their mark
on this field Richard report has won a
few games down in recent ones gukesh he
is one two out of his last three games
with a draw in between so even though
they're in the second half of the
standings they are still playing some
very good games and this just tells you
you how evenly matched everybody is
let's not forget the Jordan men Forest
one taught a steal two years ago
defeating Anish giri in a rapid
tiebreaker in this particular Edition he
sits on 12th Place he said a rather
mediocre performance but the magic of a
tournament like Tata steel is first of
all that somebody in the bottom half of
the tournament cross table has the
potential to impact the top half with a
well-timed win or even a draw and of
course the second element is that
someone like Richard report or who Kesh
can still continue to play exciting
chess and can still continue to
entertain chess fans even if he doesn't
have the potential to win the tournament
that's not the only thing that matters
in a tournament as prestigious and
storied as this
it's true every player that is invited
to this event they are known for their
fighting spirit for their Love of the
Game and they are going to put on a show
for the many Spectators in the hall and
as we see these six boards still in
session in the top left Anish gear
against
a pair of knights have been traded and
so we see an end game of night and Five
Pawns per side and he's scary trying to
win this game because of his active King
Tanya I think that no deerback he's
playing this super well he has proven
himself every single round in this event
and when he needs to hold with the black
pieces I think he is on the right track
motorbikes and games I think this is an
underrated narrative Robert norderbeck's
end games this tournament have been
astounding Magnus Carlson is not an easy
player to just outplay from a slightly
better end game yet that's exactly what
notrebec did in that Queen end game
Vincent kymer
people were shoveling dirt on Notre back
in that pawn down Rook End Game Bang he
holds a draw and now again confidently
with over an hour on the clock it seems
like notrepeck isn't even giving Anish
giri the tiniest iota of counter play in
this end game I don't think a niche can
make anything of his King on C5 he's
sort of looking up at the skies there
yeah that King is active but Notre back
is not going to push either of his pawns
he's got the impregnable fortress on the
queen side and on the king side with his
last move G7 G5 he makes sure that Anish
will never be able to orchestrate any
Shenanigans with F4 I think we are
rapidly moving toward a peaceful results
there's only one thing that I could
think of of how white makes progress
let's say in this position we can bring
up an analysis board white tries to
bring the Knight towards the black queen
side pawns which don't have Defenders
nearby so let's say white makes the move
Knight to C4 uh bringing the Knight
forward and try trying to attack the B7
Pawn
if black plus H6 for example I just want
to show that Knight D6 is not possible
because B6 check forces the king away
from the Knight and wins that piece on
the spot the 97 comments
I wonder why the night I need to restart
my computer
darn it I'm getting old eyes are not
what they used to be the same reply is
after night A5 B6 is check forking the
king and the Knight so I just want to
point that out because if instead of H6
black plays the move uh Knight C6 now
Knight D6 is actually available because
B6 check drops your own Knight on C6 so
there are little tricks and traps that
no direct has to be careful to avoid
because if your knight is forced back in
that variation after Knight C6 Knight D6
just to you know one move deeper
black is in the back rank you're getting
very passive there and that's not the
defensive posture you want where the
white knight is hopping left and right
and just trying to create wiggle room
for that King that is active on C5
you're exactly right and at this point
white can continue poking and prodding
at the queen side with Knight B5 and the
moment you can get black to push one of
his Queen side pawns you can see the
eval bar shooting up like Apollo 12
right there like a rocket because white
gets now access to this very important
B6 square and black is going to be
completely tied up black is going to
have to bring his King back and that
means well who is going to defend these
incredibly weak pawns on the king side
so Black's defensive construction hinges
on his ability to keep his pawns where
they are so that white knight and
White's King neither peace is able to
infiltrate the queen side anishkiri
could continue making attempts he could
maybe push his Pawn up to A5 but at the
end of the day Robert I think that's
water under the bridge I simply do not
see a single way
for right to break through on the queen
side if of course as you pointed out
Notre back is not self-destruct
well you're mentioning Apollo 12. in
each game might have to be like Apollo
Creed he might have to give it as all
and leave it in the ring because you
know he has a night end game with an
active King he needs to find a way
forward it just doesn't look possible
and these two have not played each other
much over the board in classical chess
they have only played three times before
this game they have drawn all three of
their games so their history is quite
short that's what happens when you're
playing a teenager right no no deerback
is only uh become on the scene in recent
years and the second bullet point is the
most important one the winner of this
match will have the tournament lead if
the draw that means abducator maintains
his lead but that is what they are
playing for the stakes are very high
they are indeed and I was mesmerized
during the break by notorbeck's rating
progress he was rated 26-33 in December
of 2021. exactly one year ago on the
January supplement he was two six four
one not only has he crossed 27-13 but
the guy now leads the strongest
tournament one of the strongest
tournaments ever held we sometimes take
the progress of these young players for
granted Robert we should not because
this is absolutely
unprecedented juicy toroff is three wins
and two draws of the black pieces these
young guys what they're pulling off is
just absolutely unreal
he's showing that it's not just youthful
energy that is leading him to Victory I
mean he has great technique as you
mentioned in his against Vincent kymer
he was almost lost in fact Vince should
have won the game but it was that
tenacity to stay in it and winning three
games with the black pieces in this
field abusatar has proven game after
game that he is the real deal there's a
reason why Uzbekistan won the Olympiad
gold and it's because of this I was
gonna say man but you know he's a man
he's a teenager but it's this chess
player who is staring his opponent down
he fears no one
he fears no one indeed and the talent
coming out of Uzbekistan Torah of course
is the headline talent but not the only
one you have sundara who is playing in
the Challenger section and the quitting
himself quite well you have vakirov and
uh you've got a couple of 12 and 13 year
olds who are now over 2400 and just an
exciting new crop of talent that keeps
growing and growing Uzbekistan want the
Olympiad and they will be a force to be
reckoned with for many many years to
come so so cool it's such a great time
to be a chess fan
it is the Olympiad uh the that team
everyone wanted photos with them I
actually took the same flight out of
Chennai with the Uzbekistan team and
they had their trophy they were wearing
their suits even to the airport and
everyone there wanted a photo with them
I did not ask for a photo Donna all I
did was I take no deer back to the side
talked to him about his success
congratulate him and saying that I hope
this is just the start of a really
illustrious career and I do want to add
that he is so grateful for all the
opportunities that he has to play chess
uh part of our conversation was him
telling me that that he feels like the
online tournaments really have helped
him because he was a familiar name to
those who are in the chest circles Deep
In The Weeds of the chassis but he
became a household name based on his
successes in pretty much every online
tournament and then he skyrocketed over
2700 and he's not slowing down because
of his success to this point in the
shots of Steel he's around 27.35 he
could go all the way up to 2740 plus
he's in the top 20 players in the world
and he's showing that it's not just
alireza faruza he is not the only
teenager that you should keep an eye on
it's abdusitarov it is uh our generic I
see guccesh Vincent kymer prognan to all
the players you see in this field and
abdusitarov in many ways has led the
charge over the last year while ferrugia
has been quite quiet not really playing
all that much outside the candidates
where he didn't have a very good event
now dearbeck led his country to bolt and
he is not stopping there
no he is not and is it really a surprise
that the playing Hall there at wake and
see is teeming with Spectators who want
to catch a glimpse of this generational
Talent as you can see that big crowd
gathered behind the barrier watching the
Masters and the challengers at play as
the world champion
walks back and forth he doesn't want to
look at his position his position's too
boring
and uh what a scene what an atmosphere
in uh in the Dutch town of Wake On say
how great that Wake On say you say that
word and most people associate it
immediately with the tournament not a
coincidence and a very well deserved
reputation
for sure I'm in the tournament is among
the best in history only a handful of
tournaments can compete with it in terms
of its stature and its average rating
and just the Champions who have walked
through those Halls and in each Geary
you saw that look on his face I think
he's might be thinking that his Champion
run for this year is going to be another
year where he might have to settle for a
second he is in second place right now
there still are two games after this
round concludes but he needed this game
done yeah I feel like with the white
pieces against the person in front of
you you need to take care of business
when you sit across the board from the
player in first well two players had
that task in front of the Magnus Carlson
was the other and neither Anish nor
Magnus really able to to do anything
against their opponents superb opening
preparation well we will keep an eye on
Anish Gary's attempts to squeeze
something out of this end game but hey
he's got to be careful he's down to 17
minutes you definitely do not want to
overpress here as we go back to our
bird's eye view one game has already
concluded that's bottom left aronian
caruana with a relatively uneventful
draw Carlson and Wesley so are very
likely to follow as are I would add
aragaisi and gukesh that's uh bottom
right hand side of your screen they've
got what seems to me uh to be a dead
equal end game Robert despite the minor
peace and balance I really don't think
that either side has any realistic
winning chances
yeah the only boards with many pieces
remaining is second from the left
between pragnada and maksulu Parham he
has the upper hand in that one now as he
is first to the action over there on the
queen side and the one in the middle and
the bottom row Vincent kymer with white
Richard reported black only two pawns
have been traded for each side and white
is just a bit more active you see that
Knight on C4 is staring into the enemy
territory so I like Vincent Cameron's
position I think he's just a bit better
and it's comfortable to play and same
goes for Parham maksudu that is more
tactical in nature the maksudu game but
I think that Vincent kheimer and Parham
both can be happy about their current
positions yeah Max sudlu has landed a
night on A4 we discussed several lines
where that move
is incredibly Troublesome for white
given the paucity of pieces on the queen
side that B2 Pawn is hanging and the C2
Pawn is going to hang if the knight from
C3 uh is smoked out and it is very
likely to be because black simply
threatens to take the Knight on C3 so a
trade is likely in prognananda might
have overextended himself on the king
side he is gonna have to press on the
gas pedal if he doesn't want to end up
losing his entire Queen side and having
nothing to show for it another game
Robert that we haven't looked at in a
while is of course the dingley run
against Jordan van Forest I feel like
they've been on the same position for
like ages like every time I look it's
that same end game position do you see
what I'm saying
yeah so why don't we look at that game
it's second from the right dingley Ren
against Jordan Von forest and things
have changed but only a little bit the
players are in an end game uh Jordan fun
forest with the great opening
preparation and now that we're here
donium it is Five Pawns two Rooks and a
minor piece per side but it's a knight
against a bishop the pawns on different
sides of the boards if we trade off all
the Rooks we'll see that A3 Pawn become
a healthy past pawn and that's very
dangerous for black to deal with so that
is why Jordan has put his Rook on A4 and
it's there to stay it protects the C4
pawn it blockades the A3 passer the
Knight on B6 also keeping everything
together The Rook on h8 keeping the
white Rook on H1 honest if you move the
Rook from H1 you just drop that pawn
over there so it seems like it's going
to take time for white I think he needs
to play the H3 at this point and for
black H3 is almost a welcome sight
because look at those dark squares
they're juicy that black king on E7 at
some point can think about putting on
its Nikes and running right into those
dark squares on the king side so H3 for
now it keeps everything defended but in
the long term it could create weaknesses
that are going to be difficult to bend
off that's a great Point yeah King E7
Airlines cleared for takeoff you know
it's easy to say well black doesn't have
a dark squared Bishop but the king can
kind of act in the same exact capacity
another benefit of the move Rook H4 is
that black lands another pair of eyes on
the C4 Pawn which of course but I cannot
afford to lose and I feel like the
reason the eval bar is at a complete uh
is completely levels just because
neither side can really make any
progress as long as all of the pieces
remain on the board black could try to
get the king uh into the center with
both of White's trucks still life but
that of course is associated with no
small amount of danger I feel like after
H3 Jordan could consider a move like
Rook H4 to D4 just centralizing The Rook
making sure it's on a better square and
maybe even supporting The Rook with E5
if I had to choose the side I would
probably choose black just because his
pieces are more active but on the other
hand
is it fair to say that if white doesn't
do anything drastic Jordan's winning
chances are very very limited he can
really never take his eyes off of the C4
pawn and as long as white keeps his
pieces trained onto that pawn
I feel like we're in a bit of a
stalemate here
well one thing that you pointed out that
I wasn't initially considering is that
Rook on H4 defends C4 a second time so
I'm wondering if white plays H3 to free
up the H1 Rook can black play Knight D5
and maybe hop into E3 or F4 and if we
could just put the moves H3 and Knight
D5 on the board I just want to show one
more thing that not only are those dark
squares vulnerable and that Knight would
love to hop in C4 to C3 is kind of a
threat because the b2a3 configuration
there that pawn chain it can be
dislodged with the move C3 and then
we've created weaknesses in White's Camp
last Rooks are very active and I'm
starting to like Jordan's position more
and more I I believe it can hold but he
needs to be very accurate and for ding
in general Tanya this has not been a
good event for him something just seems
off it could be that world champion
preparation that is full attention is on
uh that he doesn't want to use prep that
he's storing for John the Palm Nashi but
it just doesn't feel like the dingly red
we're accustomed to because that
dingleren is the one that defeated hikar
Nakamura in the final round of the
candidates he played with exquisite
Precision uh at end game master class to
win a game that looked almost unwinnable
at first glance but he found the holes
in akaro's position and he was able to
maximize the pluses in his position and
just in this event it feels like he's
been constantly on his back foot
it has and the epitome to me of the
dangling run that we are accustomed to
is that when over uh Richard report
after which digg made his way into the
studio and just rattled off these insane
lines he was cool as a cucumber in a
ridiculously chaotic position navigating
his way through the labyrinthine
complications with with such Grace and
the ding that we see in this tournament
just isn't able to do that of course his
game uh that I mentioned previously
against Anish giri is really a case in
point so it could be a lot of different
things you're absolutely right it could
be that the added weight of the
tournament that's coming up for him
maybe dedicating a little bit too much
of his brain power uh to thinking about
Astana because that's coming right up in
less than three months but whatever it
is the world number two just hasn't had
a memorable event to say the least but I
also just wanted to compliment you on
this idea of C3 because as the Dalai
Lama once said on chains are only as
strong as their base Pawn sorry that was
Robert Hess
well I I don't pretend to be as kind and
considerate but I am considering all the
options in the position in C3 that dark
squares on the king side they look
vulnerable and Jordan Von Forest has not
had a good tournament it's been
memorable but not good on in terms of
results he is blundered upon in I think
four different things so he he needs to
avoid that in this one because if he
blunders something he might be
immediately lost that outside pass Pawn
the A3 Pawn it's really dangerous not
for now because it's completely
blockaded but if you overlook something
that allows white to free up his pieces
Suddenly It's from passive uh staring
into this Pawn on C4 to activity and
that is what black cannot afford to
allow is white getting very active and
some freedom for the pieces
and if things get desperate you could
also consider the idea here of playing
H3 and then playing Rook C1 and then
squeezing the king up to A2 and maybe
trying to play the move B3 and simply
eradicate the pawn on C4 that really
changes the tenor of the position but if
the pawns get traded maybe the bishop
gets into B5 and ultimately maybe white
can try to set his Pawn in motion but
that's very far into the future and
there's a lot of logistical difficulties
on Route not least of which is the fact
that if the Knight sits on D5 King A2 is
never possible because of the night Fork
on B4 so I I really like the way Jordan
has been handling this game fantastic
preparation D take C4 is definitely a
move that's going to be repeated uh
across the top level and uh handling
this end game with tremendous Precision
so far but can he continue in the same
spirit
I really like his position just more
activity white is passive so I think
Jordan is doing a very good job first
good preparation but suddenly he's the
one down on time they're not in time
trouble because they're pretty close to
move 40 and they're not too many pieces
on the board but it is interesting that
suddenly Jordan is the one who is down
the clock
yeah I mean a good expression is work
expands and contracts to fill the time
available to it which refers of course
to the fact that you'll take three
months if that's what you have to work
on an essay and if you have 12 hours
then you'll be able to Rattle it off and
I think something similar happens when
you rattle off a bunch of
fantastic opening preparation you just
find yourself with all this time and
well you're going to use it for one
purpose or another right eventually
you're gonna find something to think
about and I think in this case Jordan
invested a lot of time deciding where to
drop his King back right before they
traded queens and uh obviously he's
playing one of the greatest end game
players of all time so you're probably
gonna take a little bit longer than
usual just double and triple checking
every move especially in the context of
the fact that Jordan has been blunder
prone in this event
you need to calculate he needs to think
and he will do just that as will dingley
run who has a position where his Rook on
H1 tied down if he pushes that H Pawn so
his Rook can be free then the dark
squares are free for black to infiltrate
so it's not an easy decision for dingley
Wren you could see him pondering his
next move because it will change the
trajectory of the game well so while he
does that I think we should zoom out to
our view of all the games uh the top
left and each Geary against Abdul sitar
he made the move G3 just a single move
played a small little Pawn push but I
don't know exactly what he's aiming for
but he hopes that he can somehow make
progress there
yeah I think I need sort of treading
water for the time being try to get
Notre back to put his cards on the table
and orderbreak has a pretty vast Choice
here if he can move his Knight really
anywhere uh but as we already discussed
Knight C8 uh or Knight C6 rather is
associated with uh some problems on
account of whitesnite jumping into D5 so
black definitely has to be careful uh
you don't want to push a queen Side Pawn
and motorbreak has left himself with
plenty of time and I mean plenty he's
got right about an hour to figure out
how to maintain his
seemingly impregnable defensive
Construction
bottom left to the right of Iranian
caruana which is our first result of the
game pragnananda has still Robert not
made a move once that Knight landed on
A4 his Beach upon is hanging is situpon
is hanging and I'm not sure what he has
to show for it on the other side of the
board
honestly things are looking great for
maksudlu and Vincent kymer whose game is
in the center and the bottom row it's a
camera you see the eval bar going up in
his game against Richard report so I
mean that game looks really really nice
for the German teenager and I think we
can just bring that one up because the
move for white seems very thematic and I
believe it's going to net him a sizable
plus here if he you didn't even let me
say it because you're reading my mind
you are the prophet after all a five the
point of A5 is going right after the B6
tender point and if you take on A5 the
Knight Will capture back and look at the
bishop on F1 done it we actually pointed
this out earlier the bishop was doing
good work defending the pawn on G2 but
now it's also staring at the A6 Pawn
which will be cemented in place so if
you play B5 the Knight hops into B6 if
you take on A5 then Knight takes back
and the A6 Pawn is weak you have two
choices neither looks Pleasant it's just
going to be a clear Advantage for
Vincent with zero risk and I think we
kind of called it that pawn breakthrough
d65 which report played just a couple of
booths prior has brought him nothing but
problems the pawn structure is
symmetrical but the peace placement is
not it's like every single piece is
placed on a perfect square while black
these pieces are all clustered on the
king side the Knight on f8 is sort of
stuck in transit and at night on C3 it's
most definitely not stuck in transit it
can Transit itself over to C5 and put
even more pressure on the A6 Pawn
combine that with a clock situation 22
minutes for the uh Romanian Grandmaster
this is not looking good the one thing I
will say Robert is from a psychological
perspective if you're Vincent you have
to avoid getting into what I call Here
We Go Again mode because he knows he's
had two golden opportunities to score a
full point last two games he failed on
both counts of course those were
complicated end games but you've got to
avoid psyching yourself out and kind of
convincing yourself that no matter how
good it looks you're gonna find a way to
mess it up something tells me Vincent is
going to stay composed though I think
Vincent will be composed and we will
come back to this game very shortly but
I do want to take us to the game between
Nish Geary and nodirbec Abdus atarov
because they have been moving very
slowly and I feel like that means that
they're considering their options but
I'm also looking at Anisha he's kind of
got that one hand on his head
seems like he knows what the result of
this game is going to be and I feel like
the draw could happen sooner than we
expect
do you think it's possible that G3 was
accompanied by a drawfer because we know
that kind of body language after a draw
for you kind of look at your opponent
move your head from side to side
something about the demeanor of the
players tells me as you're kind of
implying that the result might be coming
pretty soon
yeah and if you accompany with a draw
for you know how I feel about your
offers generally I I guess I do
understand that this position is
completely even and there isn't much
room to work with there's no weak points
that I will suddenly infiltrate and
cause problems for black so if it was
accompanied by a draw offer then I think
no nearbeck would accept that I mean
very happily maybe he's just looking to
make sure and you know they haven't
reached to move 30 yet so I do believe
that in the tournament they should
reached 30 but we're actually being told
that G3 was a draw for you're correct so
my initial thought was that might be the
case and our producer is telling us that
Anish did offer a draw and now he's
likely just waiting for nadir back to
accept
well the sort of draw rules in this
tournament are pretty unique it's not
that you're forbidden from offering a
dropby form of 30. they're encouraged
but there's exceptions to the rule and
don't Rebecca accepts Anish giri's draw
offer with 50 minutes on his clock from
a position of strength and done it we
can hear them talk so they have a mic
we'll listen to them speak
ing
foreign
we hear the players communicating in
Russian both are fluent Russian speakers
and Donna you are a Russian speaker
yourself what were they talking about
what was their analysis unfortunately I
mean obviously I could not make out
every word I heard the move Knight D5
quintupettes mentioned many times
uh I think they're discussing whether or
not white had any chances in that end
game they were talking about a couple of
concrete lines I heard the move H5
mentioned I'm not sure in what context
exactly but you know these post-game
discussions it's always hard to capture
exactly what lines they're talking about
they know
but it could be anywhere from the
opening to the end game
and I love seeing this though because
for a niche this was a disappointing
result he wanted to win with the white
pieces it's not the end of the world
he's drawing a very strong player who's
having a fantastic tournament but
they're just calculating they're saying
in this end game did I have chances and
they're looking like finger pointing
this is clearly an end game right when
you when you see them
doing the finger pointing you know
they're like okay I go here you go there
I go here you go there does my dog first
or yours
let's see if we can bring the audio back
one more time I'm going to take another
stab at trying to puzzle out which
position they're talking about
yes
King C6 King A6
but I don't know where
here comes over we don't need a
translator to know what that means just
please get out of the playing Hall
they're like no we need to finish
analyzing this
tournament Ambassador over there saying
I'm gonna sit in my chair here
they're very quiet players who are still
getting focused he's saying you want a
knight C7 Knight D5 but I guess I guess
it's somewhere in that night end game we
just don't know where
this is cool
foreign
I think they've moved to the middle game
the finger pointing yeah they're they're
pointing towards the center you know the
sort of the D and East files E5 E5
squares
right
I knew she was talking about like that
he didn't have too much time to prepare
but in any case wow that's oh
that's something to note because they're
coming off a rest day so yeah you know
Niche does have a family and kids and
maybe that was part of the reason he
didn't get to prepare as much as he
would have liked but he did draw this
game with the white pieces against the
nearbeck Abdus atarav and you saw that
smile on abusot's face and it's because
they were having a very friendly
post-mortem discussing the variations of
the game but the result will also be
relieving for him because abdusitave
gets black a second game in a row
tomorrow against Wesley so and Wesley
might have himself a very long day
because Magnus Carlson may make him work
for the draw but that's in the top right
but the bottom left look at the eval bar
done is suddenly whoa Haram maksudu has
an overwhelming advantage
I was looking for that evil bar I
couldn't even find it that's how far
it's dropped for white oh and prognanada
has really lost the threat of the game
we could feel it slipping away from him
really ever since he went Knight F5 but
things have gone from dubious to bad and
now to worse let's check into that game
to see how bad it has gotten this is the
live position A4 is probably not this
last move as he tries to chip away at
Black's very impressive Pawn Phalanx in
the center and on the queen side let me
make one thing perfectly clear Robert as
good as this might be objectively black
is far from out of the woods from a
practical standpoint
yeah that King on G8 it's a bit lonely
over there the G6 Pawn is tender so
let's actually make a careless move like
Rook A to B I'm defending my B5 Pawn
right but after a takes B5 a takes B5
there's Rook takes B5 I am distracting
your queen away from the G6 square and
if your queen takes the Rook down goes
G6 Queen G7 next is Checkmate so black
does need to be very careful there's
already a big threat in this position of
capturing twice on B5 which means that
black very likely should make a move
like Rook D6 sliding that Rook up to
give that pawn another Defender
and by the way there's another vicious
trap set by Prague oh I blundered the
fork on D2 no I didn't Queen C3 and
there's another mating Square on G7 the
tables turn here instantly as black
simply loses the Knight on D2 but this
is Child's Play these are tactics that
are high Max Lulu would see in a bullet
game he still has right about 24 minutes
on the clock Rook D6 it's not an easy
move to play but I really think it makes
Black's job so much easier because it
takes the weight off of black screen
enabling Black's Queen to supervise the
queen side and potentially even in some
cases jump into E3
wow yeah the E3 Square could be juicy
could be one that black species go to
but that G6 Pawn that's really where the
attention is for now so the question is
what to do about the B5 Pawn do you push
before yourself you're mentioning
Queenie three ideas at some point of
course you take care of G6 but do we
push B4 that way our Pawn is safe and
sound do we play Rook D6 defending the
Pawn With The Rook so that way the queen
is free to move and maybe Queen E3 to
follow so I think param is
I I want to say almost spoiled for
choice in the sense that there are a
bunch of options that look very
promising for him but he does need to be
very careful you know make one slip and
suddenly your king side falls apart
what really hurts Prague is attacking
chances here assuming our hum does not
stumble in this position is the fact
that there's no place for The Rook The
Rook just it can't move up to F4 there's
a pawn there it can never go up to F3 so
all that white really has are his Queen
and his dark Square bishop and perhaps
indirectly The Rook on B1 which which
could contribute with the deflection but
if black plays before Rook D6 then that
Rook is canceled out maybe you could try
an eventual Rook B3 but White's position
is also on the verge of falling apart I
mean D4 is coming Knight D2 is in the
mix assuming black guards the G7 Square
so no question Robert I think that black
is objectively winning but can Parham
keep his composure something that he has
struggled to do in a couple of critical
moments in this tournament his game
against kukash is the case in point he
had that winning idea after Google cash
overpressed and instead he made a
horrible blunder under that instantly
turn the tables
it's a shame for Prague Nanda because he
started this tournament off with a bang
he had some decisive victories he beat
Jordan Von Forest but lately it seems
like things have gotten out of hand for
him and so the tournament is long I
think probably gonna wish it had wishes
it ended earlier but he still has
chances in this game if he digs deep if
he uses the clock situation against his
opponent Arham has 21 minutes and change
to make it to move 40 we're only a move
28 so there's still many moves to come
the position is still complicated so
it's not going to be the simplest of
tasks for our hum so why don't we
leave Parham to it he has several good
options here we'll take a peek at our
bird's eye view just to see the other
game still in session well first we have
the playing Hall with so many Spectators
and I like that they have the boards up
on display I I haven't really noticed
that in previous rounds of commentary
but you see that they have their own
bird's eye view on the monitors
wow
and our producer letting us know that
they build a ramp
so that the spectators can stand higher
and catch all of the action from above
there's free parking for the spectators
Robert this these are minor things but
when taken together this is what makes a
tournament like this top of the line
This is why Tata steel has the
reputation it does
yep no it's true they do everything they
can to make this a festival that
everyone will enjoy and somebody who
hasn't enjoyed their tournament has been
dingly Wren and we saw the Eva bar
suggest he is in some trouble here so we
are gonna head to break but when we
return we will jump right into his game
against Jordan Fun Forest you see Daniel
goren he does not look like a happy
camper and we'll see just how bad it is
on the flip side of this break
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Hall is still buzzing with energy we are
several hours into the round is the 11th
Road of action in the Tata steel Chess
Masters tournament and we know the
players are giving it their all this
home stretch we are enjoying ourselves a
fun day of Chess I am Grandmaster Robert
Hess alongside me is Grandmaster Daniel
narodiski and Donya it's been fun thus
far we've had a result in the books and
we're not seeing so many decisive games
and one game that I think will end
relatively soon is this one between
dingley Wren and Jordan fund forest and
I think I misread the body language from
dingeren that it might be a game where
he's upset with the result but I think
it's because he's upset with the draw he
had the white pieces he's playing a low
rate of player but we do see them
repeating moves
and there's absolutely no reason uh and
no justification for ding to refrain
from this repetition where he goes
Bishop D1 setting up a discovered attack
against The Rook The Rook moves back to
A5 and then the bishop moves back to E2
hitting the C4 Pawn on and on they go
ringing around the rosie same with the
ornament Forest neither side uh has any
justification to try any Shenanigans and
a great result for Jon Ben Forrest one
of the bright spots of his tournament
has been his drug it's Magnus Carlson
and now
but something crazy happens a very solid
draw against England with the black
bases
it's the good thing about being one of
the lowest rated players in the fields
is draws are good for your rating so
your invent for us on the scoreboard
he's not having the best event where he
only has four points from 10 games he is
a former champion of this tournament so
he has high expectations for himself but
with the draw he'll gain a couple of
writing points that he actually may be
at net positive even it's going to be a
good result for him and he is showing
more stability he lost three games with
the black pieces he then beat Arjun
aragaisy with white and now he has
several draws in a row including the
hold against Vincent kymer in that very
long game in round 10. so I think it's
only a matter of time Dania before they
shake hands and dingly ren you see it is
a body language he looks like he is
going to make this draw he just isn't
happy about it
yeah he's looking intently seeing if
there's anything to be done here but his
King side's too weak the pawn on C4 is
too strong the pawn on A3 is too
immobile his pieces are too
uncoordinated there's nothing left to be
done except acquiesce to the repetition
there he goes Bishop E2 and a dejected
clock press the ornament Forest
exchanges contact
and there they go the handshake and the
draw
and we don't have audio for the players
but they are about to analyze their game
here the draw is a fair result I think
Loren's wondering about the opening and
Jordan has all the answers because
Jordan prepared some deep lines some
very interesting Dynamics from the
get-go where he sacrificed a pawn and
then a piece and then just getting crazy
uh in that one but
for Jordan a very very good result a
hold of the black pieces
indeed and just Fearless I mean to go
for a line like that against the world
number two where your king sits on E7
where you lose your entire Queen side
that's not easy even if you have
stockfish on your side even if you know
that objectively the position is equal
one could even say that you know had
ding made one more misstep in that
incredibly complicated middle game he
might not have been able to pull out a
draw so an impressive job by ding there
uh to find that move Queen A3 liquidate
the game into an end game but all things
held equal obviously still not a
positive result for Ding and he still
sits on a rather
uh unfortunate is he on minus one yes
five out of 11 minus one we do see him
smiling here so at least he's enjoying
the analysis and if we're being honest
and we should always be honest dingley
Wren has something he's looking forward
to probably a little bit more than this
event he wanted to win this event he is
a competitor he loves chess but if he's
going to win only one event this year or
and even in his lifetime I think the
world championship match against the
Underpants she is the one so we see the
players still going over the game it's
friendly conversation and there's the
eye of the tiger behind them because
Richard's report is wearing a shirt with
a tiger on it
unfortunately Richard report's position
uh does not really match his shirt if I
may be honest this position
is not worthy of a tiger let out of the
cage he is struggling against Vincent
kymer and he doesn't want even to look
at his own position
right and we see empty board there's
Richard again we caught up we caught up
to him but he's pacing around as chess
players do when their opponent is on the
clock but we do have
this draw it is done with the player's
repeated moves Rook a four to A5 the
bishop going back and forth between D1
and E2 so the C4 Pawn needed a defense I
think God just to go with the Rook on A4
for a second
um and the bishop to D1 uh you just have
to be careful if you're Jordan and there
is
the reason why he moved his work back to
A5 is now the bishop is in line with the
Rook on A4 so if you make some kind of
other move you may fall victim to some
kind of Discovery and that's not so fun
to deal with uh not to mention the Rook
on H1 is now free because the Rook on C2
defends all the way across the second
rank to the H2 Pawn so that's why Jordan
decided to go back and forth with Rook
A5 and A4
and for ding I mean the bishop has
absolutely no other prospects and as
we've already discussed Rook H to C1
here blindly piling up on C4 would be
and very inadvisable on account of Rook
takes H2 and the tactics simply do not
work out for why Bishop takes before
Rook takes rook and white drops the
bishop on C4 so just because you're
having a rough tournament just because
you're out rating your opponent by over
100 points does not mean that you should
do something foolish every single player
in this tournament is more than capable
of punishing play that lacks objectivity
so definitely the right decision for
both sides and our third peaceful result
of the day Iranian caruana then we had
giri against Abdus and now of course
ding against then Forest four games
remaining and I think I should correct
myself because the more I thought about
it I was listening to you don't worry
but that might have been a leopard on
the rich report shirt rather than a
tiger so I'll need to see that later on
but right now I all I can see is the bar
in the game between prognando and
maksuda where is that bar it is all the
way down which means that white is
objectively lost and I think it's
actually quite easy to explain at this
point before there were some chances for
an attack for Prague Nanda but right now
oh my goodness Tanya look at the wall of
Pawns from black all of them are in the
light squares this is not Checkers but a
deep five Pawn can quickly become a D4
pawn and white has nothing to Target the
King on H6 is perfectly safe the bishop
on E7 covers all the checks uh the G6
Pawn has all the defense it needs and
now it's time for black to start
throwing those pawns forward and oh gosh
Daniel this is just a miserable position
for prognanda be still my Beating Heart
look at that pawn Phalanx and do not be
deceived by the presence of opposite
colored Bishops with Queens on the board
opposite Cloud Bishops most certainly do
not signify draws potential even if the
Queens are off the board for that matter
with the pawns rumbling forward to D4
and to E3 white wouldn't really have uh
any Solace either
barring some sort of massive blood I
don't see how Parham blunders because
he's got the dark scores under lock and
key white simply has no way to reignite
the flame on the king side Robert I
think it's as simple as playing D4 and
then slamming a rook onto C3 and
eventually you're gonna go either D3 or
E3 the position I don't like this phrase
but I think this position warrants it
the position plays itself it does it's
just past pawns for black nothing that
white can look at Bishop F7 yes my
Bishop is free that Queen on B6 will
slide all the way over to F6 to deal
with that Bishop flush it out of there
and then the C2 Pawn is loose and the C
file is open so look at this queen F2
black and even play C3 common Rook C3 B4
you just make sure your pawns are all
safe and sound and protected and then
the F4 Pawn can even be targeted later
it's on a dark Square this is as
miserable of a position as it gets and I
feel for prognanda because he did have a
good start to this tournament early in
the event he beat dingley rent the world
number two with the black pieces that
was in round four in round seven he beat
Jordan Von forest with white but since
then in round eight he lost against
Richard report in round 10 he lost a
good cash here in round 11 it looks like
he is going down against so Parham stops
his downward trajectory and from
prognanda it's spiraling out of control
unfortunately for him
it is indeed and a real shame because he
showcased some incredibly creative
opening preparation that Knight F3 to H2
move which I think in the narrow context
of the opening resulted in a very
successful position I think frog was
objectively better and I think your
suggestion of b2b4 I just think Prague
chose the wrong side of the board to
play on he went with Knight F5 it was a
little bit over optimistic he might have
missed arham's response if Bishop takes
Knight and then D5 and once those two
pawns appeared in the center Parham
simply never looked back those pawns are
now on D4 and E4 and those pawns are
going to Signal the end of this game
very shortly there's nothing holding
them back and prognanda he's looking at
this position and I'm sure he thinks
it's quite hopeless but he will give it
his all so why don't we take a step back
for a moment here because this game it's
clear prognanda is in trouble Arham is
likely to win this game but but one game
that is not so clear to me well two
games in fact in the bottom right the
end game two Rooks and minor P's end
game for goo cash and Arjun it looks
like with an outside pass Pawn gukesh is
making some progress and maybe he has
some winning chances and then in the
middle over there Vincent kymer the
bottom row against Richard report we see
that there is a material imbalance so
I've done uh I'll let you choose but
that game is Knight and Bishop versus
rook and pawn with many other pieces on
the board
I definitely want to check it to the
Vincent kymer game because as
encouraging as the signs may appear for
him given the material imbalance it
seems to me that Richard report is the
one who's made serious defensive
progress over the course of the last
couple of moves I mentioned Here We Go
Again mode and Vincent might be slipping
into that mode so as we go to the live
board white has a bishop and a knight
for blackstroke and black also has a
Pawn on A6 which may appear
insignificant but if the Queens are
traded that pawn could potentially turn
into a a rather annoying Force so with
his last move Robert Rook E1 to A1
Vincent supports the Knight on A5 make
sure that Rook C5 uh isn't as dangerous
as it otherwise would be I think he's
got Queen A2 in response and if Vincent
can win the pawn on A6 and then
consolidate his minor pieces and get his
Rook into the center is right on to C6
eventually he's going to be winning but
that is a lot of ifs that is a lot of
moves and it seems to me that black has
several ways in which he can really
attack and try to exploit the lack of
coordination among White's pieces at the
present moment well done I want to do it
side by side so can you go back to a
move 20 after Black's 24th move yeah so
we see in the live board and the smaller
one underneath the players that's Knight
Bishop for white and a rook for black if
white airplane Knight takes B6 on our
analysis board
Knight takes B6 white can follow up with
Bishop takes A6 and it would have been
white who has the uh The Rook for the
minor pieces so the Knight of B6 still
under attack The Rook was under attack
so Rook takes C3 that's you know
Bishop takes C3 and the Knight moves
away say to D5
we have a situation where white has a
rook and two pawns two outside pass
pawns for the two knights so in the game
black is the one with the Rook for the
minor pieces in this analysis board we
have white with the Rook for the minor
pieces and I think that was a critical
moment uh that was overlooked by Vincent
or maybe he assessed it as complicated a
position he didn't think that I would
give him the most chances or it was a
little bit risky but that was a shot for
him that would have led to a material
imbalance in his favor
it would indeed instead he played a
takes B6 and situated his Knight on A5
but Richard report fearlessly
centralizing his own Knight and hitting
the B4 pawn and this essentially forces
White's hand Vincent takes on D5 and
then he takes again he takes on G7 and
here we have mass liquidation Queen
takes before working and now a very
annoying move Queen B4 to C3 I think a
very accurate defensive move by Richard
report not only does he hit the Rook but
he paves the way for potentially
disturbing Rook C5 forking the queen and
the Knight I don't think it's the end of
the world for white because the queen
could come up to D7 and counter attack
the E8 Rook but I think you see what I'm
saying Robert the queen could also come
into E1 if the Rook vacates the first
rank there's just a sense in which
Vincent isn't able to effectively
coordinate his pieces in time to stop
the infiltration of black strokes and we
could be talking about a three result
game if White's not careful
yeah I think that Vincent will have to
take a defensive stance for now uh slide
that Queen back to A2 you do not want to
see Black's Queen land on E1 so if
you're Queen A2 everything is nice and
defended and the A6 Pawn is still loose
and if Vince is going to win this game
it's going to take a long time dare I
say it he has played two extremely long
games in rounds nine and ten and if he
is going to go on to win this game he
needs to keep the pieces on the board
not to trade off the Queens not to get
into some end game where it's hard to
pile up on pieces he needs to keep the
pressure on Richard report and I
actually want to go back if you don't
mind again Donna I I did you I had the
engine on and saw it uh when I went back
just now to look at the position because
I was wondering if we scroll back a few
when black went Knight D5 and white took
on D5 because I was sitting there back
here the A6 Pawn was hanging and it
attacks The Rook on C8 but it turns out
the Peter laughed in my face and said
Bishop takes A6 it's mad I was wondering
that too yeah met by Knight takes C3
which means The Rook on D1 is under
attack as so if you take on C8 you lose
work on D1 but if you take on C3 there's
Rook takes C3 oh my gosh nasty and
Knight G4 at the end threatening Queen
H2 with a mating attack and hitting the
queen on C3 with the bishop on G7 the
long range sniper uh will do the damage
in both directions Queen is loose on C3
so if you take the Knight on G4 you lose
your queen and if you don't take the
Knight well you're gonna get checkmated
on H2 and G2
gosh it seems like the moment the bishop
leaves the F1 Square where it was
protecting the all-important G2 Pawn all
hell breaks loose Vincent correctly
avoided this line this is very
instructive though so Knight takes D5 at
this point was White's best chance and
in the live position he has indeed
played I think the only move to keep his
Advantage Queen D5 back to A2 kind of
curling up into a ball on the apha but
that's exactly what he has to do as an
intermediate step toward consolidation
on the next move he can bring his Knight
back to B3 and open up a direct line of
communication to the A6 Pawn
um probably this is a two result game
but I think if Richard report maintains
his composure if he keeps his Rooks
active maybe Rook E8 to d8 in this
position uh merits attention trying to
get the Rook to D2 I think his activity
should give him enough to secure half a
point he needs to be active he can't
just sit and wait for what's coming and
I think Richard he understands these
positions quite well we'll see if he can
handle this and hold the half point but
I want to zoom out again because the
game between Prague Nanda and Max it's
gone from bad to worst so what are the
worst positions you could even look at
in the bottom left of our screens here
no oh gosh like black is active
everywhere the queen trade is being
offered and if the Queens go off the
board then it's likely that blacks will
scoop up the F4 pawn and promote the
e-pawn at the same time
the game is over it's it's done for
it's just the lack of counter play right
not all minus five positions are you
know the same some there's a concrete
win and if you don't see it then the
position is unclear others like the one
we have in front of us on the bottom
left
Parham has six different possible moves
at least on every turn and you could win
this position essentially playing on
increment so maybe Prague won't reside
on in this position but I think
resignation is only a few moves away and
we thought that a peaceful result was
only a few moves away in Magnus
Carlson's game against Wesley so but
turns out the world champion is still
trying to tighten some screws I think we
should check back into magnus's game to
see if he's managed to create any
realistic chances uh to make Wesley's
path to a draw any more difficult
well if we go into that one it is an end
game bishop and pawns against Knight and
pawns and you mentioned this a long time
ago at the A7 B6 pawns are in dark
squares which means that they can be
attacked by the dark Square Bishop now
the E6 Pawn is safe and sound you can't
actually
attack that pawn with your king because
look at the control that black has E5
under control by the Knight F5 and D5
under control by that pawn so what is
White's plan what is he aiming for he
needs and what he really wants is to
create a past Pawn in this position so
let's actually just force it let's play
the move I'm gonna try to think how to
make this work let's just go King E7
back and forth maybe let's go King E4
just for yeah we're just kicking up to
H4
yeah just go for it King E7 G4 King F7
F4
or whatever you just keep moving
backward H5 and after King F7 we go G5
and this is the ideal scenario for white
and it's winning because either you take
on G5 and after F takes back I have a
pass pawn and that will distract your
pieces and then I will actually be able
to push my B Pawn at some point to kick
your knight out of there and then my
king will be able to infiltrate so it's
a long story but that would be a winning
position for white and if you don't take
on G5 what will take on H6 that pawn is
on a dark Square so after F5 the bishop
will simply win it so that is a dream
it's not going to come true because in
the starting position Wesley so made the
move E5 check we were just talking about
how that pawn was doing an important
task covering the D5 and F5 squares he
says my king can do the same job after
King E4 the black king slides up to E6
and that whole end game with the pawns
pushing up the board it started with the
penguin F4 the pawn can't go to F4 now
because the E5 will capture it
I think that move annoyed the heck out
of Magnus he was definitely hoping to
carry out that plan and one of the most
difficult most coveted end game skills
is knowing when to push pawns when to
sit around and shuffle your king back
and forth there's a time and a place for
that but there's also a time and a place
for pushing your pawns and changing the
structure of the position what is the
purpose of E5 as you're indicating
you're creating a very nice Square for
your king making it virtually impossible
for white not even virtually simply
impossible for white to create a pass
Pawn on the king side because F4 was an
integral part of that now of course that
square is under Black's firm control and
crucially if white brings the king up to
F5 I think Wesley has in mind wait a
second
if you go G6 then white goes King E4 so
what is Black's intention on the king F5
I think so if King F5 you have to start
with the move H5 put you upon the light
Square then you'll play G6 check and
when the king draws back to E4 you keep
the opposition with King to E6 so Wesley
playing a great game he was playing very
quickly out of the opening good
preparation and now that he's in the end
game he is not slipping up and for
Magnus Carlson he entered this round
just like Wesley so with six out of ten
you see on the right hand side of your
screen underneath the cameras that these
players are tied for third place a win
would put either player at seven points
tied for second place but a draw leaves
him a full point behind notary wreck
Abdul satar of and if history is to tell
us anything and we should always be
informed by history the winning score
has been nine points at minimum in nine
of the last 11 events so eight and a
half points was the winning score when
Jordan Von Forest beat anishikiri in tie
breaks but other than that one exception
the rule has been nine points or more so
Magnus if he draws this game his maximum
score will be eight and a half he'll
need help from the rest of the field
you will need the cards to fall a very
particular way now we've seen all sorts
of crazy things happen at the end of
tournaments but this is going to be a
tough pill for the world champions to
swallow he was really hoping to put the
heat on Wesley so but
the American Grandmasters opening
preparation just shut Magnus out he
really never had any chances in this
game the pieces came off the board and
then Wesley made a couple more accurate
moves uh in the end game and now E5
check a very important resource to shut
down perhaps White's last remaining uh
plan of action creating a king side pass
pawn and by the way Robert I just want
to point out once again that after King
F5 H5 is an only move Wesley has to see
that move because if you throw in G6
check first you allow the white king to
infiltrate on the other side because the
H6 Pawn is going to hang so as always
Wesley with surgical calculation
surgical Precision he is a scientist and
he is not giving the world champion any
leeway in this end game
and if Wesley draws this game he will
move to six and a half points out of 11.
that will be a full point just like he
entered the round behind no dearbeck
Abdul sitarov and there is something
important that Wesley so has going for
him is that if you look at his 12th
round pairing he gets white against
Abdul sitarov so he needs to do what it
is he needs to do what Magnus Carlson
couldn't is beat no deerback abusot with
the white pieces so if Wesley draws this
game and I should say almost a win at
this point he is holding this one he can
tie abusatara for the standings by
beating him tomorrow and then I'll have
black against probably not in the final
round so Wesley so continues to fly
under the radar we've talked about this
from the start of the round somehow he
doesn't get the recognition it's because
he had these two wins in the middle of
the tournament otherwise he's had draws
his games have been quite docile but now
that we're at the last few rounds he has
a chance to score tournament Victory if
he is able to beat Abdul sitarov in
round 12 he gets the white pieces there
he gets black against a struggling
problem in the final round Wesley so
could end this tournament as the winner
he absolutely could and we're not just
forecasting impossible scenarios this
could all happen if one particular
result goes a certain way if Wesley
deals Notre brick Abdus tour of his
first loss of the tournament with
fatigue now playing a major role with
Wesley's incredible ability to stir
things up with the white pieces Anything
could happen and there you see the world
champion he's down to four minutes on
his clock he's going to have to make a
decision about where to put his King but
I think a draw for might be forthcoming
pretty soon
Magnus Carlson a drug he's the status
quo that's not what he wanted that is
something that no dear Beck and Anish
are going to be happy about and actually
after his draw earlier today the media
caught up with the niche to ask him
about how he feels with Magnus so close
to him in the standings and he also gave
his thoughts on the state of the game
to this round I don't think so huh I
don't think so was he off point behind
me
really
oh Jesus that's very bad
I don't check the standings it's not
very alone another question I'm secure
but I think he was half a point behind
you have you seen his position right now
um yeah I was very surprised right now I
saw that he's putting pressure because I
I maybe Miser evaluated sort of because
I know that you can sometimes put
pressure Bishop against Knight but black
looked so active at some point and it
looks like black should be very
comfortable but I guess Wesley decided
to go into the defensive mode
um I don't think that's necessary
because actually if you do that then the
pawn on B6 turns out to be a weakness
and um yeah I think blacks goes into a
very passive approach it's possible to
lose that position
um
so yeah maybe that's that's possible
but to be honest uh I don't see how it
impacts me very much we've already
played and I have two more rounds to go
placed by other people so I think it's
all um it's all good
you heard it from any scary there he's
saying what Magnus does
it doesn't impact him because he's
already played Magnus he needs to focus
on his upcoming opponents and in general
when you are chasing the leaders you
want to face them so for Magnus he has
already lost his games to both Noir
Becca and to anishkiri but Anish said
Dania that he didn't understand if
Wesley had to get so passive because now
that we're deep in this end game well
the King on F5 looks very powerful it
could cause some players to scratch
their head and get nervous Wesley is not
just some player he's not just anybody
he's the chess.com Global Champion the
former Fisher random world champion he's
won the grand chess tour he's won all of
these big events I think he sees this
position and says I'm good
and I think we see that just by the
speed with which he played H5 you don't
play a move like that within 15 seconds
unless you are absolutely sure that
white is out of winning chances and
Wesley is sure that white is out of
winning chances and he's got very good
reason to be sure of that because G6 is
coming next you can't really pre-move it
because white could drop the king back
to E4 preemptively that of course should
be met with King to E6 and the moment
White's Bishop leaves the E3 the g1a7
diagonal black can repositioned his
pawns on a light Square so I'm looking
at this it's not even one of those
things where magnets could Shuffle his
pieces back and forth for many moves and
hope for a mistake I don't even think a
mistake is possible there's just no
testing option for white I think Magnus
should just stop for a draw here
and magnus's clock I mean he doesn't
have all that much time he needs to make
10 moves and he has two moves to do so
so with move 40
of 10 moves away he needs to rush a
little bit here he'll get 50 minutes
after reaching uh that move but he might
just let the game Peter out before then
because you don't want to blunder with
30 seconds on your clock and having to
make a few more moves to get to the time
Patrol so for Magnus he can make the
move F4 right now just trade off pawns
and as long as he doesn't blunder a
night fork or let the black king into
the game because G6 check is coming and
if you keep walking the white king back
to E4 and then to D3 the black key is
going to run to D5 and once it gets
there it is a very happy piece and white
is the one losing control of the
position
now you're exactly right you can find a
way to lose any position and if you go
back to E4 and then you allow blacks
Knight to circle around let's say to F6
or to D6 well then Wesley might be the
one who declines the draw but Bishop to
D2 by Mr Carlson
a concrete attempt to provoke the move
Knight D4 which I don't think Wesley is
going to play I think he's going to
avoid that move with a 10-foot pull
because that Knight on B3 could get
dominated by a bishop from B4 I don't
see a reason for Wesley to refrain from
the move G6 followed by King E6 white
will plant the bishop on C3 Robert but
Wesley could take that opportunity to
reposition his pawns on a light square
and I think that might be the straw that
gets Magnus to offer the draw wow
well played there and you're right the
G6 check is automatic Knight D4 check is
something that people would play in
bullet chess they see a check they give
a check and there's also a fork you win
the B3 Pawn but because Knights are
short range pieces and Bishops they see
the length of the board Knight D4 check
is asking for trouble because you win B3
but you give E5 and the white king will
run over to D5 and into uh the black
position and go up to the queen Side
Pawn so just to show that Knight D4
check you know it wins the B3 Pawn good
for you once you take there the bishop
moves I think to E3 and the reason it
goes to E3 is Knight C5 was the retreat
Square you wanted to go to but now if
you go to see if I take it and when they
ensuing King and pawn and game is Kane
D5 mops up the queen side so this was
not at all what Wesley so wants he is
just going to play G6 check he's over
his kingd E6 and he can play A6 and B5
as you have been calling for
yeah King E6 and white essentially has a
choice either bring the bishop back to
E3 and then black can start
repositioning the Knight you know when
the Knight reaches D6 we talked about
this don't let black skin get to D5
because then Wesley might be the one
declining the draw for so I'm with you
if I'm Magnus I'm playing F4 and I'm
getting out of that tournament Hall with
half a point because you've got a minute
35 you don't want to have to deal with a
new set of challenges you know and and
five moves to make before move 40.
Wesley though taking his time very
methodical and G6 check is on the board
you can't fool someone like Wesley with
a trap this prosaic
and Magnus Carlson is not going to bring
his King to G5 no he Retreats it to E4
that's the right decision you need to
keep your King close to the action and
King E6 I do think we will see F4 and
once black is able to play A6 and B5
there's no longer a question of will it
be a draw it's when is it going to be a
draw because the only thing that Magnus
had gone from is those pawns on the dark
squares which is Bishop could attack
once it goes A6 B5 then the white king
can't enter from anywhere and as long as
black doesn't blunder the E5 Pawn uh
then there's nothing to worry about
and that's exactly right and of course
the reason Magnus put his Pawn on A4 is
to prevent black from pushing B5 for the
longest time Wesley simply did not have
the time to play the move Asics but
finally with the Knight on C6 guarding
E5 he's got the tempo he needs A6 is
already on the board and just in the way
that Magnus put his pen down you know
that a draw for his forthcoming either
on this move or on the next but I
definitely think we're going to see a
result before move 40.
well Max Carlson has a minute of 43
seconds and left he gets 30 seconds
added per move and it has only been 33
moves thus far so he has two reach move
40 and keep winning chances otherwise he
might as well just offer a drama
I have an idea Dania yeah I don't think
it works but if he slow plays it a bit
with F3 and G4 so hear me out hear me
out let's go F3 I think he just played
it I don't need to go F3 Magnus did it
for me
and the reason he's doing this is let's
say you go B5
okay
and I'm wondering at what point white
can play the move G4 and try to open up
an Avenue the problem is black will have
to move B4 and then that shuts the
bishop away from the A5 square and then
Knight A5 takes B3 is what he's looking
for so Madness is actually kind of
putting the question to Wesley in a way
but I just feel like B5 is coming and
that's obvious and how is Magnus Gonna
Keep challenging let's see from there
to piggyback off of your idea let me try
to remedy the problem by playing sort of
counter-intuitive move before yes I'm
creating a weakness but on the other
hand you're essentially guaranteeing
that these Queen side pawns remain
immobile of course if black is able to
trade the bee pawns then the game ends
in a draw immediately now let's say
black you know stays put with King to D6
and white plays G4 not trying to put
words in your mouth but I feel like your
ideal scenario is ghgh and then F4
and after ef14 F4 I don't see a good
defense against King G5 this is still a
dead draw I'm sure maybe just King D5
and King C4 but Magnus is always able to
find ways to extend the game and I think
he's looking in this kind of Direction
B5 is on the board
is Magnus gonna take and play before
Robert if he allows before then it
becomes a three result game well you're
playing too well so I think what he's
hoping for is after G4 that Wesley will
take on A4 and that's a mistake I think
a lot of people in the audience would
make is while they're Pawn captures it's
even material why don't I just liquidate
and get to an even simpler ending but
the problem is that through G4 if black
takes on A4 there isn't a Target to go
after after B takes A4 back look at the
bishop on C3 it completely dominates
that Knight on C6 and if the Knight
moves away from C6 you drop the E5 Pawn
if you're a king to F6 you walk you walk
into a pin or King D5 versus F4 both
both moves will be good uh but if you
walk the other way there could be G
takes H5 and King F5 and King G5 and
going after the H Pawn so this is the
outside chance that Magnus is looking
for and he did just make the move G3
instead maybe it's a Tempo thing he's
going to G3 for but B4 should be
Wesley's response played B4 and after
the bishop Retreats playing Knight A5
you give up B4 Pawn but you get the B3
Pawn
and after Bishop takes before Knight
takes B3 the problem isn't that white
imminently loses the a pawn it's that
the bishop is just tied down to the
defense of the C5 square and the Knight
of course is not trapped it always has
the D4 Square it's it can jump around on
the queen side you can't trap the Knight
and if you play A5 here then the Knight
could reshuffle itself back to C6 Knight
D4 Bishop C3 Knight C6 and as long as
black stays anchor to the A5 Pawn
there's just no way uh in a million
years that white could create enough
chances here uh to generate true winning
chances it's close though still because
like let's say you play G4 yeah or am I
being too dismissive if black takes with
the H Pawn then we have F takes G4 and
maybe this still holds but getting that
outside pass Pawn looks dangerous and if
black has to deal with that that could
be a problem so I think magazine is just
he knows it is should be a draw but he
is just trying to heat up this pressure
here a little decision there and if
Wesley missteps that's when he can play
for a win
and I think this game really epitomizes
something vessel into paulov uh told me
a while back when we were commentating
the World Cup I asked him how
specifically if you had to quantify how
Magnus Carlsen has changed the game and
he literally told me that there are
actually many many positions which 15 20
years ago would have been a greater draw
you know 10 or 15 moves ago and this is
exactly a position like that where you
know kramnik and Adams playing this in
2005 would very likely have signed the
Peace Accords back when the queens were
still on the board but Magnus Carlson
keeps going and he keeps going and of
course maybe eight times out of ten
magnus's opponents are going to hold the
fort but there's always going to be
those two times and Magnus has shown
that you can squeeze out wins in the
most improbable situations and he
doesn't do this out of a sense of
Showmanship I'll look at me I'm such a
fighter he does this because he can
actually he actually believes that he
can win and his track record in this
regard speaks for itself
there are so many actual traps that I'm
thinking about I mean I'm visualizing uh
positions down the line and that's what
Magnus does so well is just to go for
this before let I just want to show a
sample variation so B4 for black Bishop
D2 it's important to point out why A5
not 95 is a bad move for black because
Bishop E3 and then Knight is dominated
and that Bishop can slide to B6 putting
your pawns on dark squares is definitely
not the thing to do so the Knight comes
to A5 to win this Pawn on B3 you take on
B4
um A5 is a very important move for white
just to make sure that
um you keep the pawn A6 stuck in place
the Knight goes to D4
and then after Knight D4 let's type a
bishop C3 so I'm going after the Knight
you have to go back to C6
uh
I do have Knight B3 not trying to play
Devil's I'll let you demonstrate your
idea ah but a really good point though I
actually might want to play Knight B3 to
tie you down to the A5 pawn and to have
the possibility of dropping back to C5
to push the king away no that's a really
important point maybe things I think is
a great move because I think Knight C6
gets you into trouble so Knight B3 is
active defense whereas here G4 happens
and you can't go king of six because of
King D5 you don't really want to play
King D6 either because you take on on H5
and the King runs in so Magnus is trying
to get exactly this position and this
does look like one where he can
legitimately play for a win if that
Knight moves you drop the E5 Pawn so
Wesley's task is not over in my head I
was like okay for sure it's a draw you
mentioned how back in the day the
players just shake hands I wouldn't be
thinking the same way but Wesley needs
to play that Knight B3 move I think he
will find it because he is so precise
but Magnus is asking all the right
questions
he is but Wesley's taking his time I
really like the way Wesley is managing
his clock he's left himself with 12
minutes or four moves he's taking you
know two three minutes per move because
Wesley he's played Magnus enough times
to know that a single misstep and you
can dig yourself into a hole that you'll
be getting out of for the next 60 moves
so these next three four moves before
the time control are crucial if Wesley
wants to make a draw here pain-free the
line we were looking at Robert with the
Knight coming back to C6 rather than B3
of course that position is still a draw
but why would Wesley want to torture
himself like that as he plays Knight C4
same exact product as Knight A5
and Magnus takes before Wesley takes B3
and will we see A5 from the world
champion
I think for sure we'll see A5 is a
minute and a half it is move uh 37 so he
has a few more moves to play before he
gets additional time a full 50 minutes
will be added to his clock and he is
trying to work this end game it's what
Magnus has done throughout his entire
career when most players would have
called it a day gone to dinner Magnus
says I am going to keep every resource
available to me I'm gonna think about it
and I'm gonna try to execute on that and
I am actually really believing that
there are legitimate winning chances
before I would say okay come on let's be
real we're saying it but Wesley's gonna
defend now I'm like It's Tricky the
Knight will be outclassed by the bishop
so Wesley will need to find his Knight
going back to B3 as you pointed out
and I did experience the wrath of Magnus
Carlson's end games yesterday we played
a little Blitz match and
it doesn't matter if you were a piece up
it doesn't matter if you are nominally
better anytime you enter an end game
against Magnus Carlson you feel like
you're losing it's almost Supernatural
and everybody at the elite level has
experienced that feeling
at least once and Magnus was 16 seconds
can't forget about his clock
and there he goes a4a5 fixing the a
Pawns in place
and time for Wesley to extricate his
Knight
okay so the Knight can go right back to
D4 I don't really see any other viable
options Knight C1 looks a little bit too
adventurous for me
actually oh no oh my gosh I was saying
Knight C1 just drops a pawn because the
bishop C3 but then it goes right back to
B3 so it's the variation you were
talking about from a different move one
but I think Knight T4 is the most
watertight option
Bishop C3 yeah it might be three exactly
so Knight could actually even even
Knight A1
probably allows black to survive but
you'd only play that if you have a death
wish I mean it's a little too fancy for
your own good
yeah I am Knight C1 or Knight D4 seem to
lead to the same result it's also
important to point out Knight D4 F4 may
seem scary because it undermines the
Knight but when the Knight drops back to
C6 it simultaneously hits the bishop so
the knight's just too active here
Wesley great defender having a very good
tournament he's gained some rating
points
um he beat Vincent kymer and gukash in
back-to-back rounds and both of those
games were fights and this game against
Connor went down to an end game his game
against kukesh was one where it seemed
like Lucas was in rough form at that
stage of the tournament and uh was was a
decent position fell apart quickly and
if we zoom out you know for a moment
here speaking of a position that was
decent and fell apart you look at the
game between Prague Nanda and maksudu
it's now into a bishop of opposite color
Rook end game black is up to healthy
pawns the e-pawn is ready to start
promoting and that's the second from the
left and the bottom there's just one
tactic you need to avoid you are you
know exactly where I'm going with it so
if we can pull up the game between
Prague and the Parham
that the one thing that param needs to
look out for is Bishop G8
which threatens Rook H7 Checkmate now
you'll see it's gonna happen so you'll
avoid it you can make the move G5 to
create space for your king and then your
F Pawn and your e-pawn are passers and
black is just going to promote them
and whichever way White Checks if white
plays Rook H7 the king Dodges laterally
if the Rook gives the check on A6 the
king Dodges the check vertically and
obviously once these spawns are traded
as you're saying the pawns are going to
promote we are going to see a result in
this game any second Prague did not play
Bishop G8
he instead has played the move Rook to
A6 Last Resort trying to tie himself to
this G6 spawn but clinical Precision
from parhamaksudu Swinging The Rook back
to C3 and he is going to drive it over
to G3 defending his last remaining
weakness frankly this is the stage of
the game Robert where your resignation
might be the best move
to pawn lead for param you can slide
that Rook to G3 as you're mentioning
then the E Pawn is ready to go the B
Pawn is also there let's not forget
about that it could be a useful decoy at
some moment and Bishop E6 was prognan's
choice I wonder what he's threatening
Don is that Bishop takes F5 no I I don't
know why it's covering his Rook uh
Robert it's time for B4 what do you
think of that we should show that though
before in all seriousness allows Bishop
takes F5
pins the pawn on G6 and it should be a
draw after that even though it Still
Remains a bit complicated because of
Black's passers so do not blunder think
about what your opponent just did why
would it why probably put the bishop
there is to go for a cheapo and for for
Parham another thing to look out for
let's say about King G7
uh-huh
and then okay seven check and King F6
you'll notice that your king doesn't
have safe squares so if the bishop
Retreats Rook F7 is check and mate so
you once again you have to deal with
that threat with move by G5
yeah but once you play G5 and you set
these Pawns in motion as long as you
avoid blundering one of your connected
passers you're completely winning also
we should point out that move 40 has
been made which means 50 additional
minutes have been added to the clock do
not be fooled by the fact that Parham
seemingly has one minute when that
minute elapses he will get an additional
50 minutes awarded to his clock I
personally would not have been able to
survive uh even another minute of this
torture because
some of the most painful moments Robert
I think they'll co-sign me on this some
of the most painful moments happen when
you know that the results of the game is
not in question and your opponent just
has Oodles of time and he's thinking and
thinking a double and triple checking
and you're just in agony so I think
Prague he's so resilient he's so
resourceful but once Arham just solves
this final Pitfall once he sidesteps the
final landmine I think we're gonna see a
resignation here
that undoubtedly will be the case
because you're running out of Hope if
you're prognanda I think it's smart to
play on and as we see the Tekken tekkens
the seconds
[Laughter]
Alexa what is a Tekken a tekken's a game
foreign
like a mixture of Tetris and no you've
never played Tekken before
oh like
t-e-k-i-no t-e-k-k-e-n it was a fighting
game it's like a very famous uh arcade
game Dania do you still not know who
you're dealing with after all these
years and all that we've been through
together I was the one
slip of the tongue and then somehow
you're the one who chat is gonna go
after because you don't know Shaq is oh
I just laid myself out I mean chat is
just going to
have a field day here I can just feel
and there we go
of course they will because ever
at play Tekken and they were ever had a
favorite character that they would fight
with all right well while we are going
to find you something to make sacrifices
to become a grand master and some of
those sacrifices involve gaps in
cultural upbringing which I admittedly
do have
well while you get roasted by chat uh we
will
head on to a break the playing Hall it's
clearing out a bit yes Don is showing
off his Boomer status indeed but the
playing Hall is clearing out still
plenty of games in session all of these
players in the chess Festival take it
seriously this is the 11th round of the
tots of Steel Masters in Vikings a we'll
see if Wesley so can continue to hold
off Magnus Carlsen when returned in just
a few minutes
when I say chess what's the first word
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game
fantastic okay it's just a sport
absolutely very competitive known
worldwide uh battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
thank you I appreciate it it's chess a
sport intellectually yes okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
[Applause]
chess chess yes like the gate chess I
can beat you in chess if you beat me
I'll give you ten dollars ten ten if you
beat me I
a bit
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I don't know what you're doing
I do know what I'm doing I don't know
what I'm doing it's all right that's all
right I don't know what I'm doing in
life
okay
all right bro that's Checkmate oh
who's Mate who's made bro I will
unbelievable you got 30 seconds for me
quick interview come on you look like a
chess player you play chess if I haven't
played chess okay when I say chess
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind winning
foreign
of these three things one of them is
real
chess dancing chess climbing chess
boxing chest climbing just climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climbing
chess books chest boxing chess boxing
you nailed it okay am I right for real
you nailed it seriously yeah of of the
two of us one of us is a World Chess
boxing champion which one do you think
it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not he does get he tried to hit
another guy earlier so he looks oh my
God she didn't even hesitate from now on
will you stop making me do things in New
York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun
s that is a losing move
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps win eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title Anish Geary is
just I mean he beat both world number
one and world number two in the same
tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps Mr Tara
leads Vikings a he is already a legend
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
we're back to the playing Hall in
Vikings there you see many competitors
in the chess Festival as well as
Spectators looking at the Masters play
their games and while there are many in
the playing Hall there are many more
watching online I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess along with Grandmaster Daniel
laradiski we want to thank the over 40
000 people watching across the platforms
right now this is exciting stuff we're
near the Finish Line in vikon Zay this
is the 11th round out of 13. so after
this round concludes we'll only have two
left our leader is Nuri Abdus tarov and
Dania he has been mighty impressive
he has indeed and today was just a
continuation of the young Uzbek talents
incredible run he has showcased every
aspect of Chess Mastery this has been a
universal performance from opening
preparation which we saw today to end
game Acumen which we saw against Magnus
on The Winning Side and against kymer uh
on the drawing side to just grit and
resilience and a lack of blunders in
order to pick Abdus tour of has had it
all and all he has to do now is hold
strong through the final two rounds but
what a final two rounds it's going to be
he has perhaps the most difficult trial
of his entire tournament as he faces
Wesley so in the next round and a Wesley
so whose confidence is likely to be
bolstered after a solid draw against the
world champion
and Wesley he hasn't made yet to be
clear yeah it's gonna happen in all
likelihood uh but that leaves the second
half of the standings because those
players despite not being in contention
for first place they are still fighting
they're still giving it their all
Richard reported Vincent kymer they're
playing their game Arjun Eric garci and
gukesh are still slugging it out and
para maksudu he's well on his way to
victory over pragnananda while Jordan
Forest and dingly Wren Drew their game
so as we look at our remaining games we
see one game where the bar is dipped all
the way down that's the one between
paramaksudu with the black pieces and
prognanda with white but let's go to our
game of Vincent kymer and Richard report
because there is a material imbalance
there so sometimes even if it is dynamic
equality or it is level because there
aren't many pieces remaining it can be
trickier than initially meets the eye I
don't necessarily think Daniel this is
that tricky I think that black now with
two pawns and a rook for the minor
pieces there just aren't enough pawns
remaining if white could put upon an A3
we'd be talking about a real winning
chances but after the move H4 we see
Vincent waiting for Richard return I
wouldn't be surprised if what he returns
there's a draw offer just the way he's
looking around he doesn't have anything
in this position to attack as I've noted
so what's he going for the answer might
just be a half point
the armies are just at a standstill
black of course cannot move either of
the Rooks from their place I mean The
Rook could Shuffle between A7 and A8 the
other Rook could Shuffle between C5 and
B5 but you certainly do not want to give
away your A5 Pawn but the same goes for
white you don't want to move your knight
away from C4 because then black stroke
slides over to B4 and the moment that
black a pawn is set in motion you know
you start regretting not just taking the
draw so just because Vincent has had a
frustrating go of it uh as I said in
reference to ding doesn't mean that you
need to lose all of your objectivity and
uh you know do something foolish neither
side has any winning chances here if it
draws an offered on this move I think it
might be offered on the next report is
probably going to play Just H5 and uh
the situation on the king side is
similarly lifeless just no Pawn breaks
no ideas just Bishop B2 to F1 and black
kind of does the same
where is report
he is maybe using the bathroom after
reaching move 40 that was White's 41st
move and I think when he comes back it
is likely that it draws off we are at a
standstill uh neither side can make any
progress as you pointed out done it and
is good an astute observation that the
black Brooks are stuck defending A5 and
the B5 Rook is defending E5 as well
if you move off the A5 pawn it will
immediately be captured and well the
Knight can't move because it worked
before so it just seems to be a position
where the best the sides can do is move
their kings back and forth and that
means that we'll see the point being
split
and you could see Richard leaning over
taking a quick peek at Vincent kymer
scoresheet I think just making sure that
move 40 has indeed been made which it
has we stopped ragnananda in an
unfortunate moment losing on time uh
without realizing that he had not yet
made his 40th move this was against
Richard report obviously the position
was already lost but just the way that
the players are sitting as Vincent kymer
gets up no draw for yet but the draw for
could come any second you could see H5
accompanied with a draw for Rook A7
another one of those neutral moves one
way or the other this game I think is
going to end very very shortly
yeah and for
Richard there you see him on screen he's
looking at this position and he's like
well nothing's happening he even see the
hand right there oh there it is draw
yeah
yeah both players are kind of like okay
not much life all right let's just draw
this game and for Vincent kymer yeah a
game where he was stable throughout he
did have an advantage if and they're
gonna go over the game you saw him point
to go to the analysis area but he had a
moment where he could have sacrificed
his own Rook
um for uh sorry he ended up taking two
modded pieces for a rook but he could
have given up two minor pieces for Rook
of his own but had those past balls it
was not easy it was very difficult we're
always aided by the eval bar saying
there's something there for Vincent he
could have looked at that position and
be like that's too risky let's do that
in another event
yeah another peaceful result for the
young German Grandmaster under the
expert tutelage of Peter leko for many
years now of course leko's style clearly
visible in Vincent kymer's incredible
positional understanding he's so patient
he's so methodical in his approach to
the game of course belies is very young
age and I think Robert that there's a
narrative that's being spun of course we
know that the Chess World is very
reactive the chess worlds chess fans
tend to see one or two games and make
sweeping conclusions on their basis and
there's this idea that if it's a
chimer's bad at end games and that this
tournament has revealed a you know a
massive hole in his chest understanding
and I would really tone that idea down
of course Vincent has had some really
frustrating games but he has not had a
single game where I would classify it as
an easy win right Ben Forrest I'm just a
tour of those were end games where he
had to demonstrate Exquisite accuracy in
order to pull out the point he's going
to come back home Peter leco and him are
going to work on end games and I think
he's going to come back in his next
tournament ready to convert some of
those 50 50 positions
it's a situation where it's not your
tournament and in another event he could
have scored those victories but here in
Viking Zade this grueling 13 round event
with such a long time control against
the best players in the world there are
no free points it's just not happening
here so for Vincent kymer I do think
he's played better chess than a score
would indicate the last three rounds
have been very strong play he's had the
upper hand in every game he just hasn't
scored that full point but let's go away
from this one a drug was a fair result
we still have three games remaining the
one between maksudlu and I think that
one is nearing its conclusion the one
between Arjun Eric icy and gukesh has
quite a lot of life left to it in an end
game where the sides have a rook minor
piece and five uh four pawns I can learn
to count at some point and then Magnus
and Wesley they might be going back and
forth with a knight and Bishop Tango
yeah we will keep an eye on the world
champions game which essentially should
end any second but we've been saying
that now for right about 30 30 minutes
and the Chess World says that about
everyone of Magnus Carlson's equal end
games and then he ends up winning them
unfortunately for Magnus Wesley just not
giving him any chances at all we'll
bring you that result when we have it
but let's go uh and take a closer look
at the all India matchup between uh the
two struggling Indian Juniors aragaisi
and gukesh gukesh has sort of righted
his ship in the last couple of games
really aided by a very fortuitous
blunder by Parham a couple of rounds ago
our generic icy still unable to score
his first Victory will this game be his
lucky one I don't think so Robert I
really don't see black losing this end
game barring some sort of major blunder
no at this point it's all about this B4
Pawn if white is able to bring that
Knight around and win the pawn then of
course you're in the driver's seat and
maybe just have a winning end game but
black is in time uh two things leave
black uh in a perfectly acceptable
territory one is the three pawns on the
light squares the move H5 comes to mind
let me just go after your pawns because
I want to make your Pawn chain shorter
after I swap on G4 then I can play G6
after I'm just gonna keep trying to take
down your Pawn chain as best I can it
won't require some Precision of course
that is always the case but H5 is one
idea and Bishop D7 would be my other go
Bishop D7 to A4 and try to get that Rook
out of the face of that past Pawn
yeah Bishop D7 is sort of the concrete
approach if we could bring up the
analysis board it may appear to be a
blunder due to 95 but Bishop A4 comes at
the perfect moment now
I don't think white wants to take the
Rook as Knights are notoriously bad at
stopping past pawns I feel like Knight
takes C4 asks for trouble but on the
other hand if you play Rook B2 black
could actually Force the Knight versus
Bishop end game the thing is what really
allows white to breathe easy is the fact
that the king it's kind of an optical
illusion it doesn't look like the king
is able to stop the pawn but it is and
it is because of the unique placement of
Black's Bishop after King E3 B3 the king
slips through to D2 and B2 relinquishes
the connection with the Bishops of black
as the sped in Tempo either moving the
bishop away or probably more prudent is
now to play the Robert Hesse of H5 and
Robert one way or another I feel like it
doesn't even matter if the Rooks remain
on the board we're gonna get some sort
of liquidation where black liquidates
the king side and maybe white wins A6
this position is just so clarified and
so easy to calculate that I really don't
see either player going astray here with
you know well over half an hour on the
clock
too simple of an end game not enough
pieces are remaining and it is level so
it's hard to imagine the players going
wrong at this point uh the one way to go
wrong is if we get Knight versus Bishop
ending Knight can jump from a color
complex to color complex we'd love to
mention that because it's true that is
how the pieces move but it plays a huge
role in end games but I do think H5
going right for the pawn chain might be
the simplest approach
yeah H5 hit it where hit white where it
hurts on the pawn on G4 and in the event
of h595 The Rook could swing over to E4
dislodging the knight from its defense
of the G4 Pawn Yeah I really like them
of H5
and I think it will lead to a quick
liquidation and yet another peaceful
result will we have a decisive game
today well with 99 certainty we will but
practice is still somehow hanging on for
dear life against barhamaksudlo
unfortunately is resistance is not
likely uh to last much longer Robert is
it or did something cataclysmic happen
no I actually think if we go into that
game right now you see Parham he is
leaning in and he might be leaning in to
his past Pawn on e4 that's the second
from the left and the bottom row there
and we bring up the board E3 the bishop
on F6 is under attack but who cares
about that Bishop might be the claim and
there's something very fancy here uh so
e if you go E3 okay let's bring up an
analysis board
The Rook takes the bishop over there on
F6 of course that Bishop is under attack
so let's grab it and after E2 then white
puts the Rook on E6 so this is the big
question do you play Rook C1 check and
immediately get a queen in The Rook has
to sacrifice and we get an end game with
bishop and two pawns against rook and
two pawns the good news is the F4 pawn
and the HD Pawn are split so that should
give black uh a winning position but
alternatively I was going to say you
might not even need to rush with a move
B4 is also tempting because you don't
have one pass Pawn you have two so you
bring your king to G1 to stop the E Pawn
then after King G1 the move B3 is played
and how are you going to stop both
well I think you're actually going to
get the same outcome because after B2
Rook B6 black has nothing better than to
play this move Rook C1 and white is able
to eliminate both pawns obviously
this comes at the cost of an exchange
and in comparison this is a better
version for black because White's King
is actually further away from the H4
Square I think black's King can now make
a Mad Dash for that square and White's
just not going to be able to keep his
pawns alive now maybe Parham maybe this
is what he's calculating he's just
making sure because Robert you'll second
me on this some of these end games with
Rook versus bishop and a couple pawns
they are often a lot harder to convert
than they appear the margin of Victory
is oftentimes much more narrow than it
appears so that is one option and it's
not enough just to calculate A3 you also
have to figure out E3 Rook E6 like does
the pawn go through Barham decides to
avoid that and slips his King back to G7
but he has parted ways with the B5 Pawn
is he over complicating this or is this
still a straightforward win Robert what
do you think trying to figure it out
because after Bishop takes B5 you want
to push that pawn to E3 but the Rook
does get to E6 in time right so okay E2
is not happening which means black
should play Bishop D4 and I think what I
think the key here is the Rook doesn't
have squares on the e-file the black
king is going to slide over to F7 and
once that happens The Rook is not going
to be able to stay behind that pass Pawn
yeah so for instance white can play the
move H4 and after King F7 I suppose that
white could play them over Rook E6 to D6
and hit the bishop but let me uh bring
to the table a old Soviet Grandmaster
move Rook C2 to F2 I'm too lazy
calculate variations I just want to take
two takes that four and the moment the
bishop steps away from B5 obviously
black plays the move E2 and you could
not care less about the G6 spawn Rook F1
anyone Queen is coming to a theater near
you so I feel that Parham has made a
wise decision in avoiding the
immediately too and this is happening
Bishop takes B5
Rook F2 he hasn't even played E3 he just
went straight for the jugular you called
it the F4 Pawn on a dark Square cannot
be defended once that pawn is gone it's
two running passers for black and four
prognanda he needs to be a pest he needs
to play Rook A7 check Force the king
away from the bishop and bring the Rook
right back to A6 he needs to somehow to
get after this G6 Pawn which is on a
light Square which means the bishop can
really attack it so
um let's look at one variation so Rook
A7
okay
King H6
Rook A6
so Bishop D4 that we got we have to do
something we don't want to repeat moves
and then is Bishop E8 in time that's the
big question
oh gosh
well not only is it in time you
definitely don't want to lose the G6
spawn if you're if you're Parham now I
don't think it's Up For Debate well
maybe it is Up For Debate that this
position is winning what's the move here
the evil bar dropped precipitously maybe
just by three
oh again I keep forgetting about this
move yeah this is the key resource
and even after Bishop takes you six
you're still playing E2 there's no
discovery
yeah
no this is over if you can't play Bishop
E8 then you can't defend the pawn and if
you can't defend the pawn
then the three on one should be very
very straightforward
yes sir important line because G6 will
be captured but that does not save the
day for Progress no that's what Parham
was calculating that's why he's been
spending so much time is he knows he's
winning so let's be accurate let's not
waste our opportunity and with a win
Haram will tie prognanda in the
standings and his tournament will be
very respectable and let's not forget
that para maxulu was a minute
replacement or yanches of Duda so he did
not have ample time to prepare he was
not spending weeks and weeks training
for this tournament he was just living
his life
having fun and then suddenly it's like
hey can you come to Vikings you need to
play against Magnus Carlson and he's
Geary nerdy back abusotarev and the rest
of the field
this reminds me of those stories of you
know basketball players or semi-retired
athletes who get a call from a team you
know we need a player can you come play
for us in three days and then they have
a you know a career performance so our
hom just minding his own business
playing some online Blitz all of a
sudden he gets a call from you know you
ruin Vandenberg the main organizer of
Tata steel arm we're in a bit of a tight
spot you come play Tata Steel in a week
it's not easy to just gather your bags
and go like you said I mean all these
other players they're spending weeks and
weeks preparing for each and every
opponent they know who they're playing
and uh this should not be discounted I I
very much respect arham's fighting
spirit in this tournament he shied away
from Quick draws and even though this
won't necessarily be a performance he
frames and tells his grandkids about
he performed very respectably indeed
it's a good showing it really is and
it's commendable and other people who
have been less minute Replacements and
have performed well include Maxine
Russia La Crosse at the candidates
tournament in 2020 and 2021 where he
entered the field after Timor rajava
withdrew and he led after the first half
with four and a half out of seven he
beat Jana palmchi who then went on to
win the second half and win the event so
um Aaron maksudu he is performing
admirably he is going to win this game
but if we zoom out Dania and if we look
at the game between our generic icy and
gukesh that
has happened the bishop coming out to A4
so we
predicted more or less the direction of
that game instead of playing an h-pawn
push in the bottom right hand side of
the screen
he has activated his bishop and his Rook
so don't actually think we might see a
repetition soon that's what I'm
predicting
you think some sort of King E3
but King E3 there is maybe the immediate
B3 let's bring up take a little bit of a
deeper dive
yeah actually I was thinking that there
would be that uh-huh I think we both
were thinking King E3 Rook C3 check King
back and so on but beat uh oh three was
available oh
sly little move King to E1
and now
the pawn on before actually cannot be
defended but you can give it away in
order to carve out a path for The Rook
to attack that extremely vulnerable Pawn
on H3 so I think likely we're gonna see
B3 correct me if I'm wrong Knight takes
B3 Rook H2
you could now
be careful here you could also take on
B3 if you want to force an immediate
draw and play Rook A2 afterwards so like
you just trade off the minor pieces play
Rook A2 when the A5 Pawn but I'm with
you this looks more challenging for
humor me how what exactly is how does
white Force the driver's white Hammer
this I guess Knight D2
yeah right Knight D2
take it and okay yeah Rook B6 or even a
barrage of checks probably does the
trick yeah I think just checking
is probably the simplest password don't
go 94.
do not blunder the fork
but I just think you can give a bunch of
checks here yeah the king cannot Escape
without giving away a bunch of Pawns so
that's one option the other one I was
mentioning is you could take on the
night in the current position and after
the Knight is captured oh a draw has
been agreed after Bishop takes B3
because you called five Pawn would have
been lost so you see the players talking
and they're going to analyze the game uh
these two youngsters from India hard
fought draw there
a hard-fought draw indeed and you can
see that crowd in the back Whispering
amongst themselves it's just great to
see classical chess receiving this level
of interest on my stream yesterday
Robert I had someone asking whether it
was worth making a six hour drive uh to
to watch a Tata steel round in progress
and just the fact that you know someone
would come up with that question already
speaks to the level of respect and awe
that chess fans hold these players in so
it's just amazing to see
and you could see the players there
setting up the pieces the discussion did
not last a long time they want to make
it to dinner
and they hard fought working man's straw
maybe they'll dine together the point
was split there was peace and these two
teenagers from India oh the tournament
hasn't been going the way they would
have wanted for Arjun he has not won a
single game
but he has been steady in others and for
gukesh he's lost many games but he also
happened to win a couple so he's been
maybe the most combative player in the
field along with Magnus Carlson so uh as
we see the results five games down five
draws in the books we have the game
between Magnus Carlsen and Wesley so
still ongoing that one is in an end game
and then prognanda with the white pieces
against baramaxulu it's been all Parham
for most of this game after they left
the opening and that's not good news for
the Indian fans out there they would
have loved to see Prague strike
while Prague is Living on a Prayer right
now he is still trying to muddy the
waters but unfortunately what really
reduces his chances to almost nil is is
the addition of 50 moves uh 50 minutes
on on move 40. it's just the fact that
Parham has as long as he needs to work
out the details
and uh as we take one more look at the
bird's eye view here you see those two
games over in the top right we've got
Magnus Carlson contemplating his next
move the Knight has jumped all around
the board it's currently on E2
and it's threatening to worm its way
back to F4 and hit that pawn on H3 I
think Magnus Carls have been saying this
for a long time Robert I think it maybe
it's time to start winding the game down
yeah and we can go right into that game
as Magnus he has the bishop against the
Knight of the night though it's jumpy
it's been hopping about the position so
and we see Magnuson screen there he is
thinking calculating he's still working
that's the best thing about Magnus is
games that we're like this is a draw
obviously it's a draw come on this point
just take the drugs take it just take it
but Magnus will always play it to the
very end and we see that he brought his
Bishop back to D2 stopping Knight F4 the
Knight can't hop into G1 but it's not
like white is scared to make the move H4
that's a move in many positions you'd
play anyway so for
Wesley here Knight G1 is an option but
Knight G3 check is also something to
consider because if the white king steps
back to D3 after Knight G3 check the
black king gets to go up to E5 oh
and E4 check is coming the Knight is not
going to be trapped I don't think
although wait a second
it should be one maybe there's h
a
ah
I'm struggling to make heads or tails of
this is so complicated H4 all of a
sudden
I guess H4 works yeah because Bishop
takes Knight
Pawn takes of course and you the king is
not in the squares there's a king E3 and
the average G5 the white King has to
retreat to E2 because the white H4 pawns
froze into place and then if the King
goes up to D4 though right if the King
goes I went first king D4 does white
have the move H4 that's the big question
the answer is no because once you take
it
also white black thing actually just
reaches is is still in the box but I had
a crazy idea here uh in the event of uh
Knight G3 checking D3 can D5 Bishop P1
H4 what if white makes a waiting move
along the lines of King to E3 I guess
black and repeat with Knight F1 Knight
G3 but my point is a broader one does
Wesley really want to enter these types
of complications this is not really in
his style so I feel like Wesley is
probably going to spend some time
searching for a a draw that contains a
broader margin of error if we can go
back to the position after Bishop D2
the current game position are there any
alternatives to the check on G3
yeah maybe just
move your king oh King D6 is gh5 and of
a knight G3 check is there that's
actually very clever oh
yeah that's KD6 just
Holding On And if white goes King D3
very sloppy black host Knight G1 and
you know
you start regretting everything
all of your life decisions you start
reconsidering so King D6 is an option
you know what else is an option I
actually think Knight G1 and then Knight
back to E2 is perfectly sufficient as
well I I don't see a single wafer white
to pose any threats here the bishop
can't get in contact with the E5 pawn
and so yeah I'm with you and can we just
go back to that Knight G3 check initial
line for a second I want to admit a
mistake in my calculation that after
Knight G3 I saw first of all King E3 is
met by Knight F1 check and I'm pretty
sure you could swap off the minor pieces
and if the King goes to D3 after King D5
Bishop E1 I was thinking that I'd E4
check because if you take F takes E4 the
Knight saves Itself by taking the pawn
we're trading our pieces it's going to
be a draw but King E3 is available and
wait somehow this still is equal
my goodness gracious I guess after King
E3
you're surprised the black doesn't lose
now let's think about this for a second
I'm not turning the engine on obviously
actually I see it wait wait don't say it
yet I think I see it just give me a
second there
oh Knight F1 Knight H2 exactly what are
we still might be hard
wait a second
oh and the Pawn's the wrong color yeah
wow
this is actually super cool Knight H2
now why can't hasten with King G2
because F3 hang so what has to take
first
oh but it's a moot point because
then I can actually move back to F3 I
was thinking that Knight takes G4 is the
elegant draw that's what I was gonna do
you know I love it when the bishop and I
know one don't match uh I don't know so
just to clarify for it from this
position all black does is run the king
to A8 and that's all you do like you
just put your king there and white can
make let's just show it we have time
let's show it so we do uh King G3 King
D5 King takes put the king in the corner
and we'll make all the moves for white
going over towards the a pawn you're
gonna win the a pawn that's you know the
great thing for you you get to take that
a pawn if you want it and after all is
said and done you still can't kick this
King out of the corner that's the
problem with the boundary is Bishop to
uh G3 check if the king when the King
goes to A8 if you don't leave this
configuration it is stalemate so
normally if you weren't on the last file
you would be able to play A7 and the
king would go to like whatever uh what's
before what's before a
stop it
um I don't got any Roman numeral
whatever eight
yeah and the king would be able to go
there and the white king would go up to
B7 but the King has no legal moves so it
is stale mate and that would be a draw
and people often ask me you know what is
my favorite thing about Chess well there
isn't just one thing but one of the
things I appreciate about the game that
we're watching is that even the most
basic configurations every time I look
at them I really I really feel the
beauty of them you know white has a
bishop and a pawn in 99.9 of cases an
extra bishop and a pawn is a Surefire
win and yet this is an exception because
of the specifics of the king placement
and the specifics of Chess geometry the
fact that A8 is a light Square white
cannot make any progress uh and cannot
smoke the black king out without causing
stalemate it's it's just cool I mean
even the most basic theoretical
positions in chess are really beautiful
if you think about them at an abstract
level
okay I don't know I was gonna say it's
one of those end game positions that you
need to know you need to memorize you
need to lock that in so that if you have
a game where you're worse and you're
like oh my knight might get trapped it's
okay to sacrifice your night for those
remaining pawns so you can make the draw
and
Knight G1 played up goes Wesley's Knight
to the other side of the board he's
attacking those pawns and Magnus will
have no choice but to push his own Pawn
to H4 here and he does
up goes magnus's pawn and down goes
Wesley's Knight back to E2 it goes
and they're gonna find some sort of a
repetition here might be a draw for
but at this point there is just nothing
left to play for well I mean black is
not worse here at this point you know
Black's not the one you know holding
from a position of weakness
oh Wesley has done everything he has
perfectly played his end game where it
there were some tricky moments he didn't
allow himself to get under any duress
and that's how Magnus often wins is you
start looking at your position and
you're like oh it looks shaky am I
holding and you start questioning
yourself and he makes you do that oh
Wesley so is a man on a mission he is
determined and he has beaten Magnus
Carlsen in that fisher random world
championship match that's a different
variant it's not your standard setup for
classical chess but the point is he took
down Magnus in a match when it was one
on one and that will build confidence so
Wesley has left the board I think we can
leave this board as well because the
game between Prague Nanda and
paramuksudu that one when we left it
we're thinking that it's just a matter
of time before the e-pawn runs and
prognanda is at the board he is
calculating uh but it does seem like
he's mainly looking at a situation where
it's when is it time to hit resign
exactly
yeah yeah it's uh currently only one
extra Pawn for black but obviously that
does not tell the whole story because a
second Pawn on F4 is falling but even
more important than that as we've
previously indicated Bishop E8 it comes
close to working but unfortunately that
epon slips through the cracks it goes
all the way to E2 and this construction
Bishop on D4 Rook on F2 is absolutely
deadly because it keeps the king
confined on H1 and you know the red
carpet is essentially unrolled for the
e-pawn and it's just a frustrating
frustrating stretch of the tournament
for Prague you can see how hard he tries
he puts everything out on every game but
how old is he 16
I think he is 18 of them I don't know
they're all they're all around the same
age I'll look it up while he's 17.
and we split the difference
I mean how many more Tata steals is he
gonna play how many more times
is he going to be flying into Amsterdam
and taking the train to that picturesque
Resort Seaside Town many many times he's
got such a bright future he's gonna hit
you know any second now
and he's definitely gaining rating from
this tournament as well so no reason to
be overly dejected if you're Prague and
of course he's got a chance to finish
strong uh in the last two rounds
it's not his day today it's not been
a good event in the second half for
Prague Nanda but he is such a talented
player he has beaten Magnus Carlson in
the Champions chess tour so we know that
he has what it takes to continue
ascending in the Chess World but we'll
leave him to this position as it's
likely coming to a conclusion soon we'll
take a quick break and when we come back
we'll see if para maxulu can end this
game in this favor
oh
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now right here almost there and you did
it
oh what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude idiot I
told you to bring it let's just go get
somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
back in the playing Hall in Vicente
pragnanda has just made his move his
sister by shali back there in the
distance playing in The Challengers
tournament and well we predicted that
the G6 Pawn would drop now probably not
trying to figure out is there a way to
stop this past Pawn on E3 if the Rook
comes to E6 slides behind the pawn it's
very simple E2 Rook F1 check E1 equals
Queen black will go up eight full Rook
so again it really feels like there's no
way to catch that pawn
no and you can't move your Bishop
because the king makes contact with the
Rook you have to move your Rook the only
other feasible square is G1 so maybe
it's worth trying Rook G1 and then after
E2 the benefit of putting your Rook on
the first rank is that Rook F1 no longer
comes with a check so perhaps Robert
Rook G1 E2 you could swing the bishop
back to P5 and Rook F1 in that position
doesn't actually work because the bishop
defends the F1 Square via the X-ray you
actually take on F1 and then you take
again once black promotes to the queen
so
frog and I'm looking up at his opponent
does Rook G1 offer any off chances or is
there a Crusher there well that's a
wonderful line I think we should show
what you were just mentioning that uh
first let's start with Rook E6 just to
show why this doesn't work we're saying
E2 it should be five to go after the
pawn and then Rook F1 is check the king
moves to the second rank you promote and
white has to give up The Rook that's
just a winning position or black so that
doesn't work but you made a really
instructive point about Rook G1 because
after E2
oh and we see him play virtue one after
E2 Bishop B5 Rook F1 is oh he plays E2
oh my God there's a CR oh
what's what are you see here
I think there's I think there's an
amazing tactic and I think you have to
find this there's Rook H2 check
oh
there's Rook H2 check
oh my gosh because if King takes Bishop
G1 is check so you can't take the pawn
and that means a queen will appear on E1
oh my gosh we're gonna see that we are
big I'll look at Parham he's played
Bishop B5 Rook H2 and resignation Parham
maxulu with a tactical shot to win an
impressive game he signed the score
sheet with emphasis and he takes down
prognanda
and you know what's crazy Robert Rook H2
might have been the only winning move
because if you play Bishop to C3 and say
I want to avoid the tricks you can see
the eval bar shooting all the way back
up why because white gives the bishop up
for Juan pun and then swings The Rook up
and wins the other Pawn there's no way
to defend F5 and as we know rook and
Bishop versus Rook is a drop so that's
actually what Parham was calculating all
the way back when he played move 48
Bishop D4 how freaking impressive is
that that's so ridiculous just to go a
half step back there as you were
pointing out earlier Rook F1 does not
work because the bishop eyes the F1
Square through the E2 Pawn so after Rook
to F1 white is able to capture that rook
and win the pawn and then you see it's
just a situation where all right even
end game Bishop's opposite color it's
going to be a draw so that is
unbelievable that he had to see Rook H2
check in this moment it's much easier
it's like yeah so it's happening on the
shoulder doing a puzzle okay you see
that but go back to 21 Bishop D4 down
yet
he had to see he had to see Rook H2 what
do you mean Rook H2 check in this
position that doesn't look like he does
anything but that is the power of Parham
maksudlu he is such a good tactician we
have seen him excel in the online rapid
and Blitz tournaments and he's proving
it in classical as well just one more
time let's go through those final moves
just because one more time so
instructive that he gives up his Rook on
H2 after pushing his Pawn all the way to
the second rank it seems like white is
just in time to stop the pawn Rook H2 is
wonderful
deflection and Discovery all rolled up
in one I love moves that can be labeled
with more than one tactical category
that's what really adds Beauty
deflection in the sense that you are
bringing the king onto a square such
that Bishop takes John as a check if it
wasn't a check white would have been
able to pick up E2 and obviously
removing the defender in the sense that
this enables the e-pawn to promote to a
queen but we have one more game that is
very likely to end uh shortly as well
what a game by Parham we congratulate
him warmly but let's switch back to our
last remaining game as the world
champion continues to squeeze and
squeeze and squeeze but Robert to no
avail and with every Pawn that
disappears from the board the likelihood
that Magnus finally acquiesces to the
draw increases exponentially
we all know of the night's tour the
mathematical geometric sequence here I
feel like we're seeing that in a live
game that night was just on G1 a little
while ago and how is this here already
it went night after E2 down to C1 up to
B3 and this has been what is required
for the draw if Bishop takes E5 white
wins a pawn only to drop this Pawn over
there on A5 and it's a simple trade of
Pawns and that is not what white wants
if you want to win the game so Magnus
can try F4 by pushing F4 if black is to
take the pawn F4 then the white king
takes back and goes to G5 and wins the
H5 Pawn sadly the still will be a draw
if you think of it from magnus's
perspective but it's the best you could
possibly hope for and you know what
black could try here and it's actually
not as easy as it appears all black
needs to do is give up the Knight for
the H4 Pawn so for example here Knight
C5 King G5 walks into a fork so white
has to waste the tempo moving the bishop
and okay Knight B3 it is a draw but if
black wants to be fancy uh what he can
do is give a check and then go hunting
for some H4 Pawn meet takes Knight G2
you don't care about anything else just
grab that pawn and as we previously
demonstrated this is a very well known
draw so that's possible but after RAV4
you could also throw in an intermediate
check on C5 uh if you wanted to avoid
that so at this point there are just so
many drawing lines the last thing I'll
point out Robert is that Bishop B4 is an
attempt to dominate The Knight and
prevent it from moving back to C5 five
but here the simplest I think is to play
Knight D4 looks like you're walking into
a little undermine trap with F4 but the
Knight can drop back to F5 counter
attacking the H4 pawn and only black can
win after IV Knight H4 so again Magnus
has to be prudent here
and I think he's going to find a way to
bail out yes there's F4
and he plays F4 and he's been looking
like a poker player he's playing with
the pieces as a poker player does with
chips uh all you know cards on the table
but it's clear that there's nothing more
this is a complete information game
Wesley so can calculate this as well as
anybody else on the planet so we see
that it is reduced material it is a draw
in Magnus he is probably going to be a
little bit upset that he couldn't get
more from this game the result is normal
it's Wesley so he doesn't lose very
often in this tournament he has won two
games and drawn the rest beating Wesley
just doesn't happen in classical chess
with any degree of regularity so Magnus
can be okay with that he can accept it
but what's probably going to bother him
is he just didn't have winning chances
from the start Wesley was able to fend
off any initiative or any hope of
initiative and I just really feel like
it went to the end game so early that
Wesley never struggled
and and frankly Magnus just hasn't had
all that much success on the white side
of an Enzo Indian obviously his most
famous most notorious game was that sink
filled cup Affair against uh Neiman
where he tried the G3 variation that
went into an end game pretty quick this
went into an end game pretty quickly so
Agnes is kind of coming up empty uh in
every Nimble he has tried so far in the
last couple of months and he's gonna
have one more game with the white pieces
maybe he'll switch uh switch approaches
and just play one E4 against Notre back
he got a good position with one C4 so
Magnus has been all around the map in
this tournament and he has two more
games if he is to have any chance at
finishing in the top two maybe even
winning the tournament he has to win
both of them and you know what's
fascinating Robert I love this part of
the tournament because we see players
taking so much risk I think we're gonna
see Magnus Carlson tomorrow taking
incredible amount of risk especially if
the opening against pragnananda does not
go his way but that is a game the
unconditionally expects himself to win
can you imagine anything worse in life
than losing a game with the white pieces
in what was a blowout to para maxulu and
then having to set up the next day and
play Black against Magnus Carlson
because that's probably not his task
I don't think anybody envies well a lot
of people do because they want to play
Magnus but I think from a competitive
standpoint it just sounds like a brutal
stretch and then the last game Magnus
gets black against Argent aragaisy
spoilers that's what's left for
prognanda and Arjun they're not playing
for first place but they can keep Magnus
out of first and so it's going to be up
to Magnus to come up with preparation
that gives him winning chances and this
game they just were none Wesley so
deserves a ton of credit and Wesley
himself has the same chance that Magnus
does to win the tournament but the
biggest difference is Wesley controls
his Destiny more and the reason why is
the next round
Wesley so plays against noribbeck
abdusitara oh man
I have no words I mean that game is
going to speak for itself
that is going to be a huge game Notre
break that's a second black in a row the
most brutal stretch of the tournament
for him today holding the draw from a
position of strength against the
nishikiri showcasing some phenomenal
opening preparation can he repeat that
success tomorrow I think Wesley so is
going to come armed to the teeth as
Magnus
you know running his hand through his
hair
staving off the inevitable this is a
draw Seven Ways to Sunday
and we see the leaderboard underneath
the player's cameras there we see that
Magnus and Wesley tied for third
entering the day they will finish tied
for third as well and somebody who's not
in the top seven but will play a major
role in determining who wins this
tournament is Jordan Vaughn Forest
Jordan he won this event in 2021 we are
two years removed from that but look at
his final oh look at his pairings he
gets white against nishikiri and then
black against no dear Beck Abdus Atari
he plays the people in first and second
place and if you are Magnus Carlson or
Wesley so you may say hey Jordan you
need some help preparing I got some good
lines for you please take those two down
absolutely and I think Jordan's gonna
have himself a fun time in the last two
rounds because he's obviously out of
contention he's having himself a pretty
decent event I don't think he's going to
go crazy trying to win these two games
but Jordan is perfectly aware that he
could enter the history books as someone
who as you're saying directly impacts
the final standings and I think he's
gonna Savor that opportunity I think
he's gonna come you know with some very
uncompromising chess in these last
surrounds as Wesley recaptures the pawn
on E5 you can pre-move knight G6 and
Knight takes H form I guess is that
Carlson is going to go King F4
or
he offers a draw right here and right
now what do you think of Wesley actually
pre-moved it like he grabbed his Knight
and moved to G6
that would be funny
oh gosh well Magnus go ahead and done it
no I I was just gonna say that I've done
stuff like that you know to lighten up
the atmosphere
um I remember resigning against avara
kobian and instead of residing I just
put a second Queen on the board and VAR
had that you know brief you know fight
or flight reaction like what just
happened and then of course I smiled and
extended my hand so occasional moments
of levity even in you know high-level
classical chess nothing wrong with that
I think
yeah it's fun too just especially when
you're losing a game uh it's fun to mix
it up a little bit change the ending uh
but for Wesley he's gonna be thrilled
drawing with the black pieces against
Magnus Carlson that's a huge achievement
something he's done before and likely
we'll do it again but considering the
stakes Magnus with three wins in his
previous four rounds and you see magnets
look up at Wesley because they might
need either a new score sheet or he's
just getting ready to draw nah not worth
it
I would offer a jar right here just so
you don't need to write out all of the
info on the new score sheet
there we go take that baby home Knight
takes H4
wow surprisingly Wesley knows his
theoretical end games can you believe it
shocking right absolutely mind-boggling
and how long are they gonna play this
position I'm just curious I I think
Magnus plays that the stalemate it's a
very Magnus thing to do he doesn't like
offering draws and especially if he has
more material why not get that King all
the way over to the A6 pawn and uh
wait what oh no that's a mistake no
let's just a lack of depth on the engine
uh I'm gonna pull up the tail base which
you can do yourself on chess.com events
the table base says draw so the engine
just had a brief moment freaked out for
a second but we were not phased nice try
nice try stop and the old the old
engines you know I remember looking with
Fritz four for its five they were so
myopic in their assessment of these
positions that they would give you know
plus nine plus 12 and you would keep
shuffling the pieces around and
obviously the reason that happened is
the old primitive engines just it they
weighted the material too much they
didn't have a formula built in for a
situation where a site can't make
progress that that concept is very hard
to quantify so of course modern engines
they have table bases built in and they
avoid that problem bear Kings on the
board and a handshake between these two
incredible players these two competitors
these two fighters and what a hold for
Wesley so it just didn't give the world
champion a chance
and Wesley takes the bishop on A5 but I
think if we look at the rules of chess
the bishop should still remain A5 I
don't think takes A5 is a move that was
played it doesn't matter because the
draw is uh the result but I just was
thinking about that for a second there
it's like in basketball when someone
fouls happen and someone takes a shot
after the whistle and then the person
one of the players jumps up and grabs
the ball you know to make sure it
doesn't go through the hoop don't let
jacus think he had an extra piece
yeah God forbid you know that's the
ultimate Alpha move Magnus ends the game
with an extra Bishop Wesley says no no
no I'm making one more move
and it's bear Kings and it's a draw and
the kings are in the middle of the board
facing each other
in an illegal configuration signal to
the official transmission that the game
has ended in peace
and so
as the players look at each other set up
the pieces a peaceful day here in uh
round 11 of Tata steal a peaceful day
but not for lack of trying and not for
lack of competition
no there was definitely Fighting Chess
in many of these games Vincent kymer for
example against Richard report that was
a game where there was material
imbalance but at the end it was a
standstill the players are shuffling
back and forth uh dingley ran against
Jordan Von Forest that wild opening
preparation by Jordan and then it just
came to a halt when dingley Wren played
accurately Anish Gary had an active King
in a double Knight end game it just
wasn't meant to be for him so he remains
a half point back and credit to
parhamaksulu you won't see him on the
top half of the leaderboard at least not
yet but he wins a game with the black
pieces unfortunate for prognanda and the
many Indian fans out there it was not
his day Dania he really just got caught
with his attention of the king side
while Parham scooped up material on the
queen side yeah Prague in the second
half of the tournament has been
struggling with some of these incredibly
complex positions especially when his
King
is in danger but today it was parham's
King who was in danger he got his King
out of danger and ultimately it was
prague's King who fell victim to a
beautiful tactic that capped off a fine
technical end game display by the
Iranian Grand Master as he scores the
only decisive game of the day it was all
balanced on the other Boar's notabeck
keeps his lead with a solid
well-prepared draw against Anish giri
anishikiri sits a half Point behind over
here back up to sitarov so for him he
will need some help his matchup against
Abdus the thing of the past he'll need
the likes of Jordan Von forest and
Wesley so to do him some favors but the
second half of the field through 11
rounds we see these players at minus
scores they are below 50 and dingley red
would be the most surprising name on the
list otherwise it's just a tough field
there are no easy games no free points
but as we look forward to tomorrow's
round 12 Donya I think the matchup of
the day is quite obvious look at the top
here honestly so take Sunday if Wesley
beats him he catches him in the
standings
ladies and gentlemen we are in for a
photo finish and what makes this game
even more spicy is the fact that I'm
expecting one E4 and I'm so curious what
noterbeck is going to bring to the table
with black because he did struggle in a
game against Arjun aragaisy and Wesley
so is one of the leading specialists in
the Italian and in the Rue Lopez from
the white side so that game is going to
be a barn burner as is of course Jordan
van Forest versus anishkira Anish
definitely has a chip on his shoulder
ever since he lost the tiebreaker in the
2021 Tata steel and remained the
runner-up for the fifth time he's gonna
try to write some wrongs in that game
and Magnus Carlson is going to bring
everything to the table in a game that
he has to win in order to stay relevant
and he gets the white piece he goes a
struggling a reeling prognanda so for
Magnus Carlsen today he couldn't get a
win but tomorrow is a good pairing All
Things Considered but Wesley so versus
norderbeck Abdul satar of will Wesley be
able to do what did he could not today
and for abusatar of a second day in a
row with the black pieces will he show
that Stellar preparation that allowed
him to hold quite comfortably today
against Curie those are the questions
for tomorrow but today action has come
to a conclusion it was another really
exciting round Dania it was a pleasure
to commentate with you we'll be back
tomorrow same time same place so for all
you who want more chess come back spend
your weekend with us because Tata steel
chest 2023 concludes this Sunday two
days from now see you then
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]